♪
>> WE'RE IN THE NATION'S CAPITOL
FOR TONIGHT'S YOUTUBE GAME OF
THE WEEK, THE SPOT WHERE THE
NATIONALS AND THE BLUE JAYS ARE
GETTING READY TO PLAY ONE OF A
TWO-GAME SET AT NATIONALS
BALLPARK.
TORONTO IS FOUR GAMES OUT OF THE
SECOND WILD CARD SPOT IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE.
VLAD JR. IS MAKING HIS CASE FOR
THE M.V.P.
AND THE NATIONALS ARE LOOKING TO
PLAY SPOILER WITH ONE OF THE
BRIGHTEST YOUNG STARS IN THE
GAME IN JUAN SOTO WHO, BELIEVE
IT OR NOT, HIS HOME RUN DERBY
PERFORMANCE ACTUALLY IMPROVED
HIS SWING.
I'M NOT SURE HOW THAT HAPPENED
BUT IT WAS FUN TO WATCH IN
DENVER.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK PREGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY
SPOTIFY.
I'M LAUREN GARDNER, AND MY
CO-HOST TODAY IS FIVE-TIME
ALL-STAR WHO SPENT FOUR SEASONS
PLAYING FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
HE WAS A WORLD SERIES CHAMPION
WITH THE 1995 BRAVES AND SMASHED
493 HOMERS OVER HIS AMAZING
19-YEAR CAREER.
OF COURSE, I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
MAN, THE MYTH, THE LEGEND, THE
CRIME DOG, FRED MCGRIFF.
I FELT LIKE I WAS A GAME SHOW
HOST, FRED.
HOW ARE YOU?
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
FRED: L.G. RED.
LAUREN: DID I MAKE IT AWKWARD?
WE GOT IT RIGHT.
IT'S AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU.
WE HAVE QUITE THE MATCHUP.
IT'S YOUR FORMER TEAM, YOU'RE A
LEGEND WITH THE BLUE JAYS.
SHOULD WE UNBOX THE MATCHUP?
FRED: LET'S DO IT.
LAUREN: JAYS-NATS, FIRST OF THE
TWO-GAME SERIES.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH THE
JAYS HERE IN THE RACE, JUST FOUR
GAMES BACK, THE SECOND WILD CARD
SPOT.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS HERE AND
DO YOU THINK THEY CAN MAKE A
PUSH IN A VERY TOUGH DIVISION?
FRED: IT'S VERY TOUGH.
THEY'RE HAVING A GOOD YEAR.
NINE GAMES OVER .500 IS
IMPRESSIVE.
THE ONLY THING, THE RED SOX AND
THE RAYS HAVE HAD GREAT SEASONS
SO IT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH.
THEY'VE GOT THEIR WORK CUT OUT
BUT STILL HAVE A CHANCE FOR THE
WILD CARD.
IT'S UP TO THEIR PITCHING.
YOU HAVE ALEK MANOAH TONIGHT BUT
THOSE GUYS HAVE TO BE SHUT-DOWN
AND GIVE THIS TEAM A CHANCE TO
WIN.
BECAUSE OFFENSIVELY, THE BLUE
JAYS CAN SWING THE BAT.
LAUREN: YES.
FRED: SO IF THEIR PITCHING HOLDS
UP, THEY HAVE A CHANCE.
BECAUSE THE RED SOX HAVE BEEN
SO-SO IN THE SECOND HALF.
BUT I'M A LITTLE WORRIED ABOUT
THE YANKEES BECAUSE THE TRADE
THE YANKEES MADE TO PICK UP
RIZZO AND GALLO, IT'S CHANGED
THE DYNAMIC OF THAT TEAM.
I'M A BIG FAN OF HAVING A LEFTY
POWER HITTER IN THE LINEUP AND
FOR MOST OF THE YEAR, THE
YANKEES STRUGGLED.
YOU GOT STANTON AND JUDGE FROM
THE RIGHT SIDE.
THEY REALLY DIDN'T HAVE THE BIG
POWER LEFT-HANDED BAT AND NOW
YOU ADD RIZZO AND GALLO SO, THE
JAYS HAVE THEIR WORK CUT OUT.
LAUREN: WE TALKED ABOUT WHAT THE
LOS ANGELES DODGERS WERE ABLE TO
DO AT THE DEADLINE.
YOU TALK ABOUT HOW THE RICH KEEP
GETTING RICHER BUT THAT ALSO
HAPPENED IN THE EAST COAST WITH
THE NEW YORK YANKEES.
THE TWO POWER LEFTIES.
ANTHONY RIZZO MADE HIS PRESENCE
KNOWN, RIGHT AWAY, HIS FIRST
COUPLE OF GAMES, ENDEARED
HIMSELF TO THE FANS.
YOU'RE RIGHT, EVERYONE BE ON
WATCH FOR THE NEW YORK YANKEES
BUT TORONTO HAS THAT NICE YOUNG
CORE.
THEY WERE REPRESENTING AT THE
ALL-STAR GAME IN DENVER,
COLORADO, CRIME DOG.
IT WAS A LOT OF FUN TO WATCH
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU SEE WHAT
VLAD JR. WAS ABLE TO DO, NAMED
THE YOUNGEST ALL-STAR M.V.P. IN
THE HISTORY OF BASEBALL.
BUT GREAT YOUNG NAMES IN THE
LINEUP.
FRED: BIGGIO AND BICHETTE.
THOSE KIDS ARE AGGRESSIVE, THEY
GO UP THERE SWINGING THE BAT AND
BICHETTE, I'VE WATCHED HIM WHEN
HE WAS YOUNG.
HE'S COME SUCH A LONG WAYS.
BIGGIO, A GOOD PLAYER FOLLOWING
IN HIS DAD'S FOOTSTEPS.
AND THEN VLAD.
VLAD HAS BEEN AWESOME.
AND I LOVE THAT LAST YEAR AT
THIS TIME THE BLUE JAYS WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT HIS WEIGHT, HAD
HIM D.H.'ING MOST OF THE TIME
BUT THIS OFFSEASON HE LOST
WEIGHT AND SUDDENLY HE'S A YOUNG
STUD, 314 AVERAGE,,35 HOME RUNS
AND NOW HE'S BEEN PLAYING FIRST
BASE EVERY NIGHT.
LAUREN: HE LOOKS SOLID FOR THEM.
40 POUNDS IN TOTAL.
I KNOW HE WORKED REALLY HARD IN
THE OFFSEASON.
FRED: JUST SAYING.
LAUREN: YOU NEED TO BE MORE
MOBILE AND LIVING UP TO HIS
POTENTIAL BECAUSE HE WAS PART OF
THAT DRAFT CLASS OR CAME UP WITH
FERNANDO TATIS JR. WHO WAS A
STAR IN THE MAKING FROM JUMP.
SO I THINK HE PROBABLY FELT SOME
OF THAT PRESSURE, AS WELL.
SO IT'S REALLY INTERESTING, ON
THE BUMP TONIGHT FOR THE BLUE
JAYS IT'S ALEK MANOAH.
ARGUABLY ONE OF THE BEST ROOKIE
PITCHERS IN THE GAME.
FRED: WITHOUT A DOUBT.
HE COMES RIGHT AT THE HITTERS.
I'VE BEEN WATCHING HIM.
HE'S NOT SCARED.
HE'S COMING RIGHT AT THEM WITH
FASTBALLS, THROWING STRIKES.
HE'S ON A MISSION, FOR A YOUNG
KID, I MEAN, YOU GOT TO LOVE
HIM.
LAUREN: IT'S DEFINITELY THAT
CONFIDENCE YOU LOOK FOR AND IT
SEEMS LIKE THIS TEAM -- YOU CAN
ATTEST TO THIS, HAS THAT
CONFIDENCE.
THEY'RE OUT THERE HAVING A GOOD
TIME AND YOU SEE ALL THESE TEAMS
HAVING THOSE HOME RUN
CELEBRATIONS.
THEY HAVE THE JACKET.
IT SEEMS THAT ENERGY COULD
PROPEL THEM TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
FRED: WITHOUT A DOUBT.
SIX WEEKS LEFT IN THE SEASON.
GO HARD, GO AS HARD AS YOU CAN.
IT'S HELPING THESE KIDS GET
EXPERIENCE SO NEXT YEAR, IN THE
OFFSEASON, IF THEY MAKE A FEW
MORE MOVES WITH THEIR PITCHING
STAFF, THEY'LL BE VERY TOUGH.
LAUREN: IN A VERY TOUGH
DIVISION.
ON THE FLIPSIDE, THE NATS ARE IN
A TOUGH DIVISION THEMSELVES.
WE DIDN'T KNOW PEOPLE WERE
EXPECTING THEY MIGHT HAVE A
BOUNCE-BACK YEAR AFTER WINNING
IN 2019, DOWN YEAR IN THE COVID
SEASON.
BUT THE NATS SOLD OFF A LOT OF
PLAYERS, SEVEN ALL-STARS AT THE
DEADLINE OVER THE COURSE OF TWO
DAYS.
BUT THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO PLAY
SPOILER.
FRED: IT'S A BEAUTIFUL THING.
I'VE BEEN IN THIS SITUATION.
YOU SET GOALS GOING INTO THE
YEAR SO THIS LAST SIX WEEKS, YOU
STILL GOT YOUR GOALS.
BUT YOU WANT THESE OTHER TEAMS
TO GO HOME, YOU WANT THEM
GOLFING AND FISHING YOU WITH.
SO METS AND REDS AND BRAVES,
THEY'VE GOT TO BE HEADS-UP
BECAUSE THE NATS ARE ON A
MISSION AND YOU GOT THE YOUNG
KIDS, CARTER KIEBOOM'S, ROBLES',
IT'S TIME FOR THEM TO STEP UP
AND SHOW THE NATS THEY CAN PLAY
BUT IT'S ALL ABOUT, HEY, I WANT
YOU ON THE GOLF COURSE WITH ME
AND FISHING.
SO --
LAUREN: I LOVE THAT!
FRED: I'M GOING TO BEAT UP ON
YOU.
LAUREN: YOU JUST WANT COMPANY
OUT THERE.
THOSE ARE GREAT ACTIVITIES TO BE
ENGAGED IN.
YOU TALKED ABOUT CARTER KIEBOOM
AND VICTOR ROBLES.
LET'S TALK ABOUT JUAN SOTO.
22 YEARS OLD, AN ABSOLUTE STAR
IN THIS LEAGUE AND IT SEEMS LIKE
THIS IS HIS TEAM AT THIS POINT.
FRED: I LOVE HIM.
HE'S OUTSTANDING.
HE KNOWS HOW TO PLAY THE GAME.
GROWING UP IN DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC, SO HE'S BEEN AROUND
BASEBALL ALL HIS LIFE.
BUT HE HAS HUGE POWER.
I WATCH HIM ALL THE TIME AND HIS
OPPO POWER IS UNBELIEVABLE.
EVERY TIME -- HE'S GOING OPPO.
WHEN I WOULD TRY TO HIT A BALL
OPPOSITE FIELD, I HAD TO REALLY
HIT IT.
I PROBABLY WOULD HIT FIVE OR SIX
HOME RUNS TO OPPOSITE FIELD.
BUT SOTO, EVERY TIME YOU LOOK
AROUND, HE'S GOING OPPOSITE
FIELD.
HIS LAST -- SINCE 2018, HE'S
BEEN KILLING IT, OPPOSITE FIELD.
AND RONALD ACUNA HITS OPPOSITE
FIELD HIMSELF BUT SOTO -- IT'S
IMPRESSIVE BECAUSE TO HIT A BALL
TO THE OPPOSITE FIELD, IT'S
OUTSTANDING.
AND THEN, HIS EYE.
HE TAKES SOME AWFULLY CLOSE
PITCHES.
I WONDER IF HE'S TIPPING THE
UMPIRES OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
LOOK AT THESE PITCHES HE'S
GETTING, AND THE UMPIRES ARE
CALLING THEM BALLS.
THEY'RE CLOSE TO BEING STRIKES.
LAUREN: REAL CLOSE.
FRED: YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
HIS CHASE RATE AT THE END OF THE
DAY IS UNBELIEVABLE.
13.3, THE LOWEST IN ALL OF
BASEBALL.
SO IF HE DOESN'T SWING, IT'S A
BALL.
AND IT'S JUST GREAT HOW HE USES
THE SPREAD STANCE AND SO THAT
HELPS HIM JUST SEE THE BALL VERY
WELL.
HE'S NOT -- HE'S JUST PRETTY
SIMPLE, HE PICKS HIS FOOT UP AND
PUTS IT DOWN AND THEN BAM, HE'S
SWINGING AND HE HAS SUCH A GREAT
EYE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE AT THE AGE OF
22, TO BE THAT GOOD.
LAUREN: THE AGE OF 22, TO HAVE
THAT MUCH DISCIPLINE AT THE
PLATE, I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
WERE DOING AT 22.
I WAS STILL EATING SKITTLES FOR
BREAKFAST.
FRED: I WAS SWINGING AT BALLS IN
THE DIRT.
LAUREN: I DON'T KNOW HOW HE'S
ABLE TO DO IT BUT YOU SEE WHAT
HE'S DOING.
HIGHEST O.P.S. THROUGH AGE 22
SEASON.
PRETTY GOOD COMPANY TO BE WITH
TED WILLIAMS AT THE TOP.
FRED: NOT BAD.
LAUREN: NOT AT ALL.
IT'S TIME TO GET TO THE OUR POLL
QUESTION OF THE DAY AND THIS IS
A HARD HITTING ONE.
IT'S BASICALLY WHO IS GOING TO
WIN TONIGHT'S GAME?
BLUE JAYS-NATS, HIT US UP, THE
PITCHING MATCHUP, ALEK MANOAH
WITH 2.59 E.R.A. IN 59 INNINGS
PITCHED AND ERICK FEDDE WITH A
5.12 E.R.A. IN 91.1 INNINGS
PITCHED.
WHEN WE COME BACK, ROBBIE RAY
WILL JOIN US AND WE'LL HAVE MORE
ON THE YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK
PREGAME SHOW.
FRED MCGRIFF, LAUREN GARDNER
WITH YOU.
>> STOP MADE BY ESPINAL, POPPED
UP, THROWS TO FIRST.
DIGGED BY VLADI TO GET THE OUT.
>> SHARP ONE-HOPPER TO SHORT.
BICHETTE, WHAT A PLAY AND
STRETCH BY GUERRERO AT THE END.
WHAT A PLAY BY BO BICHETTE TO
RETIRE JACK MAYFIELD.
SPRINGER LIFTS ONE, THIS BALL IS
WELL STRUCK AND IT'S GONE, AS
WELL.
NUMBER 15 ON THE SEASON FOR
SPRINGER AND IT IS 2-0, BLUE
JAYS.
SPRINGER TURNS ON ANOTHER ONE
AND THIS WILL BE HIS SECOND HOME
RUN OF THE NIGHT.
>> HE THROWS AND THE PITCH IS
SLUGGED IN THE AIR, STRAIGHTAWAY
CENTER FIELD.
SPRINGER BACK THROUGH THE TRACK,
AT THE WALL AND MAKES THE CATCH!
GEORGE SPRINGER WITH A LEAPING
GRAB AT THE WALL IN STRAIGHTAWAY
CENTER FIELD!
HE ROBS TORREYES OF EXTRA BASES.
>> DEEP AND A GRAND SLAM FOR
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ, THE FIRST OF
HIS MAJOR LEAGUE CAREER AND THE
BLUE JAYS LEAD 7-2.
LAUREN: WELCOME BACK TO MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY SPOTIFY, EXCLUSIVE
HOME OF THE JOE ROGAN
EXPERIENCE.
WATCH ALL NEW EPISODES FOR FREE
ONLY ON SPOTIFY.
WE LOOK AT THE 2021 E.R.A.
LEADERS IN THE A.L.
ROBBIE RAY SANDWICHED BETWEEN
TWO ALL-STARS.
PRETTY GOOD E.R.A. IF YOU'RE
INTO THAT, WITH A 2.88.
WE WELCOME IN THE LEFTY STARTER
FROM THE NATION'S CAPITAL.
ROBBIE, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE IN THE
CONVERSATION FOR THE CY YOUNG
THIS SEASON.
WHEN YOU HEAR THAT, HOW DOES
THAT MAKE YOU FEEL IN YOUR
EIGHTH SEASON IN THE BIGS?
ROBBIE: IT DEFINITELY FEELS LIKE
HARD WORK STARTING TO PAY OFF.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD NAMES ON
THAT LIST.
LANCE LYNN IS HAVING A GREAT
YEAR.
GERRIT COLE IS DOING WHAT HE'S
ALWAYS DONE.
JUST TO BE IN THE CONVERSATION
WITH THOSE GUYS IS VERY
HUMBLING, FOR SURE.
FRED: I KNOW IT'S TOUGH, YOU
CAN'T GIVE AWAY YOUR SECRETS.
BUT CHANGING LEAGUES, GOING FROM
NATIONALLY TO AMERICAN LEAGUE,
WHAT ADJUSTMENTS HAVE YOU HAD TO
MAKE?
ROBBIE: YOU'RE NO LONGER FACING
THE PITCHER IN THE NINE HOLE SO
INSTEAD OF FACING PATRICK
CORBIN, YOU'RE FACING J.D.
MARTÍNEZ SO IT'S A LITTLE MORE
STRATEGY INVOLVED IN THAT ASPECT
BUT IT'S GREAT.
I LOVE THE COMPETITION.
I LOVE COMPETING EVERY DAY AND
WOULDN'T WANT TO BE ANYWHERE
ELSE BUT THE A.L. EAST.
LAUREN: YOU SEEM UP TO THE TASK.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE ADJUSTMENT
THIS SEASON.
YOU'VE PLAYED IN THREE DIFFERENT
HOME PARKS.
YOU'RE NOW BACK IN TORONTO.
WHAT HAS THIS ROLLERCOASTER BEEN
LIKE FOR THE CLUB?
ROBBIE: IT'S BEEN WEIRD.
DEFINITELY A WEIRD SEASON,
STARTING THE YEAR IN DUNEDIN,
MOVING TO BUFFALO -- TWO OF
ARGUABLY THE BEST HITTERS' PARKS
IN BASEBALL AND GOING TO
TORONTO.
IT'S BEEN GREAT.
WE HAVE GREAT FANS THERE.
THEY'VE BEEN SHOWING OUT FOR US.
WE HAD A GREAT HOMECOMING, GREAT
SERIES AT HOME.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
STAYING THERE AND BEING IN
TORONTO.
FRED: ROBBIE, I KNOW IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL THING, YOU WENT FROM
THE DIAMONDBACKS OFFENSIVELY
WERE JUST OK, TO NOW, YOU'VE GOT
THE STUDS, YOUNG KIDS, GUERRERO,
BICHETTE, BIGGIO -- HOW IS
PITCHING BEHIND THOSE GUYS?
ROBBIE: IT'S GREAT.
YOU KNOW EVERY NIGHT THEY'RE
GOING TO COME OUT AND PUT UP BIG
NUMBERS.
IT'S BEEN A LOT OF FUN TO WATCH
VLADI THIS YEAR DOING WHAT HE'S
DOING, MAKING A CASE FOR M.V.P.
AND BO IS DOING BO.
WE HAVE MARCUS SEMIEN, AS WELL,
QUIETLY PUTTING TOGETHER AN
M.V.P. SEASON, AS WELL.
AND WE GET GEORGE SPRINGER, WHAT
HE DOES TO A LINEUP IS SPECIAL,
AS WELL.
IT'S BEEN REALLY FUN TO WATCH.
LAUREN: IT'S A FUN YOUNG GROUP.
I WAS ABLE TO SPEND A LITTLE BIT
OF TIME WITH THEM IN DENVER FOR
ALL-STAR WEEK.
LOVE THE HOME RUN JACKET, LOVE
ALL OF IT.
I DID SOME DIGGING ON YOUR
SOCIAL MEDIA.
TOOK ME A MINUTE.
NASHVILLE GUY, YOU'RE BIG INTO
COUNTRY MUSIC.
YOU MET YOUR WIFE, TAYLOR, WHO
IS A SINGER.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT STORY AND
WHAT BANDS ARE YOU INTO?
ROBBIE: I PRETTY MUCH LISTEN TO
ANYTHING COUNTRY MUSIC BUT WE
MET IN NASHVILLE THROUGH A
MUTUAL FRIEND.
LOVED HER FROM THE DAY I MET HER
AND SHE'S BEEN AWESOME, SOLID.
WE HAVE THREE KIDS AT HOME.
DURING THIS TRANSITION PERIOD,
GOING TO THREE DIFFERENT
STADIUMS, SHE'S BEEN THE ONE
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN THERE WITH
THE KIDS.
SHE'S BEEN SOLID THIS YEAR, AS
WELL.
I WANT TO THANK HER.
FRAN: I'M CURIOUS, IN THIS DAY
AND AGE WITH ALL THE NUMBERS AND
ANALYTICS, I KNOW AS A HITTER,
MYSELF, I WAS ALWAYS LOOKING TO
SEE PITCHERS, STRIKES PER
INNINGS, WALKS -- STUFF LIKE
THAT.
SO NOWADAYS THEY'RE FEEDING YOU
A LOT OF NUMBERS EVERY WEEK
BEFORE YOUR START.
WHAT NUMBERS DO YOU KEY ON
AGAINST OPPOSING BATTERS?
ROBBIE: FOR ME IT'S -- I TRY TO
PITCH WITH MY STRENGTHS.
REGARDLESS OF THE LINEUP, I TRY
TO ALWAYS PITCH TO MY STRENGTHS
AND I FELT LIKE THAT'S SOMETHING
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO BETTER THIS
YEAR.
NOT NECESSARILY PITCHING AWAY
FROM WHAT THE HITTER'S STRENGTHS
ARE BUT PITCHING MORE TO MY
STRENGTHS AND I FEEL THAT'S
HELPED ME BE SUCCESSFUL THIS
YEAR.
LAUREN: IT'S DEFINITELY PAYING
OFF AS WE LOOK AT YOUR TEAM AND
WHAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
THIS SEASON, MAKING YOUR WAY UP
THE STANDINGS.
MAKE YOUR CASE FOR THE TORONTO
BLUE JAYS TO REACH THE
POSTSEASON?
ROBBIE: WE'RE A YOUNG TEAM.
OUR PITCHING AND HITTING IS
COMING AROUND.
WE'RE STARTING TO CLICK ON ALL
CYLINDERS, PITCHING AND HITTING
AT THE SAME TIME WHEREAS EARLIER
IN THE YEAR WE WERE STRUGGLING
TO FIND THAT.
I FEEL LIKE EVERYTHING'S COMING
TOGETHER.
I FEEL WE HAVE A FAVORABLE
SCHEDULE DOWN THE STRETCH.
LAUREN: ROUND OF APPLAUSE, I
FEEL LIKE THAT'S A SOLID CASE.
ROBBIE, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
BEST OF LUCK DOWN THE STRETCH.
ROBBIE: THANK YOU.
TIME FOR OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT,
SPOTLIGHTING ENIK WESTOVER.
FAVORITE MOMENT, TRAVIS
ISHIKAWA'S WALK-OFF BOMB TO WIN
GAME FIVE OF THE 2014 NLCS
AGAINST THE CARDS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
LET'S CIRCLE BACK TO THE GIANTS
FANDOM BECAUSE WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS BEFORE WE GOT
STARTED.
ARE YOU SURPRISED THAT THIS TEAM
HAS THE BEST RECORD IN BASEBALL
AND DO YOU THINK THEY HAVE THE
STAYING POWER TO WIN THE THE
DIVISION?
>> I'M SHOCKED.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE SHARE
THAT THOUGHT WITH ME.
AS FOR WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE
THE STAYING POWER TO BE IN FIRST
PLACE, WHEN ALL IS SAID AND
DONE, I THINK THE GIANTS CAN BE
ASKING THEMSELVES THE SAME
QUESTION EVERY CONTENDER IS
ASKING THEMSELVES, DOES OUR
PITCHING HAVE ENOUGH GAS IN THE
TANK TO GET US DOWN THE STRETCH
AND THROUGH THE POSTSEASON.
I THINK THE GIANTS HAVE A SHOT.
THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF GUYS OUT
LET IT TO PROVE THEMSELVES IN
THE FORM OF ALEX WOOD, KEVIN
GASMAN AND ANTHONY DE SCLAFANI.
LAUREN: ESPECIALLY ON THE HEELS
OF THE ABBREVIATED SEASON, IT'S
GOING TO BE WHOSE BULLPEN LASTS
THE LONGEST SO THE GIANTS'
CLOSEST COMPETITOR IN THE
DIVISION TITLE ARE THE L.A.
DODGERS.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION WHEN THEY
GOT TREA TURNER AND MAX
SCHERZER?
>> RIDICULOUS.
IN THE MOMENT YOU'RE THINKING,
HOW IS THAT EVEN FAIR?
AT THE SAME TIME YOU HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT THE
DODGERS PUT THEMSELVES IN THIS
POSITION THEMSELVES BY COMPETING
AT A HIGH LEVEL IN THE MAJOR
LEAGUES WHILE ALSO DEVELOPING
THAT TALENT DOWN THE FARM TO GET
THEM THE PIECES LIKE MAX
SCHERZER AND TREA TURNER FOR
THAT PUSH DOWN THE STRETCH.
SO AS GIANTS FAN, IT'S EASY TO
BE MAD BUT YOU CAN'T HELP BUT
RESPECT THE DODGERS AND THE WORK
THEY'VE DONE.
LAUREN: IT'S HARD TO KNOCK
SUCCESS AND HELPS WITH THE
PAYROLL.
YOUR TEAM PLAYS THE METS
TONIGHT.
WE MIGHT AS WELL GET YOUR
THOUGHTS, IN THE N.L. EAST, WHO
DO YOU THINK IS COMING OUT ON
TOP?
>> THE N.L. EAST IS KIND OF
WACKY WHEN YOU BREAK IT DOWN.
YOU HAVE THE PHILLIES THAT CAN
FIND A WAY TO PUT RUNS ON THE
BOARD.
BUT THEIR PITCHING IS IFFY IN
SPOTS AND THAT'S THE SAME CASE
FOR THE BRAVES.
YOU CAN'T HANG YOUR HAT ON THE
BRAVES PITCHING STAFF BUT YOU
KNOW THEY'LL FIND A WAY TO PUT
UP RUNS.
THE METS, THE INTERESTING THING,
ON PAPER, THEY LOOK LIKE THEY
CAN FIRE ON ALL CYLINDERS
OFFENSIVELY AND DEFENSIVELY BUT
THE OFFENSE HAS NOT BEEN
CLICKING.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE GOING INTO
THE GAME, SWINGING WITHOUT A
PLAN, HOPING FOR SOMETHING TO
FALL THEIR WAY.
ON PAPER, ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IT
FIND A WAY TO MAKE IT CLICK AND
I THINK THE METS ARE THE
FAVORITE A GAME AND A HALF OUT.
LAUREN: I HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS
WHO ARE METS FANS AND IT'S NOT
GOOD FOR YOUR HEART.
IT'S REALLY TOUGH BEING A METS
FAN THE PAST 30 YEARS.
WHO DO YOU THINK WILL BE THE
FAVORITE TO WIN N.L. M.V.P.?
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO COME
DOWN TO WHETHER OR NOT JACOB
DEGROM WILL RETURN FOR THE FINAL
MONTH IN SEPTEMBER.
I THINK IF HE DOES COME BACK,
HE'LL LEAD THE CHARGE IN THE
PITCHING STAFF AND WILL SETTLE
DOWN.
IF HE DOESN'T COME BACK, IT'S A
TOSS-UP BETWEEN THE PHILLIES AND
THE BRAVES.
LAUREN: THAT'S A GOOD CHOICE,
ENOCH, WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
WE'LL CHECK OUT YOUR CHANNEL.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
LAUREN: MORE TO COME ON THE
YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME
SHOW AS VLAD JR. GETS READY FOR
THE FIRST OF A TWO-GAME SET
BETWEEN THE JAYS ANDONTO, SPOILR
ALERT, NOT GOOD NEWS.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> VICTOR ROBLES HITS ONE IN THE
AIR TO DEEP LEFT FIELD MOVING
DOMINIC SMITH, HAS THE PLAY AT
THE WARNING TRACK AND MISSED THE
BALL UP AGAINST THE WALL SO
ROUNDING THIRD IS RILEY ADAMS,
AND THE THROW WILL NOT BE IN
TIME.
>> CENTER FIELD, THAT BALL'S ON
THE GROUND.
SKIPPING DEEP INTO THE GAP.
ROBLES HOME, ESCOBAR TO THIRD.
SOTO DELIVERS R.B.I. NUMBER 62
AND THE NATS ARE ON TOP.
WELL HIT, SWINGING TO HIS RIGHT,
GARCIA, QUICK EXCHANGE WITH THE
HANDS.
>> NICE PLAY.
HE'S THE MASTER OF THE
SLIDE-ON-ONE-KNEE PLAY, ISN'T
HE?
>> THAT BALL HIT HARD UP THE
MIDDLE.
ESCOBAR, NICE GRAB, SHOVELS TO
GARCIA.
HOW ABOUT THAT FOR A 6-4-3.
>> WOW.
>> THAT'S ONE OF THE BEST DOUBLE
PLAYS OF THE YEAR.
>> THAT BALL DRIVEN OUT TO LEFT
CENTER.
SEE YOU LATER!
JUAN SOTO, A LINE DRIVE, THE
BALLPARK COULDN'T HOLD IT.
HE'S UP TO 61 R.B.I.'S AND HIS
19TH PUTS THE NATS ON TOP.
LAUREN: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY SPOTIFY, EXCLUSIVE
HOME OF THE JOE ROGAN
EXPERIENCE.
WATCH ALL NEW EPISODES FOR FREE
ONLY ON SPOTIFY.
LAUREN GARDNER, FRED MCGRIFF
WITH YOU AS WE BREAK DOWN THE
WASHINGTON NATIONALS STARTING
LINEUP.
VICTOR ROBLES IN THE ONE SPOT.
JUAN SOTO, THREE SPOT.
AND, OF COURSE, JOSH BELL IN AT
NUMBER FOUR HITTING CLEANUP.
CRIME DOG, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON WHAT JOSH BELL'S
BEEN ABLE TO DO FOR THIS TEAM?
FRED: HANGING TOUGH.
HE GOT OFF TO A SLOW START BUT
THE LAST MONTH OR SO, SWINGING
THE BAT BETTER.
HE WAS A HUGE ADDITION IN THE
OFFSEASON.
I WAS LIKE, MAN, THEY GOT JOSH
BELL AND KYLE SCHWARBER.
EARLIER THEY STRUGGLED BUT HE'S
BEEN DOING A GOOD JOB.
LAUREN: CARTER KIEBOOM HITTING
.234 IN AUGUST.
WE LOOK AT THE BLUE JAYS
STARTING LINEUP AND WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THE YOUNG GUYS.
OF COURSE, MARCUS SEMIEN COMING
OVER FROM THE A'S IN FREE
AGENCY, HAS BEEN A HUGE PIECE OF
THIS PUZZLE AND A LEADER IN THAT
CLUBHOUSE.
FRED: ANOTHER GREAT PICKUP AND
HE MOVED TO SECOND BASE.
THAT'S NOT EASY PLAYING
SHORTSTOP WITH THE OAKLAND A'S,
NOW PLAYING SECOND.
THAT HAD TO BE A BIG ADJUSTMENT.
HUGE YEAR.
LAUREN: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
I NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
TRANSITION AND GOING FROM SHORT
TO THIRD, MUCH EASIER.
WHEN YOU PUT IT ON THE FLIPSIDE,
MUCH ARE -- MORE DIFFICULT.
THE BLUE JAYS LINEUP WAS WITHOUT
GEORGE SPRINGER, PLACED ON I.L.
THIS AFTERNOON, RETROACTIVE TO
MONDAY.
THE JAYS CENTER FIELDER LEFT THE
GAME SATURDAY NIGHT AGAINST THE
MARINERS IN WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY
CALLED AN ANKLE SPRAIN BUT
EVALUATION SHOWED IT WAS HIS
KNEE.
THERE IS NO TIME TABLE ON HIS
RETURN SO THE MAN THE JAYS GAVE
$150 MILLION TO THIS OFFSEASON
HAS ONLY PLAYED IN 49 GAMES FOR
TORONTO.
BUT HAS BEEN IMPACTFUL IN THOSE
GAMES WITH 16 HOMERS AND 35
R.B.I., O.P.S. OF .972.
SO, FRED, THE BLUE JAYS HAVE
DEALT WITH THE LOSS OF SPRINGER
EARLIER THIS SEASON SO WITH
EVERY GAME SO IMPORTANT DOWN THE
STRETCH, DO YOU THINK THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO DO IT WITHOUT HIM AGAIN?
FRED: THEY HAVE NO CHOICE.
THEY'RE USED TO IT NOW.
HE'S MISSED A LOT OF GAMES!
IT'S BEEN CRAZY, STARTING THE
YEAR OFF WITH HIS QUAD.
AND THEN NOW HIS ANKLE.
HE PLAYS HARD BUT SOMETIMES HE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO PLAY SMART
BECAUSE WE NEED YOU ON THE
FIELD.
WHEN HE PLAYS ON THE FIELD, HE
HAS 16 HOME RUNS ON THE YEAR AND
HE'S BARELY PLAYING.
NEXT YEAR WE HAVE TO KEEP HIM ON
THE FIELD.
LAUREN: THAT WAS A GOOD VETERAN
CRIME DOG PEP TALK.
OK, MAN, WE LOVE YOU BUT DIAL IT
BACK A LITTLE BIT.
FRED: I'D RATHER HAVE YOU
HEALTHY FOR 150 GAMES THAN
TRYING TO STEAL BASES, BREAKING
YOUR FINGER, THIS AND THAT, YOUR
QUAD AND THEN SITTING ON THE
SIDELINES, COME ON, MAN.
LAUREN: I WANT TO SEE YOUR PICKS
TO CLICK.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THE PREGAME SHOW
IS FLYING BY SO QUICKLY.
WE'RE GOING TO GET STARTED HERE.
VLAD JR., A.L. M.V.P., IF HE
WINS THE TRIPLE CROWN, IS HE THE
FAVORITE?
CAN HE BEAT OUT SHOHEI OHTANI?
FRED: NO DOUBT, I'M TELLING YOU,
TRIPLE CROWN IS SO TOUGH AND THE
LAST GUY TO DO IT WAS MIGUEL
CABRERA SO IF HE WINS THE TRIPLE
CROWN, IT'S HIS, I'M JUST
TELLING YOU.
LAUREN: I THINK THAT'S
STRAIGHTFORWARD, TO THE POINT.
IT'S TOUGH TO BEAT OUT SHOHEI
OHTANI, THE MODERN DAY BABE RUTH
BUT VLAD JR., DO NOT SLEEP ON
HIM BECAUSE HE'S NORTH OF THE
BORDER.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT ONE, ROBBIE RAY AS WE LOOK
AT VLAD HITTING BOMBS HERE BUT
WE'LL MOVE ON TO A LITTLE BIT OF
PITCHING.
ROBBIE RAY, DOES HE SHOULD --
HAVE A SHOT AT THE CY YOUNG
AWARD?
FRED: HE HAS A SHOT BUT HAS TO
TURN IT ON THE LAST SIX WEEKS,
HAS TO CONTINUE TO PITCH WELL
AND GIVE THE BLUE JAYS A CHANCE.
IF THE BLUE JAYS END UP IN THE
PLAYOFF HUNT, WILD CARD HUNT, HE
HAS A CHANCE.
LAUREN: YOU LOOK AT THE COMPANY
HE'S IN RIGHT NOW.
YOU SAW WHAT LANCE LYNN WAS ABLE
TO DO IN THE SERIES WITH THE
WHITE SOX, LOOKED STRONG IN THE
"FIELD OF DREAMS" GAME.
GERRIT COLE BACK OFF I.L.
LOOKING STRONG, AS WELL.
AND THEN ROBBIE RAY IN THE MIX.
IF THEY CAN MAKE A RUN, HE'LL
PROBABLY BE A BIG PIECE OF THAT
PUZZLE.
FRED: THE WHITE SOX, LANCE LYNN
AND RENDON, HAVING GREAT YEARS
AND THE TEAM IN FIRST PLACE AND
IT'S CHICAGO.
♪ CHICAGO ♪
LAUREN: WE'RE THE FAVORITES,
WE'RE CHICAGO.
THAT'S A SPECIAL TEAM.
I WAS AROUND THEM FOR A COUPLE
OF DAYS AND YOU TALK ABOUT
CHEMISTRY, VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
THE TORONTO BLUE JAYS HAVE IN MY
OPINION.
THE NATIONALS, THEY ARE OUT OF
IT AS WE KNOW, SO MUCH SO THAT
THEY'RE OFF THE BOARD ON THE FAN
DUEL SPORTS FANDUEL SPORTSBOOK
SO WHO'S YOUR FAVORITE TO PIN
THE N.L. EAST?
FRED: THE BRAVES GETTING HEALTHY
RIGHT NOW AND I KNOW THE
PHILLIES HAVE THE EASIER
SCHEDULE BUT THE BRAVES ARE
REALLY SWINGING THE BATS.
THE TRADES THE G.M. MADE DURING
THE ALL-STAR BREAK, TREMENDOUS,
WITH ADAM DUVALL AND SO FORTH.
HE'S BEEN CARRYING THESE GUYS.
FREDDIE FREEMAN HAS GOTTEN HOT,
ALBIES, SWANSON, RILEY --
SWINGING THE BATS GOOD.
IF THE BULLPEN HINGIS IN THERE,
THEY'RE GOING TO WIN IT.
LAUREN: THAT'S THE BIGGEST
QUESTION, WHO STAYS HEALTHIEST
THE LONGEST COMING OFF OF THE
60-GAME SEASON LAST YEAR.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE TOUGH
DIVISION.
LET'S GET BACK TO TONIGHT'S
GAME, OVER/UNDER SET AT NINE.
WE HAVE ERICK FEDDE, ALEK
MANOAH.
WE HAVE A STACKED LINEUP IN
TORONTO.
CAN WE GET TO OVER NINE RUNS?
FRED: I'M GOING UNDER.
ALEK THROWING THE BALL GOOD.
I DON'T SEE THE NATIONALS
SCORING TOO MANY RUNS TONIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE BLUE JAYS
CAN POP UP SEVEN, EIGHT RUNS.
I'M GOING UNDER.
LAUREN: I THINK THAT'S A SOLID
PICK.
OVER IS A MINUS 120 AND THE
UNDER IS MINUS 102.
SO IT WILL BE INTERESTING, AS
THE NATS LOOK TO PLAY SPOILERS
AND THE BLUE JAYS ARE FIGHTING
FOR THEIR PLAYOFF LIVES.
LET'S GET YOU TO THE POLL
RESULTS FOR TONIGHT'S GAME.
TORONTO BLUE JAYS NOW 85% PICK
TO WIN THIS ONE.
ARE WE SURPRISED BY THAT?
WE HAVE NATS FANS WEIGHING IN AT
15%.
BUT LET'S BE HONEST.
I THINK WE KNOW WHO THE
FAVORITES ARE.
FRED: WITHOUT A DOUBT.
SHOULD BE A GOOD GAME.
THE NATIONALS WANT TO BE
SPOILERS.
THEY'LL PLAY HARD BUT I THINK
THEY DON'T HAVE THE TALENT RIGHT
NOW TO COMPETE WITH THE UPPER
ECHELON TEAMS SO I SEE GUERRERO
AND THE BOYS JUST DOING WHAT
THEY GOT TO DO AND CONTINUE TO
SWING THE BAT AND THIS IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO PAT YOUR
STATS.
LAUREN: GUERRERO AND THE BOYS, I
LIKE THAT NICKNAME, AS WE LOOK
AT THE WILD CARD STANDINGS
BECAUSE THINGS ARE GETTING REAL
IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE,
ESPECIALLY THE A.L. EAST WHERE
THE BLUE JAYS ARE FIGHTING FOR
THEIR PLAYOFF LIVES.
YOU CAN SEE THEM JUST FOUR GAMES
BACK OF THE SECOND SPOT BUT WHAT
IS GOING ON WITH THE YANKEES AND
THE RED SOX RIGHT NOW, AS
THEY'RE IN A SERIES OF THEIR
OWN.
FRED: SERIES GOING TO BE GREAT
BECAUSE THE RED SOX AND YANKEES
HAVE ANOTHER GAME TONIGHT SO ONE
OF THEM IS GOING TO LOSE
TONIGHT, OK.
SO BLUE JAYS, FOUR GAMES BACK
NOW, IF THEY CAN WIN THIS GAME
TONIGHT, THEY'RE GOING TO PICK
UP A GAME ON EITHER THE RED SOX
OR THE YANKEES.
LAUREN: OF COURSE, THE NATS
LOOKING TO PLAY SPOILER AS THEY
HAVE A LOT OF GAMES UPCOMING
AGAINST CONTENDERS AND I KNOW
THAT'S ALWAYS A FUN FEELING.
BUT IT'S ALSO A FUN FEELING TO
DO THE PREGAME SHOW WITH YOU,
CRIME DOG.
WHAT WAS YOUR FAVORITE PART?
FRED: L.G.
LAUREN: WORKING WITH THE CRIME
DOG, FRED MCGRIFF, AS JUAN SOTO
GETS READY FOR A BIG NIGHT IN
THE NATION'S CAPITAL, LOOKING TO
TAKE DOWN THE BLUE JAYS IN THE
FIRST OF A TWO-GAME SERIES.
15 SECONDS AWAY FROM FICHT --
FIRST PITCH AS WE GET YOU OUT TO
THE YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK.
FOR FRED MCGRIFF, I'M LAUREN
GARDNER.'LL SEE Y ON E FLIP.
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG.]
♪
>> RECOGNIZABLE NAMES.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
ON THE HOME
SIDE, THE NATIONALS DEFINITELY
DID SERIOUS SELLING AT THE
DEADLINE.
JUAN SOTO SAID I THINK I NEED
THE HOME RUN DERBY TO FIX MY
SWING.
DID IT WORK?
DAN: IT DID.
A LOT OF GREAT YOUNG PLAYERS IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
THIS GUY, IN MY OPINION, IS THE
BEST LEFT-HANDED HITTER IN
EITHER LEAGUE.
WATCH HIM TAKE BATTING PRACTICE
THIS AFTERNOON.
HE DID NOT HIT ONE BALL FROM
CENTER TO RIGHT.
EVERYTHING TO LEFT FIELD.
HE DOESN'T GET A LOT OF PITCHES
TO HIT BUT DOESN'T MISS THEM.
SCOTT: AND NOW AT THIS POINT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE DAMAGE
HE'S DONE IN THE SECOND HALF OF
THE SEASON.
YOU'RE WONDERING, WHY EVEN PITCH
TO THIS GUY?
DAN: UNBELIEVABLE STRIKE ZONE
RECOGNITION.
HE RARELY SWINGS AT BALLS THAT
ARE OUT OF THE STRIKE ZONE.
HE SWINGS AT STRIKES.
THAT'S WHY HE HITS FOR AVERAGE
AND HE HITS FOR POWER.
SCOTT: HE LEADS THE LEAGUE IN
WALKS, LEADS THE LEAGUE IN
ON-BASE PERCENTAGE, AS WELL.
HE'S GOT THE SMILE, THE SWAG,
THE CONFIDENCE AND THE FIRST
HALF WAS OK BUT THE SECOND HALF
IS DYNAMITE.
HOME RUN DERBY WORKING OUT FOR
JUAN SOTO.
UP AGAINST HOT SHOT ROOKIE ALEK
MANOAH IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
OPENING FRAME.
FIRST, THE BLUE JAYS ALONG WITH
LINEUPS AND FIRST PITCH FROM
NATS PARK.
HELLO, T.J.
>> GURRIEL READY AS HE LINES IT
INTO LEFT CENTER, BASE HIT.
BIG TWO-RUN SINGLE FOR GURRIEL
AS HE SENDS A FLY BALL TO LEFT
FIELD, WELL HIT AND IT'S GONE!
MEMBER -- NUMBER 13 ON THE
SEASON FOR GURRIEL.
AND HOW ABOUT THIS.
HE HITS IT WELL ENOUGH TO GET IT
BEYOND JO ADELL IN LEFT AND
GURRIEL IS' SECOND BASE WITH HIS
SECOND EXTRA BASE HIT OF THE
NIGHT.
BASE HIT INTO RIGHT FIELD.
DICKERSON AROUND THIRD WILL COME
HOME TO SCORE AS EATON LOBS THE
BALL TO SECOND.
>> CURVE IN THE AIR TOWARDS LEFT
FIELD, CHARGING IN, GURRIEL,
GOES INTO A SLIDE AND HE MAKES
THE CATCH.
THAT BALL DIED QUICKLY ON ITS
WAY TO LEFT FIELD.
>> LOURDES LOOKS LIKE HE GOT IT
AND HE DID.
GURRIEL SENDS ONE JUST INSIDE
THE FOUL POLE DOWN THE LEFT
FIELD LINE, NUMBER 14 ON THE
SEASON.
IT IS 6-3.
>> 0-1.
HITS IT SHARPLY DOWN TO FIRST.
FAIR BALL, STEPPING ON THE BACK,
GURRIEL.
INNING-ENDING DOUBLE PLAY
BRILLIANTLY DONE BY LOURDES
GURRIEL JR.
SCOTT: WE ARE BRINGING IT ON
YOUTUBE WITH UNIQUE FEATURES
THAT BRING YOU CLOSER TO THE
GAME WHEREVER YOU'RE WATCHING.
WE HAVE BEEN CRUISING THROUGH
OUR EXCLUSIVE GAME PACKAGE ON
YOUTUBE THIS SEASON.
TELL YOUR FRIENDS, EASY TO FIND
US, YOUTUBE.COM/MLB, FREE FOR
EVERYONE.
JOIN THE THREE MILLION PLUS
SUBSCRIBERS ON THE MLB YOUTUBE
CHANNEL AND A NEW FEATURE WE
ROLLED OUT LAST WEEK, WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT IT.
YOU CAN PERSONALIZE YOUR
LISTENING EXPERIENCE ON YOUR
FAVORITE DEVICES BY SELECTING
PRIMARY, HOME OR AWAY, IN THE
AUDIO TRACK SETTINGS.
CHECK THAT OUT.
ALSO YOUTUBE TV CUSTOMERS LIKE
ME, YOU'RE HOOKED UP IN THE MLB
POP-UP CHANNEL GUIDE.
LET'S DO THIS.
ERICK FEDDE MATCHING UP AGAINST
MARCUS SEMIEN AND LIVE ON
YOUTUBE TO A GLOBAL AUDIENCE.
SCOTT BRAUN ALONGSIDE WITH DAN
PLESAC.
ERICK FEDDE BRINGING IT WITH HIS
PACE ALREADY, A STRIKE AGAINST
MARCUS SEMIEN.
DAN: THIS IS A TOUGH LINEUP,
MARCUS SEMIEN, BO BICHETTE,
VLADIMIR GUERRERO AND TEOSCAR
HERNANDEZ.
SCOTT: ALL-STAR CITY LOOKING AT
IN THE POSITION PLAYER GROUP.
SEMIEN, 38 YEARS OLD, BET ON
HIMSELF THIS OFFSEASON, TOOK A
ONE-YEAR DEAL.
HE'LL BE BACK ON THE FREE AGENT
MARKET AGAIN AND SO FAR SO GOOD.
IT'S WORKING OUT FOR HIM.
DAN: WE HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
CHARLIE MONTOYO BEFORE THE GAME.
MADE A SWITCH.
HE WAS A SHORTSTOP FOR A LONG
TIME AND THIS YEAR MOVED TO
SECOND BASE AND HE TOLD US
BEFORE THE GAME HOW MUCH OF AN
INFLUENCE HE'S BEEN ON BO
BICHETTE.
HE'S MADE THE TRANSITION TO
SECOND BASE, AS YOU TOUCHED ON,
NOT BAD.
27 BOMBS SO FAR THIS YEAR.
SCOTT: THIRD PLACE FINISHER IN
A.L. M.V.P. VOTING IN 2018 --
2019.
A LITTLE BIT OF A DOWN 2020
ALTHOUGH IT'S 60 GAMES, SLOW
START.
HE HAD A LOT GOING ON.
HE IS BACK AND AS GOOD AS EVER
RIGHT NOW.
SPITS THAT ONE FOUL DOWN THE
RIGHT SIDE.
DAN: THE BLUE JAYS, THERE WAS SO
MUCH HYPE COMING INTO THIS
SEASON WITH VLAD GUERRERO JR.
AND BO BICHETTE, BRINGING MARCUS
SEMIEN.
THERE'S A GOOD LOOK AT VLAD
GUERRERO WHO'S HAD A MONSTER
YEAR.
IF NOT FOR SHOHEI OHTANI WITH
THE ANGELS, HE SHOULD BE A
SHOO-IN FOR A.L. M.V.P.
SCOTT: SEMIEN DOWN THE LINE,
FOUL BALL.
DAN: ONE OF THE THINGS THE
BLUE JAYS HAVE GOING FOR THEM,
WE TALKED TO CHARLIE MONTOYO
BEFORE THE GAME -- THEIR BULLPEN
IS THROWING BETTER AS OF LATE.
IT WAS THE ACHILLES HEEL OF THE
BLUE JAYS THE FIRST COUPLE OF
MONTHS OF THE SEASON.
A GOOD LOOK AT CHARLIE MONTOYO
TELLING US HOW NICE IT IS TO BE
ABLE TO WRITE THAT LINEUP CARD
WHEN YOU HAVE GUYS LIKE VLAD JR.
AND BO BICHETTE, MARCUS
SEMIEN -- THE THE LIST GOES ON.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ -- THESE GUYS
LIKE TO PLAY.
PARTICULARLY SEMIEN.
SCOTT: SWING AND A MISS, FEDDE
GETS HIM WITH THE OFF-SPEED
STUFF.
YOU'RE RIGHT, DON'T YOU DARE
MARCUS SEMIEN HE'S NOT PLAYING A
BASEBALL GAME WHEN THE JAYS ARE
IN ACTION.
HE'S THERE, JUST STRUCK OUT.
AT THIS TIME WILL BE HIS BUDDY
AND DOUBLE PLAY PARTNER, BO
BICHETTE.
VLADI JR. LEADS BASEBALL IN RUNS
AND O.P.S.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ IS THE
REIGNING PLAYER OF THE WEEK IN
THE A.L.
DICKERSON'S IN THERE, GRICHUK IN
CENTER FOR SPRINGER WHO WAS
PLACED ON THE INJURED LIST.
SANTIAGO ESPINAL AT THIRD.
REESE MCGUIRE WILL CATCH ALEK
MANOAH.
BICHETTE TAKING A FIRST PITCH
STRIKE.
WIDE ZONE.
DAN: A LITTLE BIT OF A WIDE ZONE
AND ERICK FEDDE WILL NEED ALL
THE HELP HE CAN GET.
4-8 ON THE YEAR, E.R.A. NORTH OF
5.0.
2014, HE WAS A FIRST-ROUND DRAFT
PICK OUT OF UNLV, 18TH OVERALL
PICK.
SCOTT: JOSH BELL LINES IT UP IN
FOUL GROUND FOR OUT NUMBER TWO.
LET'S GET YOUR SPOTIFY BREAKDOWN
ON ERICK FEDDE, THE 28-YEAR-OLD
MAKING HIS 20TH START.
DAN: HE'S GOT FIVE PITCHES BUT
WILL GO TO TWO PITCHES FOR THE
MOST PART.
A GOOD FASTBALL AND SECONDARY
PITCHES NEED TO COME IN PLAY.
GOOD SIGN THE STRIKEOUT OF
MARCUS SEMIEN, SLIDER AWAY.
CONTAINING THE TOP OF THE ORDER,
SEMIEN, BICHETTE AND GUERRERO,
AND IF POSSIBLE, GET SOME
LENGTH.
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN USED A LOT
AND IF HE CAN GET INTO THE SIXTH
INNING, IT WILL MAKE LIFE EASIER
FOR DAVE MARTÍNEZ.
SCOTT: VLAD GUERRERO JR. TAKING
A PITCH IN.
HIS PLATE DISCIPLINE IS OFF THE
CHARTS, ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR.
HE GETS ON BASE.
DAN: YOU'RE GETTING A CHANCE TO
LOOK AT TWO VERY SPECIAL YOUNG
PLAYERS, BOTH OF THEM FROM THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
VLAD JR. HAS CUT HIS STRIKE ZONE
DOWN AND SWINGS AT A LOT OF
STRIKES.
WE'LL GET A CHANCE TO WATCH JUAN
SOTO.
HARD PRESSED TO BE FIND TWO
BETTER YOUNG HITTERS IN THE GAME
OF BASEBALL BOTH WITH STRIKE
ZONE RECOGNITION, HOME RUN AND
BATTING AVERAGE, AND THEY CAN
GET ON BASE, TOO.
SCOTT: VLADI JR. WAS THE
YOUNGEST EVER ALL-STAR GAME
M.V.P.
HE PUT ON A SHOW IN DENVER,
COLORADO, THIS YEAR.
DAN: WHAT GETS LOST IN THE MIX
WITH THAT BIG BAT HE'S SWINGING,
YOU TOUCHED ON THE .314, 35 HOME
RUNS -- MUCH IMPROVED
DEFENSIVELY AT FIRST BASE, TOO.
VERY AGGRESSIVE THROWER.
HE'S NOT AFRAID TO TRY TO GO
AHEAD AND GET A LEAD RUNNER ON A
BUNT OR GROUND BALL TO TURN THE
3-6-3 DOUBLE PLAY.
ALL-AROUND TERRIFIC PLAYER AND
CONTINUES TO GET BETTER.
SCOTT: WHIFFS ON THE 3-1 AND
FEDDE HAS A FULL COUNT ON
GUERRERO.
DAN: SAME PITCH HE STRUCK MARCUS
SEMIEN TO START THE INNING OUT.
GOOD SIGN FOR DAVE MARTÍNEZ.
SCOTT: THERE IS THE GROUND BALL
THROUGH THE VACATED RIGHT SIDE
AND VLADI JR. IS A TWO-OUT BASE
RUNNER.
DAN: THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY HE'S HITTING .314, 3-2
COUNT, DOESN'T TRY TO DO TOO
MUCH.
THAT WAS A PRETTY GOOD PITCH
FROM FEDDE.
FASTBALL, LOCATED ON THE OUTER
HALF OF THAT SHIFT, NOBODY ON
THAT RIGHT SIDE AND HE TAKES
WHAT THE NATIONALS ARE GIVING
HIM, A TERRIFIC PIECE OF HITTING
RIGHT HERE.
A LITTLE CUTTER ON THE OUTSIDE
THIRD, DOESN'T TRY TO PULL IT,
HITS IT RIGHT THROUGH THAT
VACATED HOLE AT SECOND BASE.
SCOTT: HE HAD A HIT JUST LIKE
THAT ON SUNDAY, VLADI COMING OFF
A NICE WEEKEND AGAINST THE
SEATTLE MARINERS.
HE HAD BEEN A LITTLE COOLER UP
TO THAT POINT.
NOW IT'S TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ.
HE'S SIZZLING MORE THAN ANYONE
IN THIS LINEUP RIGHT NOW.
HE WAS NAMED AMERICAN LEAGUE
PLAYER OF THE WEEK FOR THE LAST
SEVEN DAYS LEADING UP TO TODAY.
DAN: WHAT'S SO DIFFICULT, SCOTT,
AS A PITCHER, YOU GO THROUGH
THIS LINEUP AND CONCENTRATE ON
SEMIEN, BICHETTE AND GUERRERO
AND SAY, OK, I'M GOING TO TAKE A
DEEP BREATH BUT TEOSCAR
HERNANDEZ, FOUR AND FIVE PART OF
THE ORDER, COREY DICKERSON, HIT
HIS FIRST HOME RUN FOR THE JAYS
THIS WEEKEND IN SEATTLE.
IT'S JUST A TEAM, THEY'RE
RELENTLESS.
THEY CONTINUE TO HIT AND HIT.
SCOTT: ODDS COURTESY OF FAN DUEL
SO I'M GUESSING YOU'RE GOING
OVER 5.5?
DAN: WAY OVER.
ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK THAT
HAS CAUGHT PEOPLE IN BASEBALL BY
SURPRISE IS WITH MARCUS SEMIEN,
BICHETTE AND PARTICULARLY VLAD
GUERRERO, THEY DON'T SWING AT
VERY MANY BAD PITCHES.
LISTEN, WHEN YOU HIT LIKE THEY
DO AND YOU HIT HOME RUNS LIKE
THE BLUE JAYS DO, THERE'S GOING
TO BE SOME SWING-AND-MISS THAT
COMES ALONG WITH THAT BUT AS YOU
SAW THAT VLAD GUERRERO 3-2
SWING, THEY'RE JUST UP THERE NOT
JUST HACKING.
SCOTT: FOUR-PITCH WALK.
TEOSCAR IS ON BOARD.
LOOKS LIKE A BUGGY NIGHT.
YOU CAN SEE HIM WAVING AWAY THE
GNATS IN HIS FACE.
DAN: FIVE-PITCH GUY.
DAVE MARTÍNEZ WOULD LIKE TO SEE
HIM GO DEEPER INTO GAMES.
GOING OVER 100 PITCHES A COUPLE
OF TIMES.
THEY WANT TO SEE WHAT THEY'LL
HAVE FOR 2022 AND BEYOND.
STEPHEN STRASBURG HAD SURGERY A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
LOOKS LIKE HE'LL BE OUT THE
MAJORITY OF THE 2022 SEASON.
THE BIG TRADE AT THE DEADLINE,
MAX SCHERZER AND TREA TURNER,
OFF TO THE DODGERS.
A LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
LOOK.
A GOOD LOOK AT DAVE MARTÍNEZ.
GO BACK TO 2019, WE TALKED TO
HIM BEFORE THE GAME, SCOTT.
THEY WIN IT ALL AND THAT CRAZY
COVID 2020 SEASON.
EXPECTATIONS WERE HIGH AND THIS
TEAM WAS ACTUALLY PLAYING GOOD
BASEBALL GOING INTO THE FIRST
WEEK OF JUNE AND THEN THE FLOOR
FELL OUT FROM BENEATH THEM AND
IT WAS TIME TO MAKE SOME MOVES
AND MOVE BIG-NAME PLAYERS.
SCOTT: THEY WERE 40-38 ON
JUNE 30.
TWO GAMES OUT OF FIRST BASE.
THEY'VE LOST 30 OF 40 SINCE
THEN.
DAN: YOU LOOK AT TWO TEAMS IN
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE THOUGHT HAD A CHANCE
TO CONTEND.
THE CUBS AND THE NATIONALS, BOTH
OF THEM, RIGHT BEFORE THE
ALL-STAR BREAK, THEIR PLAY WAS
SO BAD THAT BOTH GENERAL
MANAGERS AND ORGANIZATIONS
THOUGHT IT WAS TIME TO LOOK
TOWARDS THE FUTURE AND MAKING
TRADES AT THE DEADLINE.
SCOTT: THEY BOTH HAD A NICE RUN,
GIVE THEM THAT.
BOTH PICKED UP WORLD SERIES
TITLES.
YOU CAN SEE THE NATIONALS'
DEFENSIVE SETUP PRESENTED BY
SPOTIFY.
GOLD GLOVER AT SHORTSTOP.
ALCIDES ESCOBAR, 2015 WITH K.C.,
DID GREAT WORK WITH THE ROYALS.
HE'S BEEN A BIT OF A JOURNEYMAN,
AND POPS BACK UP WITH THE
NATIONALS.
WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT HIM IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE FRAME.
SEVEN MISSES IN A ROW FOR FEDDE.
GREEN LIGHT?
DAN: I WOULD THINK SO, TRYING TO
BLOW SOMETHING OPEN CERTAINLY IN
THE FIRST INNING.
RANDAL GRICHUK ON DECK.
SCOTT: FASTBALL ON THE OUTSIDE
CORNER.
DAN: PRETTY GOOD TAKE.
NOT MUCH YOU CAN DO WITH THE 3-0
PITCH.
YOU SEE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAS BEEN PROBLEMATIC FOR FEDDE,
PERCENTAGE OF STRIKES, LOWEST IN
THE N.L.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD LIST TO BE ON.
DAVE MARTÍNEZ WOULD LIKE TO SEE
HIM ATTACK THE STRIKE ZONE A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
SCOTT: DICKERSON LIKES THE 3-1,
UP THE MIDDLE, STEP ON THE BAG
TO RETIRE THE SIDE.
SO TWO LEFT STRANDED AS ERICK
FEDDE IS ABLE TO WIGGLE HIS WAY
THROUGH THE TOP OF THE FIRST.
WE'LL INTRODUCE THE NATS' LINEUP
NEXT.
>> AND THE TABLE IS SET IN THE
FIRST INNING.
>> THAT BALL DRIVEN OUT TO LEFT
CENTER.
SEE YOU LATER!
JUAN SOTO, A LINE DRIVE, THE
BALLPARK COULDN'T HOLD IT.
HE'S UP TO 61 R.B.I.'S AND HIS
19TH PUTS THE NATS ON TOP OUT OF
THE GATE.
>> OVER THE TOP AND A LINE DRIVE
UP THE MIDDLE, BASE HIT CENTER
FIELD.
UP THE MIDDLE, 2-2 IN THE GAME
PLUS A WALK.
>> OUTFIELD AROUND THE LEFT,
PULLS IT DOWN THE RIGHT FIELD
LINE.
>> EVERYTHING HE HITS IS ON THE
NOSE, RIGHT?
>> SOTO, CENTER FIELD.
THAT BALL'S ON THE GROUND.
SKIPPING DEEP INTO THE GAP.
ROBLES HOME, ESCOBAR TO THIRD,
SOTO DELIVERS R.B.I. NUMBER 62.
>> HERE'S JUAN SOTO, RIGHT
FIELD, BACK IS SOLER AND HE CAN
ONLY PLAY THE CAROM.
ROBLES HEADS FOR THIRD.
SOTO INTO SECOND, AFTER MISSING
TYING THE GAME, BY NOT TOO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WONDERING IF IT WAS
GOING TO GET OUT OF HERE.
JUST TOWARDS THE TOP HALF OF THE
SCORE BOARD WALL THERE.
SCOTT: THE SPOTIFY WASHINGTON
NATIONALS STARTING NINE.
VICTOR ROBLES, ALCIDES ESCOBAR
IN FRONT OF JUAN SOTO.
JOSH BELL, SWITCH HITTER.
YADIEL HERNANDEZ IN THE FIVE
SPOT, THE 33-YEAR-OLD ROOKIE.
CARTER KIEBOOM HITS NEXT.
LUIS GARCIA AT SECOND, HITTING
SEVENTH.
RILEY ADAMS CATCHES TONIGHT FOR
ERICK FEDDE.
BIG ROOKIE, ALEK MANOAH, ON THE
MOUND.
THERE'S NOT MUCH OF A DEBATE
OVER WHO THE BEST ROOKIE
STARTING PITCHER IS IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT HIM.
DAN: HE'S A BIG DUDE TO LOOK AT,
TOO.
6'6", 260 POUNDS AND THE
BLUE JAYS LOVE EVERYTHING ABOUT
THIS GUY.
HE'S IN ATTACK MODE FROM THE
GIT-GO.
HE KIND OF PITCHES WITH THAT
CLOSER MENTALITY TO START A GAME
OUT, NO-NONSENSE GUY, NOT AFRAID
TO PITCH INSIDE.
11TH ROUND PICK BY THE BLUE JAYS
IN THE 2019 DRAFT OUT OF
UNIVERSITY OF WEST VIRGINIA.
HAS A GOOD FASTBALL LIKE THAT
ONE RIGHT THERE.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT HIM, HE'S NOT
AFRAID TO ATTACK THE STRIKE
ZONE, PARTICULARLY WITH HIS
FASTBALL, AND ESTABLISHES IT
EARLY.
SCOTT: HE SAWS OFF BATS.
COMING OFF A CAREER HIGH
11-STRIKEOUT PERFORMANCE ON
WEDNESDAY IN A WIN AGAINST
ANAHEIM AND FOR OUR BREAKDOWN,
THERE'S A LOT TO LIKE.
DAN: ONE THING, FASTBALL
COMMAND.
HE'S NOT AFRAID.
HE'S GOT A FOUR-SEAMER AND
TWO-SEAMER.
ONE OF THE THINGS, LIKE A LOT OF
YOUNG PITCHERS, CONTROL HIS
EMOTIONS.
HE'S BEEN DOING A BETTER JOB OF
THAT EVERY START, GETTING BETTER
AND BETTER.
THE BIG KEY, BE CAREFUL WITH
THAT GUY HITTING ON THE ON-DECK
CIRCLE, JUAN SOTO.
THAT GUY IS HASHTAG DANGER
LURKING.
SCOTT: I'M ANXIOUS TO SEE THAT
MATCHUP BECAUSE MANOAH IS OOZING
WITH CONFIDENCE, HE'S A ROOKIE
BUT KNOWS HE BELONGS.
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE HIM CHALLENGE
SOTO.
FIRST, AFTER THE ROBLES POPPER,
ALCIDES ESCOBAR.
DAN: YOU LOOK AT THE BLUE JAYS
STARTING PITCHING, AND THE MORE
YOU LIKE IT.
MANOAH HAS SETTLED IN IN AND HAS
BEEN A FORCE BUT IT STARTS AT
THE TOP WITH RYU.
JOSE BARRIOS THEY ACQUIRED AT
THE TRADE DEADLINE AND ROBBIE
RAY HAS TURNED IT AROUND.
THE BLUE JAYS FEEL GOOD ABOUT
WHERE THEY'RE AT.
THEY HAVE TO RUN DOWN THE RED
SOX OR THE YANKEES FOR THE WILD
CARD SPOT.
SCOTT: WEAK CONTACT TO SHORT.
BO BICHETTE PUTS AWAY ESCOBAR.
STATCAST 3-D SETS US UP WITH THE
ARSENAL OF ALEK MANOAH.
HEAVY DOSAGE OF
FASTBALLS,ESPECIALLY IF IT'S
WORKING EARLY, THE FOUR-SEAMER
AND SINKER AND SLIDER.
DAN: HE'LL THROW SOMEWHERE
AROUND 55% TO 60% FASTBALLS AND
IF HE HAS A GOOD ONE, HE HAS
THAT FOUR-SEAMER AND TWO-SEAM
SINKER.
IT ALMOST ACTS LIKE TWO
DIFFERENT PITCHES.
THIS GUY HAS ALL THE GOODS AND
ONE OF THE THINGS, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT HIM AND WATCH HIM, VERY
COMPOSED.
DOESN'T SPEND A LOT OF TIME IN
BETWEEN PITCHES.
VERY DECISIVE ON WHAT HE WANTS
TO DO AND HE IS IN ATTACK MODE
FROM THE MINUTE HE TAKES THE
MOUND.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE PREMIER
MATCHUP OF THE NIGHT, MANOAH
AGAINST SOTO.
IF YOU'RE IN THE LIVE CHAT, THE
YOUTUBE CREATORS, LET'S HEAR IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL HAPPEN IN
THESE BATTLES THROUGHOUT THE
NIGHT?
LIGHTING IT UP SINCE THE
ALL-STAR BREAK.
NOT A TON OF LINEUP PROTECTION
ANYMORE.
DAN: I KNOW NATIONALS FANS ARE
SAYING HO-HUM, BUT IT WAS SUCH A
TREAT, WE WERE HERE EARLY THIS
AFTERNOON, BEING BACK AT THE
BALLPARK, WATCHING JUAN SOTO
TAKE BATTING PRACTICE.
IT WAS A CLINIC, SCOTT.
I DON'T THINK IF HE TOOK 45
SWINGS HE HIT ONE BALL FROM
CENTER FIELD TO RIGHT FIELD.
CONSTANTLY THINKING UP THE
MIDDLE, LEFT FIELD.
DOESN'T GET VERY MANY GOOD
PITCHES TO HIT WITHOUT TREA
TURNER IN THAT LINEUP.
PRETTY GOOD CHANGEUP RIGHT THERE
FROM MANOAH.
YOU SEE THAT SHAKE OF THE HEAD.
ONE OF THE THINGS THIS GUY DOES
REALLY WELL, TOO, HE'LL GET A
LITTLE BIT MORE SPREAD OUT WITH
TWO STRIKES.
DON'T LET THAT SPREAD-OUT LOOK
FOOL YOU.
HE'S STILL VERY DANGEROUS AND
LETHAL TO HIT IT TO ANY PART OF
THE BALLPARK.
SCOTT: NUMBER 22, 22 YEARS OLD.
MANOAH A YOUNGSTER, AS WELL,
HAVING A BIG-TIME ROOKIE SEASON.
LAST START REALLY RIDING THE
FASTBALL AND VELOCITY PICKED UP
AS HIS START CONTINUED.
MANOAH WAS TAKEN 11TH OVERALL IN
2019.
HE WAS A STAR AT WEST VIRGINIA
UNIVERSITY.
HE HAS JUST BLOSSOMED IN THE
MAJOR LEAGUES.
SOME GUYS COME UP, IT TAKES THEM
TIME TO GET ADJUSTED.
I THINK MANOAH HAS COME UP AND
SAID I FEEL BETTER HERE THAN I
DID IN THE MINOR LEAGUES AND HE
RINGS UP SOTO.
WOW, WHAT A PITCH!
DAN: NASTY TWO-SEAM FASTBALL A
ALA GREG MADDUX, LOCKS UP ONE OF
THE BEST HITTERS IN THE GAME.
SCOTT: MANOAH CAN BRING WITH --
IT WITH A NINE-PITCH FIRST.
♪
>> TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ LEADING
THINGS OFF FOR THE BLUE JAYS IN
THE TOP OF THE SECOND.
>> TEOSCAR GETS INTO ONE, LEFT
CENTER FIELD AND IT IS GONE!
NUMBER 20 ON THE SEASON FOR
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ TO TIE IT UP
HERE IN THE SECOND.
>> THERE'S THAT JACKET, BROKE IT
OUT EARLY AGAIN.
>> GRICHUK IN CENTER WITH
SPRINGER OUT OF THE LINEUP.
GRICHUK SITS ON A FASTBALL,
DRIVES IT TO DEEP LEFT AND IT'S
GOING TO GO.
SECOND HOME RUN OF THE INNING
FOR THE BLUE JAYS AND THEY TAKE
A 3-1 LEAD.
NUMBER 20 FOR TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ
AND NOW NUMBER 20 FOR RANDAL
GRICHUK.
FIVE DIFFERENT BLUE JAYS HAVE
NOW HIT 20 OR MORE HOME RUNS ON
THE SEASON.
FIRST BATTER THAT RAMIREZ WILL
FACE IN THIS GAME IS COREY
DICKERSON WHO IS 1-3.
DICKERSON DRIVES THE BALL TO
RIGHT FIELD AND HE GOT IT ALL!
DICKERSON WITH HIS FIRST HOME
RUN AS A BLUE JAY TO EXTEND THE
LEAD.
IT IS 7-1.
>> THAT WILL BRING UP MARCUS
SEMIEN.
NOW MARCUS SEMIEN, FIRST PITCH
SWINGING AND DRIVES IT OUT FOR
HOME RUN NUMBER 27 ON THE
SEASON.
THE FOURTH HOME RUN OF THE BALL
GAME FOR THE BLUE JAYS, THE LEAD
IS 8-3.
SCOTT: WELCOME BACK TO NATIONALS
PARK, SCORELESS AS WE GO TOP
TWO.
VETERAN LEFTY BRAD HAND WAS WITH
THE NATIONALS THE FIRST FOUR
MONTHS, THEN TRADED TO THE BLUE
JAYS AT THE DEADLINE AND HAS
PLAYED WITH JUAN SOTO FOR FOUR
MONTHS, NOW HAS PLAYED WITH VLAD
GUERRERO JR. THE LAST 2 1/2
WEEKS.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK HIM
EARLIER TODAY HOW HE WOULD
COMPARE AND CONTRAST THE TWO OF
THEM IN TERMS OF HOW THEY GO
ABOUT THEIR BUSINESS.
HE SAID THE TWO HAVE A LOT IN
THE COMMON, THEY HIT FOR AVERAGE
AND PACE AT A HIGH CLIP AND HE
SAID SOTO AND VLAD PREPARE AT AN
ADVANCED LEVEL FOR FOR GUYS
THEIR AGE.
HE SAID THEY KNOW THE PITCHER'S
STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES AND
HAVE A PRECISE GAME PLAN, A
SIMILAR MESSAGE THAT RILEY ADAMS
TOLD ME ABOUT THE TWO OF THEM,
AS WELL.
HE TOLD ME THEY'RE BOTH
SIMPLISTIC IN THEIR APPROACH,
AND HE MEANT THAT IN A
COMPLIMENTARY WAY.
THEY DON'T GET BOGGED DOWN WITH
A LOT OF INFORMATION BUT HAVE A
PRECISE WAY TO ATTACK THE
AT-BAT, KNOWING WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR.
TWO YOUNG TALENTED HITTERS ON
EACH TEAM.
SCOTT: THEY'RE NATURALS.
DAN: IT IS NATURAL TALENT WHEN
YOU WATCH JUAN SOTO.
YOU CAN'T APPRECIATE HOW GOOD HE
IS UNTIL YOU WATCH HIM A FEW
DAYS IN A ROW.
UNBELIEVABLE RECOGNITION OF
PITCHES TO SWING AT.
THAT LAST PITCH THAT HE STRUCK
OUT WAS A NASTY TWO-SEAM
FASTBALL THAT MANOAH THREW BUT
HE'S AN INCREDIBLE YOUNG PLAYER
AND THE NATS WILL BE FACED WITH
A DILEMMA COMING UP SOON.
THEY'LL HAVE TO OPEN UP THE BANK
AND PAY THIS GUY AND I'M NOT
SURE ON THE OPEN MARKET, JUST
EXACTLY WHAT HE'S WORTH, SCOTT.
I MEAN, HE BRINGS A DIMENSION OF
POWER AND SPEED AND AVERAGE, HE
JUST BRINGS SO MANY THINGS TO
THE TABLE THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
HARD TO KEEP THIS GUY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF TEAMS THAT
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE HIM IN THEIR
LINEUP.
SCOTT: IT'S THE AGE THAT'S A
HUGE FACTOR, TOO.
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE POTENTIAL
GREAT BASEBALL AHEAD OF HIM.
HE'S ONLY 22 YEARS OLD AND WILL
BE A FREE AGENT IN A FEW YEARS
IF HE GETS THERE.
ESPINAL FOULS THAT ONE DOWN THE
THIRD BASE LINE.
GRICHUK STARTED THE SECOND
INNING WITH A BASE HIT TO RIGHT.
THIS HAS BEEN A NICE REPLACEMENT
PLAYER FOR CAVAN BIGGIO AT THIRD
BASE.
CAVAN ON THE I.L. WITH NECK
ISSUES.
I POINTED OUT HOW GOOD ESPINAL
HAS LOOKED ON DEFENSE THIS YEAR
AND CHARLIE MONTOYO, BLUE JAYS
MANAGER, WENT BACK AT ME AND
SAID, YEAH, AND DO YOU SEE HIS
.298 BATTING AVERAGE?
THIS HAS BEEN AS GOOD AS IT GETS
FOR A PLAYER FILLING IN FOR ONE
OF OUR MAINSTAYS.
DAN: WHEN YOU LOOK UP AND DOWN
THE BLUE JAYS LINEUP -- LOOKING
AT RANDAL GRICHUK RIGHT THERE.
ESPINAL HAS FILLED IN ADMIRABLY.
THE STARTING ROTATION IS SOLID.
IF THEIR BULLPEN CAN CONTINUE TO
GET OUTS IN THE SEVENTH, EIGHTH
AND NINTH INNINGS, THEY'LL CAUSE
A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
SCOTT: ESPINAL LIFTS ONE TO
CENTER.
ROBLES HAS IT FOR OUT NUMBER
ONE.
DAN: GOOD LOOK AT VLAD JR. RIGHT
THERE.
SCOTT: I NEED SOME HELP.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
PRESSURE YOU'RE GOING TO FEEL
ALL NIGHT LONG.
A TOUGH ONE.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR A WHILE.
LET'S LINE UP OUR FIRST YOUTUBE
POLL QUESTION, MAKE SURE YOU
CHIME IN.
IT'S ON YOUR SCREEN, YOUR PHONE,
YOUR COMPUTER.
ONE AT-BAT, GAME ON THE LINE, WE
JUST SHOWED YOU FOUR OF THE BEST
IN THE BIZ.
WHO ARE YOU TAKING?
WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR THE BEST
OVERALL PLAYER, WE'RE LOOKING
FOR THE BEST HITTER, THE
CLUTCHINESS, WHO IS THE GUY THAT
YOU WOULD SELECT IF YOU'RE
SEASON'S ON THE LINE?
VLADI JR. ON THE LIST, AS WELL
AS SOTO.
WE'VE SEEN THEM THIS EVENING AND
WE'LL ADD OHTANI AND TATIS TO
THE MIX, AS WELL.
YOU FIRST.
DAN: I'M GOING JUAN SOTO.
HE MARVELS ME.
I GET IT, BLUE JAYS FANS MIGHT
BE ANGRY BUT I HAD A CHANCE TO
WATCH JUAN SOTO IN THE
POSTSEASON.
HE WOULD BE A NIGHTMARE FOR ANY
PITCH PITCHER.
CONTROLS THE STRIKE ZONE AND YOU
MAKE A MISTAKE, HE'LL MAKE YOU
PAY.
SCOTT: REESE MCGUIRE HITLESS IN
HIS LAST 17.
BUT THE POLL'S ON YOUR SCREEN.
GET IN ON THE ACTION AND WE'LL
TAKE SOME OF THE COMMENTS IN THE
LIVE CHAT, AS WELL, FROM OUR
CREATORS.
GOOD LUCK WITH THIS ONE.
THAT IS CLOCKED TO RIGHT AND
IT'S MISSED.
SOTO CAN'T GRAB IT AND THE BLUE
JAYS WILL SET UP RUNNERS ON
SECOND AND THIRD HERE WITH JUST
ONE OUT IN THE SECOND AS REESE
MCGUIRE COMES THROUGH, HIS FIRST
HIT IN 17 TRIES.
DAN: THAT'S A TOUGH PLAY FOR A
RIGHT FIELDER, THE LINE DRIVE,
HUMPBACK LINER.
SOTO FROZE A LITTLE BIT.
CAUGHT A LITTLE BIT
-- HE IS NOT SURE IF HE SHOULD
LEAVE HIS FEET.
GRICHUK HAD TO HOLD UP.
WAS ONLY ABLE TO GET TO THIRD
BASE.
BLUE JAYS IN BUSINESS.
2-3.
SCOTT: DOUBLE NUMBER 13 ON THE
SEASON FOR MAGUIRE.
THE FIRST EVER BIG LEAGUE GET
BAT FROM BIG ALEK MANOAH.
HOW DOES HE LOOK?
DAN: HE LOOKS BIG.
HE LOOKS AS BIG IN THE BATTER'S
BOX AS ON THE MOUND.
EVERY PITCHER THINKS THEY CAN
HIT.
HE WILL GET A CHANCE RIGHT HERE
TO PUT IT IN PLAY.
THE NATIONALS HAVE THE INFIELD
IN.
SCOTT: SIX MINOR-LEAGUE AT-BATS.
ONE HIT IN COLLEGE I AM TOLD.
DAN: I THINK IF YOU ARE ERICK
FEDDE RIGHT NOW, THE SAFEST
THING TO DO -- IT IS DIFFICULT
TO HIT A BREAKING BALL,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE NEVER
HAD A MAJOR LEAGUE AT BAT.
THE LAST THING YOU WANT TO DO IF
YOU ARE ERICK FEDDE IS HIT WITH
THE FASTBALL.
GO AFTER HIM WITH THE BREAKING
BALL.
SCOTT: THERE IS A HEATER.
DAN: 90 MILE AN HOUR SINKER.
IF YOU ARE FATTY -- IF YOU ARE
FEDDE, YOU HAVE TO BE READY.
SCOTT: FEDDE GOES TO THE
CURVEBALL 17% OF THE TIME.
THAT IS YOUR CALL?
DAN: YOU HAVE TO GO FOR THE
BREAKING BALL, A STRIKEOUT.
THAT IS THE IDEA.
THE ONLY PROBLEM, IT IS A
NONCOMPETITIVE BREAKING BALL UP
THE PLATE, SO FAR ALMOST INTO
THE LEFT-HANDED BATTER'S BOX.
SCOTT: DANGER IS LURKING.
SEMIEN, BICHETTE, TEOSCAR, FOR
TORONTO.
DAN: YOU KNOW THE GUY IS BIG.
THE BAT LOOKS LIKE A TOOTHPICK
IN HIS HANDS.
SCOTT: AND HE RINGS HIM OUT --
WRINGS HIM OUT.
96.
DAN: NATIONAL BASEBALL AT ITS
FINEST.
2-3, ONE OUT.
ONE OF THE NICE THINGS ABOUT
BEING A STARTING PITCHER IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE.
THAT NINE SPOT AT TIMES
CONVENIENTLY ROLLS AROUND TO GET
YOU OUT OF TROUBLE.
SCOTT: FEDDE IS ONE OUT AWAY
FROM STRANDING BASE RUNNERS.
SEMIEN GOES AFTER THE FIRST
PITCH.
0-1.
SEMIEN STRUCK OUT FIRST TIME
AROUND.
TWO K'S SO FAR FOR FEDDE.
HE IS USUALLY FOR THE BOTTOM IN
TERMS OF STRIKEOUTS PER NINE
INNINGS, BUT HE HAS PICKED UP
THE PACE THIS YEAR.
DAN: HE HAD OUT THE FIRST HITTER
OF THE GAME, SWEEPING BREAKING
BALL THAT WAS DOWN AND AWAY?
-- DOWN AND AWAY.
SCOTT: SOMETHING YOU NOTICE WITH
FEDDE, HE DOES NOT GET MUCH
CHASE.
HIS CHASE RATE IS TOWARD THE
BOTTOM IN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
WHEN HE IS STRIKING OUT BATTERS,
IT IS IN THE ZONE.
DAN: THAT BREAKING BALL, LIKE
THE ONE HE THREW 1-1 TO MANOAH,
IT STARTS SO FAR OFF THE PLATE,
AS A RIGHT-HANDED HITTER, YOU
HAVE ELIMINATED THAT THAT BALL
IS OUTSIDE.
JUST THROWING FASTBALLS UP AND
AWAY.
THE 0-1 PITCHED A MARCUS SEMIEN
IS SO FAR OUT OF THE ZONE HE
DOES NOT GET A LOT OF CHASE.
SCOTT: TO THE HOT CORNER.
SEMIEN BOUNCES TO THIRD.
FEDDE STRANDS TWO MORE RUNNERS
FOR TORONTO.
PUTTING ON THE PRESSURE, BUT NOT
CONVERTING.
SCORE LIST AS WE GO TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE SECOND INNING.
>> 1-0, ATLANTA.
DANSBY SWANSON.
WELL HIT TO CENTER.
ROBLES, AS FAR AS HE CAN GO.
GOODBYE.
3-0, ATLANTA.
>> ROBLES AT THIRD.
SOTO AWAITS.
>> DUVALL TO HIS RIGHT AND
SCORING EASILY IS VICTOR ROBLES.
THIS GAME IS TIED.
>> A SINGLE IN THE FIRST INNING
AND A TAP ON THE LAST TIME OUT.
>> HIT TOWARD THE BRAVES
BULLPEN.
AT THE TRACK, AT THE WALL.
NUMBER 25 FOR FREEMAN.
>> AUSTIN RILEY IS 2-2.
AS RILEY CRANKS ONE TO DEEP
LEFT.
ANYTHING YOU CAN DO, I CAN DO
BETTER.
>> ATLANTA 6, WASHINGTON 3.
>> SURFING ONE TO RIGHT.
COMING AROUND.
CARTER KIEBOOM DRIVES IN TWO
AND IT IS A 6-5 GAME.
WILL SMITH WILL COME ON.
A STEP BY RILEY.
A PEG, AND THE BRAVES WIN IT.
SCOTT: THIS IS BRAND-NEW.
FANS WATCHING THE GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE HAVE THE
CHOICE OF LISTENING EXPERIENCE.
CLICK THE GEAR ICON IN YOUR
PLAYER, CHOOSE AUDIO TRACKS,
CHOOSE EITHER THE PRIMARY
BROADCAST, THAT IS US, OR CHOOSE
THE HOME AND AWAY RADIO CALLS.
ALL THE AUDIO IS SEAMLESSLY ON
YOUR DEVICES.
DO NOT MISS A MOMENT ON YOUTUBE.
NICE AND EASY.
THE NATIONALS GOING WITH BELL
HERNANDEZ -- BELL, HERNANDEZ,
AND KIEBOOM.
COMING OFF OF A 9-2-3 FIRST.
HERE IS BELL.
A BIT COLD LATELY.
UP TO 19 HOMERS ON THE SEASON
AFTER A SLOW START.
HE WILL PULL THAT ONE TO VLADDY
JR. FOR THE FIRST OUT.
DAN: YOU CAN SEE WHERE BLUE JAYS
LOVE MANOAH.
PRETTY SIMPLE PLAY BY VLAD JR.
HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO BUCK
MARTINEZ, VOICE OF THE BLUE JAYS
RADIO.
HE TOLD ME THIS AFTERNOON,
IMPROVED PLAY BY VLADDY AT THIRD
BASE.
HE IS AN ACCURATE THROW HER, NOT
AFRAID TO MAKE A BUNT PLAY, TURN
THAT 3-6-3 DOUBLE PLAY, TURN
HIMSELF INTO AN ALL-AROUND
BETTER PLAYER.
SCOTT: HE GOT HIMSELF IN MUCH
BETTER SHAPE.
YADIEL HERNANDEZ TAKES A STRIKE.
HE SAID TO HIS TEAMMATES, I NEED
TO BE MORE ACCOUNTABLE.
EVER SINCE, YOU SEE A PLAYER
BETTER ON -- AT THE PLATE,
BETTER AT D, BASERUNNING HAS
IMPROVED, VIA SPRINT SPEED.
THIS IS THE 33-YEAR-OLD WORKING
FROM CUBA.
ONE OF THE FAVORITES, YADIEL
HERNANDEZ.
HE CONNECTS ON THE 0-2, DRIVES
IT TO DEEP RIGHT, AND IT IS
GONE.
YADA HERNANDEZ MUSCLES UP ON AN
0-2 PITCHED TO PUT THE NATIONALS
ON THE BOARD FIRST.
HOME RUN NUMBER FIVE ON THE
SEASON.
HIS MANAGER SAYS HE HAS SNEAKY
POP AND SNUCK ONE OVER THE WALL
IN RIGHT FIELD INTO THE NATS
BULLPEN.
DAN: CURVEBALL 81 MILES PER
HOUR, A CEMENT MIXER FROM MANOAH
.
YOU CAN SEE THE BIG RED DOT.
NOT A TIGHT ROTATION.
MADE IT EASY FOR HERNANDEZ TO
GET AHEAD OF THE BAT.
1-0, NATS.
SCOTT: IT DID NOT SOUND LIKE HE
HIT IT ON THE SWEET SPOT.
HE IS A STRONG DUDE.
THAT LEADS US TO CARTER KIEBOOM.
THIRD BASEMAN GAINING CONFIDENCE
, FORMER FIRST-ROUND PICK IN
2016 BY THE NATS.
DAN: THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
STRETCH.
A LOOK AT HERNANDEZ AFTER THE
SOLO SHOT.
I THINK THE NATIONALS WANT TO
FIND OUT WHAT PLAYER THEY HAVE
IN KIEBOOM.
THEY REALLY HYPED HIM.
THEY THINK EVENTUALLY THE POWER
WILL COME.
SCOTT: IN THE CENTER THAT WILL
DROP.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE HOMER.
DAN: HE GETS THE BAT OUT IN
FRONT OF IT.
THE CURVEBALL MAKES IT EASY.
HE HAS SEEN GOOD ONES FROM
MANOAH.
THOSE ROLLED INTO THIRD, RIGHT
INTO THE HAPPY ZONE FOR THE
LEFTY.
SCOTT: .377 SINCE THE ALL-STAR
BREAK.
HE HAS BEEN PICKING UP STARTS
AND THRIVING.
HE CAN HIT.
HE WAS A STAR IN CUBA FOR YEARS.
HERE COMES LUIS GARCIA.
YOU WONDER IF MANOAH SHOULD BE
WORKING ANYTHING BUT THAT
FASTBALL.
WE SEE THE TWO-SEAMER WITH A TON
OF BITE.
DAN: HE MADE ONE MISTAKE, THE
CURVEBALL, THE SOLO HOME RUN.
HE WANTS TO MIX IN HIS PITCHES,
THREW A GOOD CURVEBALL TO JOSH
BELL.
TWO FASTBALLS, A FOUR-SEAMER.
THAT ONE AT 92 MILES PER HOUR,
HIS BALL HAS A LOT OF LATE LIFE.
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE 97 TO 100,
BUT IT HAS LATE LIFE, GOOD
CARRY.
GOOD UP IN THE ZONE WHEN HE
THROWS THE FOUR-SEAMER.
HIS 92, 93 PLAYS ALMOST 96, 97.
IT HAS THE EXTRA GEAR, STRAIGHT
CARRY.
SCOTT: ON THE GROUND THIS COULD
BE TWO.
SEMIEN TO BICHETTE FIRING TO
GUERRERO JR.
THEY WILL DOUBLE HIM UP AND
RETIRE THE SIDE.
THE NATS STRIKE FIRST.
YADIEL HERNANDEZ DOING DAMAGE ON
ALEK MANOAH.
1-0 NATS AFTER TWO.
>> THE PITCH HIT HARD ON THE
LEFT SIDE.
COME SIT, GOES TO FIRST.
DEEP BY VLADDY TO GET THE OUT.
>> SHARP HOPPER TO SHORT.
FOR SHUT, WHAT A PLAY.
A STRETCH BY GUERRERO AT THE
OTHER END.
WHAT A PLAY BY BO BICHETTE TO
RETIRE MAYFIELD.
SPRINGER TO LEFT FIELD.
THIS IS WELL STRUCK AND IT IS
GONE AS WELL.
NUMBER 15 ON THE SEASON FOR
SPRINGER.
2-0, BLUE JAYS.
SPRINGER TURNS ON ANOTHER.
THIS WILL BE HIS SECOND HOME RUN
OF THE NIGHT.
>> THE PITCH IS SLUGGED IN THE
AIR.
SPRINGER THROUGH THE TRACK, AT
THE WALL.
HE MAKES THE CATCH.
SPRINGER WITH THE LEAPING GRAB
IN CENTER FIELD.
HE ROBS TORRENTS OF EXTRA BASES.
-- TORRANCE OF EXTRA BASES.
>> A GRAND SLAM FOR TEOSCAR
HERNANDEZ, THE FIRST OF HIS
MAJOR-LEAGUE CAREER.
THE BLUE JAYS NOW LEAD 7-2.
>> HE TOLD ME, RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE.
SCOTT: VLADDY JR. IS MIC'D UP
FOR US.
DAN PLESAC, YOU HAVE TO LOVE IT.
DAN: MANOAH MANOAH TELLING
VLADDY, I WILL GET A FIRST
PITCH, COME OUT OF MY SHOES.
I WILL NAIL IT.
TOUGHER WHEN THE GAME STARTS AND
YOU ARE IN THE BATTER'S BOX.
SCOTT: MORE OF THAT GOLD COMING
YOUR WAY THROUGHOUT THE EVENING.
HIS BUDDY BO BICHETTE IS UP AND
THEN LET -- THEN VLADDY ON DECK.
HE WENT AROUND.
A BALL AND A STRIKE.
BISHOP AT -- BICHETTE IS
AGGRESSIVE.
ONE OF THE BEST SLUGGING
SHORTSTOPS IN THE GAME.
DAN: A ROUGH SUNDAY AFTERNOON.
FIVE STRIKEOUTS IN SEATTLE.
ALL FIVE SWINGING AND MISSING.
I AM SURE HE WOULD LIKE TO GET
THINGS GOING BACK IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
TERRIFIC YOUNG PLAYER.
SCOTT: HE WAS DHING SUNDAY.
STILL NURSING SORENESS FROM THE
LAST HANDSTAND -- GRANDSTAND.
DAN: BO BICHETTE, LIGHTNING
QUICK BAT.
ALMOST APPEARS HE CAN SEE THE
BALL DEEP INTO THE ZONE.
ALMOST SAYING, I WILL GET MYSELF
JAMMED.
YOU OFTEN HEAR HITTERS AND
PITCHERS ALIKE, THE LAST THING
YOU WANT TO DO IS BE IN THE IN
BETWEEN.
YOU ARE BEHIND THE HEATER COME
OUT IN FRONT OF THE BREAKING
BALL.
SCOTT: HE WILL CONNECT INTO
CENTER.
BO BICHETTE HAS HIMSELF A
SINGLE.
THE LEADOFF TO THIRD.
DAN: TERRIFIC AT BAT.
IT STARTED EARLY ON GETTING THE
BALL TO TRAVEL.
LET'S GO TO THE DOUBLE PLAY.
MARCUS SEMIEN PLAYED SHORTSTOP
HIS ENTIRE CAREER, MOVED TO
SECOND BASE.
4-6-3, MAKING SECOND BASE LOOK
EASY.
A GREAT FEED TO BO BICHETTE AND
A STRONG THROW TO VLAD,
INNING-ENDING 4-6-3 DOUBLE PLAY.
SCOTT: MARCUS SEMIEN IS YOUR
GUY.
A SEAMLESS TRANSITION TO
TORONTO.
VLADDY.
DAN: HE WAS TRYING TO GET BLUE
JAYS THE LEAD.
BIG SWING.
SCOTT: HE HAD A GROUNDBALL BASE
HIT THROUGH THE RIGHT SIDE IN
THE FIRST.
IF SHOHEI OHTANI WAS NOT DOING
WHAT HE IS DOING THIS YEAR AND
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE, AND YOU ARE
LOOKING AT NUMBER TWO IN TERMS
OF M.V.P. VOTING --
DAN: IT IS HARD TO LOOK PAST
VLAD IF YOU ARE THROWING OHTANI
INTO THE SITUATION.
HE IS HITTING FOR POWER, HE IS
HITTING FOR AVERAGE.
FIRST AT BAT TOOK A 3-2 PITCH.
SECOND BASE WAS WIDE OPEN.
HIT A BASE HIT -- HIT A HARD
GROUNDBALL FOR A BASE HIT.
VERY ADVANCED DEFENSIVELY.
SCOTT: HE HAS THE SMILE.
THE YOUNGEST EVER TO RECEIVE THE
HONOR FOR THE ALL-STAR GAME.
22 YEARS OLD.
MAYBE A LITTLE MIGUEL CABRERA IN
HIS HITTING GAME.
OFF AND RUNNING IS BICHETTE.
BO PICKS UP THE STOLEN BASE.
DAN: THAT IS HIS 18TH STOLEN
BASE AND HE IS YET TO BE CAUGHT,
18-18.
A GOOD JOB BY VLAD NOT TO SWING.
YOU CAN SEE THE GOOD JUMP HE
GETS.
A COUPLE OF STEP WALKING LEAD.
NO CHANCE FOR RILEY TO THROW HIM
OUT.
SCOTT: THERE IS.
-- SHOULD THERE IT IS. -- THERE
IT IS.
IT IS ALMOST LIKE FEDDE KNEW IT
WOULD HAPPEN.
WE HAVE SPOKEN TO ELITE BASE
RUNNERS WHO SAY, IF YOU ARE
GOING AFTER ME, I WILL MAKE YOU
PAY.
DAN: IF YOU LOOK AT BO BICHETTE
ON SECOND BASE, YOU WILL GIVE
VLAD ANYTHING TO HIT.
IT DOES NOT GET ANY EASIER WITH
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ ON DECK.
A GOOD FOUR-SEAM BAT --
BASKETBALL -- FASTBALL.
SCOTT: DO YOU THINK HE WAS
CHECKING TO SEE IF IT WOULD BE
IN THE ZONE?
DAN: WE HAVE SEEN FEDDE.
HE WILL GO TO THE BIG, SWEEPING
BREAKING BALL.
HE STRUCK SIMEON OUT TO START
THE GAME -- SEMIEN OUT TO START
THE GAME.
SCOTT: MISSED WITH THE HEATER.
LOOK AT THE BLUE JAYS WITH
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION.
.284.
DAN: NOTICE TO THE PITCH TOTAL
IS STARTING TO GET UP THERE.
THE NEXT WILL BE THE 54TH PITCH
TO GET THROUGH TWO PLUS INNINGS.
SCOTT: PAY OFF WALKED HIM.
BLUE JAYS FANS ARE COMING IN
STRONG TONIGHT.
WHO IS YOUR GUY?
VLADDY JR. TAKES THE PIE, 53% OF
THE VOTES.
YOU CAN SEE OHTANI, SOTO, TATIS
IN A SIMILAR AREA.
DAN: YOU CANNOT GO WRONG WITH
ANY OF THE FOUR.
VLAD GUERRERO RYAN -- RAN A 3-2
COUNT.
OHTANI, 39 HOME RUNS, 2.39
E.R.A. IN 17 GAMES STARTED.
TWO HORSE RACE.
SCOTT: HE HAS A SHOT AT THE
TRIPLE CROWN.
HE WOULD BE THE YOUNGEST PLAYER
TO WIN IT IN MLB HISTORY.
MARTIANS HAVE THE DEATH BEEN
POINTED OUT EARTH, I WANT
OHTANI.
ANOTHER SAYING, OHTANI ALL DAY.
SOTO HAS A TROPHY ALREADY, I
WILL GO WITH HIM.
I HAVE TO AGREE WITH DAN.
VLAD JUNIOR IS RIGHT BEHIND HIM.
I LOVE THE QUESTION.
WE ARE NOT LOOKING AT OTHER
PARTS OF THE GAME.
STRAIGHT UP HITTING, ONE AB TO
SAVE YOUR DAY, WHO IS IT?
DAN: THAT IS DIFFICULT, TALKING
ABOUT THOSE FOUR CHOICES.
FERNANDO TATIS SPENDS DAYS ON
THE INJURED LIST, COMES BACK AND
HITS TWO HOME RUNS.
A COUPLE TIMES THIS YEAR HE
MISSED TIME WITH A SHOULDER
INJURY.
HE COMES BACK AND IT IS LIKE HE
HAS NOT MISSED A BEAT.
SCOTT: A CHECK OVER TO BICHETTE.
HE GOT KNOCKED IN THE SHIN.
A BAD SPOT.
YOU CAN SEE HIM IN SOME PAIN
NOW.
HE IS LIKE, REALLY?
DAN: I SHOULD HAVE WORN THE
SHINGUARDS WHILE RUNNING BASES.
YOU CAN SEE FEDDE CUTS THIS ONE
OFF.
OFF THE LOWER SHIN BONE, MAYBE
ABOVE THE ANKLE.
SCOTT: GARCIA'S GLOVE STAYING
PUT AND COLLIDING WITH THE SHIN.
DAN: SEE IF BO CUTS DOWN THE
LEAD THIS TIME.
SCOTT: 2-0 TO TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ.
DAN: FEDDE RUNNING DEEP COUNTS,
56 PITCHES.
HE WAS AGGRESSIVE IN THE FIRST
INNING.
THIS BLUE JAYS LINEUP WILL DO
THAT TO YOU.
YOU BECOME TENTATIVE AS A
PITCHER, ARE AFRAID TO THROW THE
FASTBALL OVER THE PLATE.
YOU START AIMING AND GUIDING IT.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW, YOU ARE
0-1, RIGHT WHERE THE BLUE JAYS
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE YOU.
SCOTT: TEOSCAR OFF OF FEDDE'S
GLOVE.
IN INFIELD HIT, THOUGH JOSH BELL
WANTS IT REVIEWED.
GUERRERO JR. UP TO SECOND.
IT WAS CLOSE.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ WITH AN
ABSOLUTE ROCKET THAT WAS HALTED
BY FEDDE.
DAN: GOOD PLAY BY FEDDE TO GET A
GLOVE ON IT.
IT IS A REACTIONARY PLAY BY THE
PITCHER.
THIS IS HIT AT HIS GLOVE SIDE
WHICH KNOCKS IT DOWN.
THIS IS ABLE IT.
GREAT PLAY BY GARCIA.
ALMOST LIKE THE SOCCER GUY THAT
SCORES A GOAL.
THROWS IT FROM BOTH KNEES.
SCOTT: 112 MILES PER HOUR OFF
THE BAT.
IF YOU ARE UNFAMILIAR WITH EXIT
VELOCITY AND WHAT IS A GOOD
NUMBER, THAT IS A VERY HEALTHY
NUMBER.
DAN: I THINK THIS WILL BE
OVERTURNED.
SCOTT: LUIS GARCIA WITH A LITTLE
SLIDE AND A NICE THROW ON THE
MONEY TO GET HERNANDEZ.
HE IS HAPPY ABOUT IT.
SOME HARD CONTACT OFF THE BAT OF
THE BLUE JAYS HERE IN THE THIRD.
BICHETTE STANDING IN THIRD,
GUERRERO JR. AT SECOND.
COREY DICKERSON IS 0-1.
DICKERSON CAME OVER FROM THE
MARLINS IN A TRADE A COUPLE
MONTHS BACK ALONG WITH ADAM
CIMBER, A VALUABLE BULLPEN
EDITION -- ADDITION.
A PROFESSIONAL HITTER AT THE
PLATE WHO JUST LOST HIS BAT.
INTO THE NATS DUGOUT.
I THINK HE NEEDS IT BACK.
DAN: THIS IS A TERRIFIC CUTTER
IN.
TRYING TO GET THE HEAD OF THE
BAT OUT IT SLIPS OUT OF HIS
HANDS.
FORTUNATE FOR FANS SITTING
BEHIND THE DUGOUT WITH THAT
NETTING.
SCOTT: REBOUNDS RIGHT INTO THE
NATS DUGOUT.
AND WE ARE BACK.
LOOKING FOR MORE SUCCESS WITH
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION,
LIKE MANY OF HIS TEAMMATES.
HE CHOKES UP A LOT WITH TWO
STRIKES.
SOMETHING HE PICKED UP A FEW
YEARS AGO.
DAN: LOOK DEFENSIVELY.
THIRD BASE PLAYING HALF WAY TO
THE MIDDLE PART OF THE DIAMOND.
IF YOU ARE DICKERSON, IF YOU CAN
HOOK SOMETHING ON THE GROUND,
NATIONALS PRETTY MUCH GIVING HIM
AN R.B.I.
GOOD JOB OF PITCHING BY FEDDE.
THE WAY THE NATS ARE SET UP
DEFENSIVELY, IT IS THE HARDEST
BALL TO PULL TOWARD THE SECOND
BASE SIDE.
PITCHING AWAY YOUR DEFENSE
BEHIND YOU.
SCOTT: IT IS HOT AND MUGGY OUT
THERE TONIGHT.
HE CHOKES UP ON THE BAT AS MUCH
AS ANY PLAYER IN BASEBALL WITH
TWO STRIKES.
DAN: THAT WAS GOODBYE FEDDE.
ANOTHER CUTTER, ALMOST HIGH.
THOMAS -- COMING DOWN ON IT LIKE
A LUMBERJACK.
GEORGE SPRINGER ON THE 10 DAY IL
AND MARCUS SEMIEN GETTING A GOOD
CHUCKLE ON THAT SWING.
SCOTT: THIS TIME TO THE RIGHT
SIDE IT WILL BRING HOME A RUN.
FEDDE COVERING FIRST.
DICKERSON IS OUT.
BICHETTE SCORES.
DAN: PRODUCTIVE OUT AND
PRODUCTIVE AT BAT.
ABLE TO FIGHT OFF PITCHES, GETS
ONE HE LIKES.
THE NATS PLAYING THE INFIELD
BACK.
A SIMPLE GROUNDBALL TO FIRST.
THE BLUE JAYS HAVE TIED THINGS
AT ONE.
-- 1-1.
SCOTT: GUERRERO IS AT THIRD.
HERE IS GRICHUK.
HE SINGLED BACK IN THE SECOND.
FOUR HITS TONIGHT FOR TORONTO.
DAN: BLUE JAYS MAKING FEDDE WORK
THIS INNING.
HAD DIFFICULTIES GETTING THE
BREAKING BALL.
HAVE SEEN GOOD LIFE ON HIS
FASTBALL.
PRETTY GOOD CHANGE OF SPEEDS.
79 MILE AN HOUR CURVEBALL.
FOULED THAT ONE OFF THE END OF
THE BAT.
YOU COULD SEE, HOT, MUGGY NIGHT
HERE IN D.C.
66 PITCHES, 25 IN THE FIRST.
THROWING HIS 25TH IN THE THIRD.
SCOTT: IT IS BELL, FEDDE.
THAT WILL DO IT FOR THE THIRD.
THEY EVEN UP THE GAME AT 1-1.
THE GROUND OUT FROM COREY
DICKERSON.
WE HEAD TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
THIRD INNING IN D.C.
>> NOW VICTOR ROBLES.
ROBLES SWINGS AND HITS ONE INTO
THE AIR.
MOVES DOMINIC SMITH BACK ONTO
THE WARNING TRACK.
MR. THE BALL, UP AGAINST THE
WALL.
ROUNDING THIRD IS RILEY ADAMS.
THE THROW WILL NOT BE IN TIME.
>> SOTO, CENTER FIELD.
SKIPPING DEEP INTO THE NET.
ROBLES HOME, ESCOBAR TO THIRD,
SOTO DELIVERS R.B.I. NUMBER 62.
WELL HIT.
GARCIA, WICKET EXCHANGE WITH THE
HANDS.
>> HE IS A MASTER OF THE SLIDE
ON ONE KNEE PLAY.
>> THAT BALL HIT HARD UP THE
MIDDLE.
SHOVELS TO GARCIA.
HOW ABOUT THAT FOR A 6-4-3?
THAT IS ONE OF THE BEST DOUBLE
PLAYS.
THE TABLE IS SET FOR THE FIRST
INNING.
OUT TO LEFT CENTER.
SEE YOU LATER.
JUAN SOTO, LINE DRIVE.
HE IS UP TO 61 R.B.I.'S AND HIS
19TH PUTS THE NATS ON TOP.
SCOTT: GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY SPOTIFY,
THE EXCLUSIVE HOME OF THE JOE
ROGAN EXPERIENCE.
WATCH NEW EPISODES ON SPOTIFY.
WE ARE LIVE FROM NATIONALS PARK.
YOUTUBE CREATORS IN THE LIVE
CHAT SECTION, YOUR CHANCE TO GET
QUESTIONS IN THERE FOR ME TO
RELATE TO JOSE BERRIOS, BIG-TIME
PICK UP AT THE DEADLINE BY THE
TORONTO BLUE JAYS.
WE WILL CHAT WITH HIM IN A
SECOND.
ALEK MANOAH BACK IN THE THIRD.
IT STARTS WITH RILEY ADAMS.
DAN: ONE OF THE THINGS THE BLUE
JAYS HAVE DONE WELL, DRAFTING.
GO BACK TO MANOAH, 11TH PICK OUT
OF WEST VIRGINIA, PAYING
DIVIDENDS IN A HURRY.
NORMALLY IT TAKES STARTING
PITCHERS A COUPLE SEASONS IN THE
MINOR LEAGUES TO GET
ESTABLISHED.
ONE THING CHARLIE MONTOYO TOLD
US, HIS MOUND PRESENCE.
HE BELIEVED HE SHOULD BE THERE,
PITCHING IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
I WATCH HIS DEBUT AGAINST THE
YANKEES.
HE WAS TERRIFIC IN THAT DEBUT.
SIX INNINGS, STRUCK OUT SEVEN.
THE BLUE JAYS WON THAT GAME 2-0.
EVERY GAME HE HAS GOTTEN BETTER
AT SOME ELEMENTS.
HE IS RUFFLING FEATHERS, NOT
AFRAID TO GET INSIDE.
IT LOOKS SO FAR THE BLUE JAYS
HAVE HIT ANOTHER ROUNDER.
SCOTT: HE IS A BIG DUDE.
DAN: YOU CAN SEE BY HIS
MANNERISMS ON THE MOUND, HE IS
READY.
HE IS VERY DECISIVE IN WHAT HE
IS DOING, LIKES HIS FASTBALL.
IT IS NOT AN OVERPOWERING
FASTBALL, BUT IT PLAYS BETTER
THAN THE GUN READINGS.
IN A DAY AND AGE WHEN WE SEE SO
MANY YOUNG PITCHERS THAT ARE
MAXIMUM EFFORT, BALL ONE, BALL
TWO.
GOING INTO THE THIRD INNING, 25
PITCHES IS MANAGEABLE.
SCOTT: ADAMS OVER SEMIEN.
IT IS A SINGLE IN THE THIRD.
AS PROMISED, JOSE BERRIOS
JOINING US FOR OUR SPOTIFY
INTERVIEW.
DAN MENTIONED YOU MAKE GREAT
DRAFT PICKS WHICH GIVES YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE GREAT
TRADES.
JOSE, GREAT TO CHAT WITH YOU.
OUR FIRST CONVERSATION WITH YOU
AS A TORONTO BLUE JAYS.
WHAT HAS THE JAY EXPERIENCE BEEN
LIKE FOR YOU?
JOSE: THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TONIGHT.
IT IS ALWAYS FUN.
I HAVE BEEN HAVING FUN WITH IT
THESE GUYS HERE.
THEY LIKE TO ENJOY EVERY GAME
OUT THERE.
IT IS GOOD WHEN YOU HAVE A GUY
BEHIND YOU LIKE THAT.
PRETTY GOOD SO FAR.
DAN: WHEN THE TRADE DEADLINE
APPROACHED, DID YOU HAVE AN IDEA
YOU WOULD BE TRADED FROM THE
TWINS?
JOSE: I NEVER SAW MYSELF OUT OF
THE MINNESOTA TWINS, BUT MY
GROUP TAUGHT ME AND PREPARED ME
FOR THAT MOMENT.
THEY EXPLAINED TO ME WHEN AND
WHY THEY WOULD TRADE ME.
DAN: WERE YOU HAPPY IT WAS THE
TORONTO BLUE JAYS?
JOSE: IT WAS TOUGH.
I HAVE BEEN WITH THE TWINS MY
WHOLE CAREER.
TO COME TO A GROUP LIKE THIS,
THEY HAVE A LOT OF TALENT.
THEY CAN DO A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
OUT THERE.
NOW WE COME HERE TO THIS GROUP.
WE GOT HELPED TO DO A LOT OF
GOOD THINGS.
SCOTT: YOU LOOK GOOD IN THE
UNIFORM.
WE WILL GET THE FIRST QUESTION
FROM THE FANS.
TWINS FAN HERE ARE SO SAD TO SEE
YOU GO, BUT EXCITED TO FOLLOW
YOU IN TORONTO.
HOW HAS THE EARLY ADJUSTMENT
GONE IN TORONTO?
IS THERE ANYTHING NEW FOR YOU,
DO YOU HAVE TO FIND NEW FOOD
SPOTS, YOUR TEAMMATES?
YOU LOOK GOOD IN YOUR UNIFORM,
THE BLUE IS LOOKING GREAT.
JOSE: BLUE LOOKS GOOD.
IT IS MY FAVORITE COLOR.
MY SON SAYS NOW YOU HAVE YOUR
FAVORITE COLOR.
THEY ARE A REALLY GOOD GROUP.
THEY GAVE ME A GOOD WELCOME.
THE FOOD WAS DIFFERENT, BUT THEY
STILL HAVE MEAT, CHICKEN, FISH,
SO WE HAVE OPTIONS TO GET
HEALTHY AND STRONG.
DAN: FROM PITCHER TO PITCHER I
AM ASKED ABOUT 30 DIFFERENT
BALLPARKS.
I ALWAYS FOUND THAT THE MOUND AT
THE ROGERS CENTRE IS ONE OF THE
BEST A PITCH OFF OF.
DO YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE PITCHING
OFF OF THAT MOUND?
JOSE: YES, I LIKE TO PITCH THERE
BECAUSE OF THE FANS.
THEY LOVE BASEBALL AND WE GET
MOTIVATION FROM THAT.
SCOTT: VICTOR ROBLES WAS JUST
HIT BY A PITCH.
WE WILL SEE IF IT WAS ON THE
LEFT-HAND.
LEFT WRIST.
HE WILL HEAD TO FIRST.
THAT WILL MOVE UP RILEY ADAMS.
FEDDE TRIED TO BUMP WITH TWO
STRIKES.
THERE IS ROBLES, A LITTLE SMILE.
ESCOBAR COMING UP NEXT.
WE ARE CHATTING WITH JOSE
BERRIOS.
FROM A YOUTUBE CREATOR, YOU HAVE
PLAYED POWERFUL HITTERS LIKE
SNOW, CRUZ, DONALDSON AND NOW
VLAD JR.
THOSE FOUR IN A HOME RUN DERBY,
WHO DO YOU HAVE WINNING?
JOSE: THAT IS A TOUGH ONE.
SCOTT: ESCOBAR WILL FIND OPEN
SPACE AND COME THROUGH.
ADAMS, COME ON DOWN.
ROBLES, COME ON DOWN.
MAKE IT 3-1.
THE ESCOBAR TWO R.B.I. DOUBLE.
DAN: TWO SEAM FASTBALL WAS UP.
ESCOBAR DRIVES IT INTO THE
VACATED GAP IN LEFT CENTER
FIELD.
GRICHUK HAS A LONG WAY TO GET
OVER.
ROBLES SCORES ALL THE WAY FROM
FIRST.
SCOTT: NOW YOU HAVE HAD PLENTY
OF TIME TO THINK ABOUT YOUR
ANSWER.
JOSE: I THINK IT WOULD BE A TIED
MATCHUP.
I KNOW CRUZ, VLADDY, DONALDSON,
THEY CAN HIT, THEY HAVE POWER.
NOW I AM WITH THE BLUE JAYS, SO
I PICK VLADDY.
SCOTT: I KNOW HE JUST GAVE UP
THE DOUBLE, BUT ALEK MANOAH HAS
BEEN SPECIAL ON THE MOUND AS A
ROOKIE LOOKING LIKE HE HAS BEEN
DOING THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
RIGHT NOW MANOAH IS ONLY MAKING
HIS 12TH BIG-LEAGUE START.
PROBABLY THE BEST BIG ROOKIE
STARTER.
THIS IS THE MARQUEE MATCHUP.
JUAN SOTO WATCHES BALL ONE.
WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN FROM ALEK
MANOAH THAT STANDS OUT?
YOU REMEMBER YOUR ROOKIE DAYS.
IS IT SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING FROM HIM, OR IS HE
SAYING, I AM HERE?
JOSE: TWO WEEKS, HE ACTS LIKE HE
HAS BEEN HERE MANY YEARS.
THAT IS WHAT HE BRINGS TO THE
MOUND, A LOT OF CONFIDENCE.
THAT IS THE BEST FOR HIM SO FAR.
SCOTT: TALK US THROUGH WHAT HE
SHOULD BE DOING WITH JUAN SOTO.
THIS IS ONE OF THE TOUGHEST AB'S
IN BIG-LEAGUE BASEBALL.
HE KNOWS HIS ZONE AS WELL AS
ANYONE.
JOSE: HE HAS TO ATTACK, THROW
THE BALL OVER THE PLATE.
HAVE CONFIDENCE AND THROW IT
LIKE THAT.
SCOTT: I THOUGHT YOU MADE THE
STRIKEOUT CALL.
DAN: THAT TWO-SEAM FASTBALL IN.
MANOAH MANOAH WANTS THIS ONE.
IT IS A PRETTY GOOD PITCH.
SCOTT: WE HAVE A GOOD LOOK AT
IT.
IT LOOKS LIKE STRIKE THREE.
JOSE: FIRST AT BAT THEY CALLED
THE PITCH AND SOTO WAS MAD.
SCOTT: HE IS A SCARY DUDE.
HOW ABOUT THAT ONE?
A LITTLE UP.
THAT IS THE THING WITH SOTO.
YOU HAVE TO CHALLENGE HIM IF YOU
WANT TO GET HIM OUT, BECAUSE HE
WILL NOT CHASE.
JOSE: YOU HAVE TO ATTACK HIM,
TRY TO SCARE HIM.
WE TRY TO SCARE HIM.
SCOTT: THERE IS BALL FOUR.
HE HAS THE LOWEST CHASE RATE IN
BASEBALL, SOTO.
PICKS UP ANOTHER WALK.
DAN: NOT THAT BAD.
TWO RUNS ALREADY IN FOR THE
NATIONALS.
IF YOU ARE MANOAH, GETS JOSH
BELL TO ROLL ONE OVER.
SCOTT: WHAT ARE THESE
CONVERSATIONS LIKE?
DAN: THIS IS GOING OVER WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO.
JOSH BELL TOUCHED ON THIS.
HE ROLLED OVER ON A FASTBALL IN
TO VLAD JR..
SCOTT: WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING TO PETE WALKER ON
THE MOUND?
JOSE: HE GIVES A LITTLE BREAK TO
MANOAH.
HE TALKS ABOUT THE PLAN, WHAT WE
CAN DO WITH THIS GUY.
THAT IS THE PLAN FOR NOW.
SCOTT: LET ME SNEAK IN ANOTHER
QUESTION FROM ONE OF OUR
CREATORS.
HEY JOSE, WHO WAS YOUR FAVORITE
BASEBALL PLAYER GROWING UP?
JOSE: MY FAVORITE WAS IVAN
RODERIGO.
SCOTT: A CATCHER IS YOUR
FAVORITE.
SMART MOVE, IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
JOSE: THAT WAS MY FAVORITE
POSITION TO PLAY, CATCHER, BUT
MY DAD DID NOT LET ME BE A
CATCHER BECAUSE I WAS TOO SHORT
AND SKINNY.
SCOTT: I HEARD YOU DID NOT START
PITCHING UNTIL 2012.
HOW OLD WERE YOU?
JOSE: 17, MY SENIOR YEAR.
SCOTT: THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME
YOU STARTED PITCHING?
JOSE: FULL TIME.
ONE INNING PER GAME.
JUST GIVE ME THE BALL AND I WILL
THROW OVER THE PLATE.
SCOTT: WHEN DID YOU START
PITCHING?
DAN: SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL.
I PITCHED IN LITTLE LEAGUE.
BASKETBALL WAS MY FAVORITE
SPORT.
THAT MAY HAVE HELPED YOU AND I.
WE DID NOT WASTE A LOT OF
PITCHES.
JOSE: I SPENT MY POSITION
PLAYERS DAYS OUT THERE TRYING TO
HAVE FUN.
I KNOW I WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
HIT AT THIS LEVEL.
DAN: THAT WAS MY NEXT QUESTION.
IT SEEMS LIKE MANOAH MUST'VE
BEEN TALKING LIKE HE WOULD GET A
FASTBALL.
HE WAS CALLED OUT LOOKING ON
STRIKE THREE DOWN THE MIDDLE.
JOSE: I AM GOING TO TRY TO HIT A
HOMER.
SCOTT: YOU GET TO HIT TOMORROW.
JOSE: I HAVE TO.
IT IS ALWAYS FUN, BUT IT IS
TOUGH.
SCOTT: AT LEAST YOU ARE NOT
HITTING OFF OF MAX SCHERZER.
JOSE: THAT WAS THE JOKE TODAY.
WHO IS GOING TO PITCH TOMORROW?
THEY SAY IT IS YOURS ARE --
SCHERZER.
SCOTT: JOSIAH GRAY, NOT AN EASY
AB.
HE IS YOUNG, A TOP PROSPECT
PITCHING-WISE IN THE DODGERS
SYSTEM.
THAT WAS THE DEAL THAT SENT
SCHERZER AND TURNER TO L.A.
SCOTT: THAT WILL LOAD UP THE
BASES.
ESCOBAR HELD UP AT THIRD, SOTO
TO SECOND.
JOSE, WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
A PLEASURE TALKING TO YOU.
ENJOY YOUR BLUE JAY EXPERIENCE.
ENJOY THE REST OF THE SEASON.
JOSE BERRIOS JOINING US FOR THIS
HALF INNING OUT.
MANOAH LABORING AS THE NATIONALS
SEEM TO HAVE CRACKED THE CODE.
DAN: A CUTTER IN THE ZONE.
JOSH BELL DOES A GREAT JOB.
UP AND IN.
BIG, STRONG GUY ABLE TO FIST
THIS OUT TO LEFT FIELD.
SCOTT: YADIEL HERNANDEZ HOMERED
OFF OF MANOAH.
DAN: FIRST AT BAT HERNANDEZ HIT
THE BREAKING BALL FOR A SOLO
HOME RUN.
JUST INSIDE THE 335 SIGN.
SCOTT: MANOAH STARTS HIM WITH A
FASTBALL.
AFTER A NINE PITCH 1-2-3 FIRST
FROM THE BLUE JAYS ROOKIE
STARTER I THOUGHT, HE IS COMING
OFF OF A CAREER-HIGH 11
STRIKEOUTS, BRILLIANT
PERFORMANCE AGAINST THE ANGELS.
THAT IS BASEBALL.
DAN: THAT WAS A 1-2 PITCH THAT
HAS TURNED THIS INNING AROUND.
SCOTT: STATCAST POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD.
LET'S SET UP THE LONG BALL FOR
YADIEL HERNANDEZ.
UNDER 100 ON THE EXIT VELO.
HE GOT ENOUGH OF IT IN THE RIGHT
SPOT.
DAN: IF YOU ARE ALEK MANOAH, YOU
WANT TO BE GREEDY.
BLUE JAYS PLAYING HALFWAY.
HARD HIT BALL, IT WILL NOT BE
EASY.
HERNANDEZ RUNS WELL.
SCOTT: THAT HOME RUN WAS HIS
FIRST EVER OFF OF A BREAKING
BALL.
HE IS A CRUSHER.
PROBABLY WHY MANOAH WENT WITH
THE PITCH AT THE TIME.
THIS TIME HE MISSES ON THE
FASTBALL.
YOU CAN TELL HE IS NOT FEELING
THE FASTBALL LIKE HE DID LAST
TIME AROUND.
HE NORMALLY DETERMINES HIS GAME
PLAN BY HOW HE DOES IN THE FIRST
FEW INNINGS.
DAN: YOU CAN SEE CHARLIE MONTOYO
WATCHING THE YOUNG RIGHT-HANDER.
EVERY GAME IS A LEARNING
EXPERIENCE, A NEW EXPERIENCE.
HE HAD TRAFFIC IN THIS GAME HE
WAS ABLE TO MANEUVER AROUND.
IF YOU ARE A FAN OF THE BLUE
JAYS, YOU CAN GET OUT OF THIS,
AT WORST GIVING UP ONE MORE RUN.
SCOTT: WHEN YADIEL HERNANDEZ
DOES BIG THINGS, THE NATIONALS
WIN BIG GAMES.
24 W'S.
WE HAVE SEEN HIM GO DEEP.
0-2 PITCH.
THIS TIME HE HAS LEVERAGE.
3-1 AND HE IS SWINGING.
TOUGH PLAY, GETS PAST HIM.
IN COMES ESCOBAR AND SOTO WILL
SCORE.
THE THROW TO THIRD IS NOT IN
TIME.
TWO R.B.I. HIT FOR YADIEL
HERNANDEZ.
5-1 NATIONALS.
DAN: SOMETIMES IT CAN BE A GAME
OF INCHES.
THIS ONE A FOOT OR TWO AWAY FROM
BEING 6-4-3 DOUBLE PLAY.
SEE BO BICHETTE PLAYING SECOND
BASE SHY OF SHORTSTOP.
THIS BALL HIT ALMOST STRAIGHT
SHORTSTOP.
ONE OF THE NEGATIVES AT TIMES
WHEN YOU PLAY THAT SHIFT GAME,
RELIEVE THE VACATED HOLE AT
SHORTSTOP.
GOOD JOB BY JOSH BELL BEING
AGGRESSIVE, HEAD FOR A SLIDE TO
GET FROM FIRST TO THIRD.
THE NATS STILL IN BUSINESS.
SCOTT: THAT WILL SCORE ANOTHER
RUN.
JOSH BELL WILL SCORE ANOTHER RUN
AND HERNANDEZ GOES FIRST TO
THIRD.
NOW HE IS GIVING UP A
CAREER-HIGH SIX RUNS.
DAN: THIS IS UNFORTUNATE, WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU HAVE A YOUNG
PITCHER.
IT IS ALMOST STRAIGHT UP
SHORTSTOP.
NOT A VERY GOOD LEAD, NO REASON
TO PICK IT AT FIRST BASE.
YOU CAN SEE HERNANDEZ HAD A LEAD
AT FIRST.
NOW YOU ARE IN DAMAGE CONTROL
MODE.
SCOTT: THE WORST START OF HIS
CAREER.
HE IS ASKING FOR A NEW BASEBALL
AFTER STRIKING AWAY TWO.
HE IS VISIBLY DISPLEASED.
HE MIGHT HAVE SOME LONG WORK
TONIGHT.
I WILL SAY THIS.
IF YOU HAVE WATCHED THE BLUE
JAYS THIS YEAR, I WOULD KEEP
YOUTUBE ON YOUR SCREEN FOR A
WHILE.
DAN: THIS IS FAR FROM OVER.
THE NATIONALS HAD DIFFICULTIES
WITH THEIR BULLPEN.
THEY HAD A TOUGH TIME GETTING
LENGTH OUT OF ERICK FEDDE, WHOSE
PITCH COUNT IS ALSO UP.
SCOTT: KIEBOOM BLASTS ONE DEEP
LEFT FIELD.
DICKERSON IS LOOKING FOR IT.
HE MAKES THE CATCH.
THAT WILL DRIVE IN ANOTHER RUN,
A SAC FLY, ALMOST LEFT THE YARD
FOR KIEBOOM.
IT IS 7-1, WASHINGTON.
DAN: A SIX RUN INNING FOR THE
NATIONALS.
ANOTHER HANGING BREAKING BALL.
THIS ONE STAYS IN THE BALLPARK.
DICKERSON GOES AS DEEP AS HE CAN
BACK TO THE WARNING TRACK.
EASY SAC FLY.
NASHVILLE IS IN BUSINESS.
SCOTT: 21 PITCHES IN THE FIRST
TWO INNINGS FOR MANOAH.
THIS IS 31.
POPS UP GARCIA.
BEHIND THE NET.
A SIX RUN THIRD FOR THE NATS.
WE HAD A LONG CHAT WITH DAVE
MARTINEZ, THE NATS MANAGER,
WORLD SERIES WINNING MANAGER,
GOING THROUGH A BUILD BACK UP
ROSTER-WISE.
HE SAID WE ARE PLAYING
COMPETITIVE BASEBALL.
WE HAVE LOST SEVEN IN A ROW.
THAT IS A FAIR BALL SPINNING
WEIRDLY INTO THE GLOVE OF
GUERRERO.
HIS POINT WAS, THEY ARE
COMPETITIVE.
IT IS A BIG LEAD, 7-1, NATS.
>> MAKE FUN OF ME?
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
YES.
♪
>> THIS ONE LINED DOWN INTO LEFT
FIELD.
MAKES THE CATCH.
ADDS A LITTLE TO THE END.
THE UKRAINIAN JUDGE IS NOT GOING
TO GIVE HIM A HIGH COUNT FOR
THAT.
>> CIMBER WAS WARMING UP.
WATCH YOUR SCREEN.
SEMIEN, GUERRERO.
IF ONLY THESE GUYS COULD LOOSEN
UP AND HAVE A LITTLE FUN WHILE
THEY ARE PLAYING.
THEY LIKE TO HAVE FUN.
>> FALLS DOWN AT HOME PLATE.
BIG SWING.
SMILE ON HIS FACE.
SLIPPED TO THE GROUND AFTER THE
BIG CUT.
>> YOU DON'T SEE THAT OFTEN.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
IT IS A MANTIS PRAYING.
>> I CAN'T CALL IT A MANTIS OR
ALIEN, I HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
SCOTT: NATS HAVE OPENED THIS UP.
7-1 AS WE GO TO THE FOURTH
INNING IN D.C.
SATURDAY IN SEATTLE GEORGE
SPRINGER WENT BACK ON A BALL AND
LANDED AWKWARDLY.
INITIALLY THOUGHT TO BE AN ANKLE
INJURY.
TURNS OUT IT IS A RIGHT KNEE
SPRAIN WHICH LANDED SPRINGER ON
THE 10 DAY I.L. EARLIER TODAY.
WE SPOKE TO CHARLIE MONTOYO WHO
WAS DISAPPOINTED FOR HIS TEAM
AND SPRINGER.
HE SAYS THERE IS NO TIMETABLE
FOR SPRINGER'S RETURN.
IT IS TOUGH NEWS FOR A HITTER
WITH AN OPS OVER 1150 SINCE JULY
24.
HE HAS EARNED PLAYER OF THE WEEK
AWARDS IN THE LAST MONTH AND NOW
IS OUT 10 DAYS OR MORE.
SCOTT: IT WAS A ROUGH BEGINNING
OF THE SEASON FOR GEORGE.
HE COULD GET OFF THE INJURED
LIST.
HAD A COUPLE ISSUES.
A RIGHT QUAD STRAIN AFTER FOUR
GAMES.
EVENTUALLY HE WAS RIGHT.
HE WAS ONE OF THE BEST PLAYERS
IN THE GAME.
A COUPLE PLAYER OF THE WEEK
AWARDS.
FOR AS GOOD AS VLADDY JR. HAS
BEEN, GEORGE SPRINGER WAS
CARRYING THE TEAM.
THAT IS OFF THE BAT AND SAILING
INTO THE GLOVE OF ROBLES.
DAN: HIGH ENERGY PLAYER.
IMPACT POSITION.
HOW ABOUT THESE NOTABLE
OFF-SEASON ACQUISITIONS?
MARCUS SEMIEN AND GEORGE
SPRINGER BOTH HAVE BEEN AS
ADVERTISED, ONE OF THE REASONS
THE BLUE JAYS ARE IN THE HUNT
WITH SEVEN WEEKS TO GO, TRYING
TO CATCH THE YANKEES, THE RAYS
AND THE RED SOX.
SCOTT: CAN WE QUEUE UP ANOTHER
POLL?
MCGUIRE, BALL ONE.
WE JUST SHOWED FOUR BIG PICKUPS.
WHICH OFF-SEASON ACQUISITION HAS
HAD THE BIGGEST IMPACT, ARENADO,
LYNN, SEMIEN OR SPRINGER?
BLUE JAYS FANS HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN TWO.
SLOW HOP AND GARCIA PUTS AWAY
MCGUIRE.
TWO DOWN.
BLUE JAYS FANS WE KNOW WILL SHOW
A BIG IN THE POLLS.
THEY HAVE  TWO PLAYERS TO CHOOSE
FROM.
DAN: MARCUS SEMIEN MADE THE
SWITCH FROM SHORTSTOP TO SECOND
BASE.
HE BROUGHT THE BIG STICK WITH
HIM.
YOU TOUCHED ON EARLIER, TOOK A
ONE-YEAR FLYER, BET ON HIMSELF
FOR ONE SEASON.
THE BLUE JAYS WOULD LOVE TO KEEP
HIM IN, BUT HE WILL BE A HEFTY
PRICE TAG.
SCOTT: THE DAY IS DONE FOR ALEK
MANOAH.
A FIRST PITCH STRIKE FOR FEDDE.
OTTO LOPEZ EARNED HIS WAY UP TO
THE MAJORS.
CLOSE TO A .400 PERCENTAGE THIS
YEAR.
5'10", 160 POUNDER, MAKING HIS
MLB DEBUT.
FIRST DAY IN THE BIGS.
LOPEZ OUT OF THE DOMINICANA
REPUBLIC, 22 YEARS OLD.
WE WILL SEE WITH -- WHAT FEDDE
GOES WITH.
2-2.
THAT WILL BE IT FOR ALEK MANOAH.
JUST THREE INNINGS, SEVEN RUNS
CHARGED TO HIS ACCOUNT.
DAN: ERICK FEDDE SETTLING IN IN
THE FOURTH INNING.
HE HAD TRAFFIC MOST OF THE GAME,
WAS ABLE TO WIGGLE THROUGH THE
THIRD INNING, ONLY GIVING UP THE
ONE RUN.
HE LOOKED MUCH BETTER IN THE
FOURTH.
SCOTT: MUCH BETTER.
LOPEZ STRIKES IN HIS BIG-LEAGUE
DEBUT.
FEDDE RETIRES TO THE SIDE IN
ORDER AND HAS A CHANCE TO GIVE
THE NATS SOME INNINGS.
HE HAS A COMFY LEAD AT THE
MOMENT, MID FOUR.
>> LAST SUMMER WHEN AMERICA
LOOKED LIKE THIS, JOSH BELL READ
THE ROOM AND KEPT READING.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO A YOUNG
PERSON ABOUT HOW READING
IMPACTED YOUR LIFE?
>> IT IS A BIG FOUNDATION.
THE EARLIER YOU CAN READ, THE
BETTER.
IF I AM GOING TO MAKE A RIPPLE,
THIS IS MY RIPPLE.
>> BELL KNOWS HE CANNOT CHANGE
THE COUNTRY ALONE, BUT WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE UNITED.
HE BELIEVES THE WAY TO GET THERE
IS BY BECOMING BETTER PEOPLE.
>> WE ARE WELCOME YOU INTO THE
FIRST INSTALLMENT OF JOSH BELL'S
BOOK CLUB.
>> SO HE STARTED A BOOK CLUB
WHERE THEY READ MOSTLY ABOUT
SELF-IMPROVEMENT AND POSITIVE
HABIT BUILDING.
IT MEETS ONCE A MONTH FOR RESUME
DISCUSSIONS AND ANYONE CAN JOIN.
THE CATCHPHRASE IS BOOKS,
BETTERMENTS, PROGRESS.
>> THE GOAL FROM ALL THIS IS
WHEN THE WORLD GETS BACK TO
NORMAL,
I THINK IF I CAN ENCOURAGE
READING TO YOUNGER GENERATIONS,
I THINK THAT IS THE END GOAL.
SCOTT: EACH WEEK THIS SEASON ON
OUR BROADCAST, WE ARE GOING TO
FOCUS ON A YOUTUBE CONTENT
CREATOR.
TODAY, OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT
SHINES ON #GAMING, ALL THINGS
MLB.
LOVES THE GIANTS.
HIS FAVORITE MOMENT WAS THE
ISHIKAWA WALKOFF HOME RUN IN
GAME FIVE OF THE NLCS IN 2014.
WE'VE BEEN SEEING HIS COMMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT, AS CLOSE
AS 10,000 SUBSCRIBERS IN 2015.
LET'S GET HIM TO OVER 10,000
SUBSCRIBERS TONIGHT.
THORNTON HAS DONE SOME STARTING
WORK IN THE PAST, MOSTLY THE
FOUR-SEAMER, THE CURVEBALL, AND
THE CUTTER.
WE LAST SAW HIM AGAINST THE
ANGELS, TWO HITS, AND HE PICKED
UP TWO OUTS.
HERE HE GOES.
KEEP YOUR TEAM IN THIS GAME
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THIS OFFENSE IS
CAPABLE OF DOING BIG THINGS, AND
IT IS A YOUNG NATIONALS TEAM
WITH AN INEXPERIENCED BULLPEN.
DAN: RIGHT NOW, THE BLUE JAYS
ARE TRYING TO GET SOME LENGTH
OUT OF MR. THORNTON.
THREE STARTS ON THE YEAR.
HE THREW PRETTY WELL IN THE
STARTING ROTATION.
3.38 E.R.A.
BLUE JAYS WERE HOPING TO GET
MORE LENGTH.
THE NATIONALS WORKED HIM OVER
PRETTY GOOD, SCORING SIX RUNS,
BUT IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE, YOU
ARE NEVER OUT OF IT.
THEY HAVE ANOTHER GAME TOMORROW
AND A DAY OFF, AND THEN THE BLUE
JAYS HEAD BACK TO TORONTO TO
START A HOMESTAND.
SCOTT: RILEY ADAMS IS 1-1.
HE SINGLED AND SCORED IN THE
LAST INNING.
HOW DO YOU LIKE THAT?
DAN: THE BLUE JAYS HAVE THE
TIGERS COMING TO ROGERS CENTRE
OVER THE WEEKEND AND THE WHITE
SOX.
IT'S A BIG HOMESTAND COMING UP,
BUT GAMES LIKE THIS, YANKEES-RED
SOX, TWO SEVEN-INNING GAMES, THE
YANKEES WON THAT ONE GAME 5-2.
THIS IS ONE THE BLUE JAYS LOOKED
UP, THE NATIONALS HAD BEEN
REELING, AND THE PITCHING
MATCHUP LOOKED FAVORABLE.
THE NATS HAVE MADE THINGS
MISERABLE FOR THE BLUEBIRDS
TONIGHT.
SCOTT: THE JAYS ARE 63-54 ON THE
SEASON.
HERE'S THE 2-2 TO ADAMS.
HE STAYS ALIVE.
TORONTO ENTERING THE NIGHT EIGHT
GAMES BACK OF FIRST PLACE TAMPA
BAY.
THE YANKEES PICK UP A WIN.
TORONTO IS THREE GAMES BEHIND
THE YANKS FOR THIRD PLACE IN THE
DIVISION.
OAKLAND IS HOLDING THAT SECOND
WILD-CARD, WHICH THE JAYS HAVE A
SHOT AT.
THEY ENTER THE DAY FOR GAMES
BACK.
-- FOUR GAMES BACK.
THAT MISSED TO ADAMS.
DAN: THAT N.L. EAST, THE
COMPLEXION OF THAT DIVISION HAS
CHANGED SO MUCH.
THE TRADE DEADLINE, THE YANKEES
WENT OUT AND MADE TWO BIG
ACQUISITIONS.
JOEY GALLO HAS HIT SOME BIG HOME
RUNS.
TALKING ABOUT BIG HOME RUNS --
SCOTT: RILEY ADAMS, GO ALONG.
HE MUSCLES UP FOR A SOLO SHOT.
IT IS 8-1, WASHINGTON, SECOND OF
THE SEASON FOR ADAMS WHO WAS
PICKED UP IN THE BRAD HAND
TRADE.
DAN: PRETTY GOOD NIGHT FOR RILEY
ADAMS, 2-2.
HE SINGLED IN HIS FIRST AT-BAT.
TAKES ONE OUT EIGHT ROWS DEEP.
CAN SEE THE BREAKING BALL, A
SLIDER, OUTER THIRD AND UP.
BIG, STRONG GUY, GETS FULL
EXTENSION.
THIS WAS A NO DOUBTER OFF THE
BAT.
SCOTT: HIS TEAMMATES ARE FIRED
UP.
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING A LOT WITH
ADAMS ON HIS OFFENSIVE GAME.
DAVE MARTINEZ TOLD US EARLIER
TODAY THE PLAN WAS TO SHORTEN UP
THE SWING AND PROMOTE HIM
PULLING THE BASEBALL MORE.
DAN:DAN: YOU KNOW IF YOU ARE
DAVE MARTINEZ RIGHT NOW, YOU ARE
GOING TO GET A GOOD LOOK AT
RILEY ADAMS.
120 TWO AND BEYOND, STEPHEN
STRASBURG HAD SURGERY A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO, BUT THERE ARE SOME
POSITIVES.
WHEN YOU LOOK TOWARDS THE
FUTURE, AARON FETTY, IF HE
IMPROVES, JOSIAS, THERE'S A BIG
ARM.
WHEN YOU LOOK AROUND THE
DIAMOND, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE NATS HAVE THAT NOT MANY GUYS
HAVE, THERE AREN'T MANY JUAN
SOTOS WALKING AROUND.
LOOK AT THE TIGERS.
ONE THING MIKE RIZZO HAS BEEN
ABLE TO DO, THE NATS ARE ABOUT
WINNING.
THEY WON THE WHOLE THING IN 2019
.
I KNOW IT WAS HARD FOR MIKE
RIZZO TO PART WAYS, PARTICULARLY
WITH MAX SCHERZER.
TREA TURNER HAS BEEN SUCH A
TERRIFIC PLAYER, BUT BASEBALL
WILL GO ON.
THIS GUY YOU ARE LOOKING AT HERE
HAS THE CHANCE TO BE A REALLY
GOOD PLAYER.
HE HAS YET TO REALLY FIND IT.
HE'S AN ELITE DEFENDER, BUT I
THINK THEY EXPECT HIM TO HIT
MORE.
YOU WATCH HIM IN BATTING
PRACTICE, AND HE LOOKS LIKE HE
COULD BE A 15-HOME RUN GUY, NOT
GIVE 75-80 HOME RUNS PER YEAR.
AS BAD AS IT IS FOR THE
NATIONALS, ONE OR TWO MOVES IN
THE OFF-SEASON, THEY AREN'T FAR
AWAY FROM BEING COMPETITIVE.
SCOTT: ESCOBAR COMING UP, AND
LET'S BRING IN DAN KOLKO FOR
MORE ON ALL OF THE MOVES THAT
THE NATIONALS HAVE MADE.
NOW WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
RESULTS ON THE FIELD.
IT WAS A 48-HOUR MAKEOVER FROM
THE NATS AFTER THE 2019 WORLD
SERIES CHAMPS.
>> THEY ARE, SCOTT.
A LOT OF THE BIG NAMES LEFT,
INCLUDING YAN GOMES WHO WENT TO
THE OAKLAND A'S, WHICH CLEARED
THE WAY FOR RILEY ADAMS TO GET
SOME PLAYING TIME, TWO YOUNG
CATCHERS, AND YOU MENTIONED
RUIZ, THE TOP PROSPECT TO GOT
FROM THE DODGERS IN THE SCHERZER
AND TURNER TRADE.
THEY WENT FROM HAVING AN
ESTABLISHED CATCHER TO HAVING
ANOTHER TO GO ALONG WITH YOUNG
TALENT.
SCOTT: RILEY ADAMS WITH THE HOME
RUN FOR THE NATIONALS IN THE
HOME FOURTH TWO TACK ON ANOTHER
WASHINGTON RUN ON TORONTO.
TO HOME RUNS TONIGHT FROM THE
NATS BATS.
GNATS, ROLLING ALONG AT HOME IN
D.C.
-- NATS, ROLLING ALONG AT HOME
IN D.C.
♪
>> JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> MY GOODNESS.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT BALL IS CRUSHED.
>> AND THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> OH MY.
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> I TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SCOTT:-ONE, NA -- SCOTT: 8-1,
NATS OVER THE BLUE JAYS.
FIVE POSTSEASON APPEARANCES,
FOUR DIVISION TITLES, AND
ULTIMATELY A WORLD SERIES
CHAMPIONSHIP IN 2019 FOR THE
NATS.
GOING THROUGH A BIT OF TURNOVER
AT THE MOMENT, WHICH WE
DOCUMENTED A BIT A HALF INNING
AGO, AND THE FAMOUS RECORD I
WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER FROM THAT
2019 SEASON, AND NATS FANS CAN
RECITE IT EASILY -- 19 WINS, 31
LOSSES FOR THE NATIONALS.
PEOPLE WERE SAYING, SELL THE
BALLCLUB PLAYERS.
GET RID OF YOUR BIG GUYS AND
START OVER.
THEY DIDN'T, AND IT ALL WORKED
OUT VERY NICELY FOR THEM.
SEMIEN IN FOUL TERRITORY.
RILEY ADAMS WILL HAUL IT IN.
MIKE RIZZO SAID, THIS IS A
STRONG BALLCLUB, AND WE SAW THE
NATIONALS PICK UP A WORLD SERIES
TITLE.
LET'S PAY OFF THIS POLL.
WHICH ACQUISITION HAS HAD THE
BIGGEST IMPACT?
MARCUS SEMIEN WINS IT.
WE'VE SEEN SOME OF OUR YOUTUBE
CREATORS ECHOING THE SENTIMENTS
OF BLUE JAYS FANS, THAT SEMIEN
HAS TO BE THE MOST UNDERRATED
PICKUP THIS OFF-SEASON.
IT'S NOT HARD TO GIVE HIM THAT
TITLE AMONG THOSE FOUR FOR THE
CONSISTENCY HE BRINGS.
DAN: HE MADE THE SWITCH FROM
SHORTSTOP TO SECOND BASE AND DID
NOT COMPLAIN ABOUT IT AND HAS
HELPED THIS GUY.
THE BLUE JAYS BELIEVE BO
BICHETTE IS GOING TO GET BETTER
AND BETTER AT SHORTSTOP.
GETTING BACK TO THE NATIONALS,
THAT RUN IN 2019, IT'S AMAZING
HOW ONE PLAY CAN CHANGE NOT ONLY
A SEASON BUT A POSTSEASON.
THAT WILD-CARD, GAME, NATIONALS
AND RISK, THE BALL GETS BY
GRISHAM, HADER BLOWS THE SAVE,
AND THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW,
THE NATS WHEN THE WORLD SERIES.
RENDON FILED FOR FREE AGENCY.
STEPHEN STRASBURG OPTED OUT.
THE NATS HAD TO RE-SIGN HIM.
MAX SCHERZER WAS SO GOOD.
SCOTT: NICE PITCH FROM THE FETTY
AS HE FOOLS BICHETTE.
DAN: IF IT WERE NOT FOR THIS
KNOCK, WHO KNOWS WHAT WOULD'VE
HAPPENED.
JUAN SOTO OFF OF JOHN HADER.
LOOKED SO BLEAK HEADING INTO THE
LATE INNINGS.
THAT WAS HIS COMING OUT PARTY.
DON'T FEEL BAD FOR THE NATS.
THEY HAVE GUYS LIKE SOTO AND
PATRICK CORBIN, ONE OR TWO
PLAYERS NOT FAR AWAY FROM BEING
GOOD AGAIN.
SURE HE HAS SCOUTS LOOKING AT
PLAYERS TRYING TO GET BETTER.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT EXPECTS TO
WIN EVERY YEAR.
THERE IS A GOOD LOOK AT RYAN
ZIMMERMAN, ONE OF THE ORIGINAL
NATS.
TWO TEAMS THAT HAD SOME
EXPECTATIONS GOING INTO THE
SEASON.
NATIONALS STARTED TO PLAY WELL
GOING INTO THE MID PART OF JUNE.
A LOT OF FAMILIAR FACES.
KYLE SCHWARBER HAD A STRONG
FIRST YEAR.
THERE WILL BE BETTER DAYS AHEAD
FOR THE NATS.
MAX AND TREA TURNER, JUAN SOTO,
THREE PLAYERS WHO ARE GOING TO
GO DOWN AS THREE OF THE BEST
PLAYERS WHO PUT ON A CURLY W
UNIFORM.
SCOTT: NOW BOTH OUT WEST.
VLADDY WALKS FOR THE SECOND TIME
TONIGHT.
HE'S REACHED BASE IN ALL SEVEN
PLATE APPEARANCES.
THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY AUTHORITY OF THE
OFFICE OF THE COMMISSIONER OF
BASEBALL AND MAY NOT BE
REPRODUCED OR RETRANSMITTED IN
ANY FORM, AND ACCOUNTS AND
DESCRIPTIONS OF THIS GAME MAY
NOT BE DISSEMINATED WITHOUT THE
EXPRESS WRITTEN CONSENT.
IGNITE SO FAR FOR THE NATIONALS
OFFENSE.
DRIVING IT TO DEEP CENTER.
IT'S GOT A LOT OF LEFT TO IT,
AND IT IS GONE!
TEOSCAR CONTINUES TO LIGHT UP
THE BASEBALL, AND HE MAKES IT
8-3 ON HIS 23RD HOME RUN OF THE
SEASON.
DAN: THAT WAS A NO DOUBTER TO
CENTER FIELD.
FROM OUR VANTAGE POINT UP HERE
IN THE BOOTH, ITS WAY UP HERE AT
NATIONALS BALLPARK.
WORD ON THE STREET IS THAT
SPORTCOAT WAS CUSTOM FIT TO
VLAD'S TAILORING.
HERNANDEZ HITS THIS ONE.
VICTOR ROBLES GETS BACK, BUT HE
HAS NO CHANCE.
THE, TRYING TO CLAW BACK.
SCOTT: THIRD STRAIGHT GAME IN
THE YEAR -- IN A ROW WITH A
HOMER FOR HERNANDEZ.
HE'S BEEN ONE OF THE BETTER
HITTERS IN BASEBALL SINCE 2019.
DICKERSON, HIT HARD ON THE
GROUND.
HE WILL TOSS IT OVER TO FETTY
FOR THE OUT.
THAT IS IT.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ STRIKES AGAIN.
THIS ONE IS NOT EVEN CLOSE TO
OVER YET.
THEY BROUGHT THE JACKET TO D.C.,
AND THEY ARE READY TO USE IT
AGAIN, 8-3, NATIONALS IN FRONT.
>> BATTING .219 WITH A HOMER, 12
RUNS BATTED IN, SWINGS, AND HE
HITS A SOFT LINER INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
IT WILL DROP IN AND BOUNCE ON
ITS WAY TO THIRD BASE.
THERE IS A SWING.
THERE IS A FLY BALL.
INTO SECOND BASE, HE GOES.
HE WILL PULL UP RIGHT THERE WITH
A DOUBLE.
>> TURNING ON THAT AND GONE, A
HOME RUN.
TRIPLE-DOUBLE, AND NOW A HOME
RUN.
LISTEN TO THE OVATION FOR JEFF
FRY.
THE FANS, ON THEIR FEET.
THAT BALL IS GOING TO FALL IN
THE GAP AND GO TO THE WALL.
HE'S GOING TO STOP AT FIRST AND
COMPLETE THE CYCLE.
A PIECE OF BLUE JAYS HISTORY FOR
JEFF FRY.
WHAT A MOVE HERE.
SCOTT: BOTTOM FIVE COMING UP IN
D.C., AND ANOTHER NEW ADDITION
TO THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK -- I
KNOW DAN PLESAC WANTS ONE OF
THESE.
YOU CAN VOTE.
WE WILL PUT THAT POLE UP LATER.
THE PLAYER WILL RECEIVE THE
TROPHY DURING THE POST-GAME
SHOW.
PLAYER OF THE GAME POLLING LATER
IN THE SHOW HERE IN D.C., AND
THEY WILL BE HOLDING THAT
TROPHY.
I AM ALL ABOUT BREAKING UP THE
SEASON IN UNIQUE WAYS.
I SPOKE TO SOME OF THE WHITE SOX
PLAYERS.
THIS IS WHAT YOU CIRCLE ON YOUR
CALENDAR.
IT'S A YOUTUBE GAME YOU GET TO
PLAY, AND THERE IS SOMETHING
EXTRA TO PLAY FOR HARDWARE WISE.
DAN: ALL THE PLAYERS WHO HAVE
GOTTEN THAT HARDWARE, THAT'S A
PRETTY NICE TROPHY TO PUT ON
YOUR MANTLE.
I WAS HOPING I WOULD TAKE THAT
HOME ONE DAY, BUT I GUESS IT IS
FOR PLAYERS ONLY.
SCOTT: YOU RACKED UP A FEW GREAT
YOUTUBE BROADCASTS.
JUAN SOTO GETTING HIT BY KIRBY
C.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE JUST LOST IT.
DAN: KIND OF OVERTHREW THAT
FIRST-PITCH FASTBALL.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT CAUGHT JUAN
SOTO SOMEWHERE AROUND THE LEFT
ELBOW, RIGHT ELBOW AREA.
TWO-SEAM FASTBALL JUST GETS
AWAY.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE HAS AN ELBOW
GUARD PROTECTING THAT RIGHT
ELBOW.
THE SMILE ON THE FACE MUST MEAN
IT DIDN'T GET HIM FLUSH.
SCOTT: IF YOU WERE GOING BACK TO
THE PREGAME WITH DAN AND I, WE
WERE GOING OVER THE KINGS OF THE
NORTH AND ALL THE MEDIEVAL
COMPONENTS.
HE GOT UNDER IT.
LEFT FIELDER DICKERSON WILL PUT
IT AWAY, AND SOTO WILL RETREAT
TO FIRST.
THINK ABOUT ALL THE ARMOR WORN
BY HITTERS.
SOTO CAN HEAD TO FIRST AND END
UP THERE WITH A SMILE.
DAN: THAT FIRST PITCH JUST
UNFORTUNATELY GOT AWAY FROM
KIRBY.
TWO-SEAM FASTBALL UP AND IN.
WE SEE THAT MORE AND MORE, HIT
BY PITCH UP.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR VELOCITY,
LOOKING FOR SPIN, BUT WITH COMES
WITH MAX EFFORT PITCHING, IT
COMES WITH LACK OF COMMAND AND
CONTROL.
IT'S KIND OF ONE OF THOSE
NECESSARY EVILS IN BASEBALL.
IT'S HARD TO BE A GUY LIKE KYLE
HENDRICKS FROM THE CUBS, A GUY
THAT MANEUVERS THE BALL IN, OUT,
UP, DOWN.
WE TALK SO MUCH ABOUT SPIN RATE,
BUT WHAT COMES WITH THAT, WALKS
UP.
HIT BY PITCH IS UP.
WE ARE SEEING FEWER AND FEWER
STARTING PITCHER IS ABLE TO GO
DEEP INTO THAT SIXTH OR SEVENTH
INNING.
YOU GO BACK TO THAT MAGICAL RUN
BY THE NATIONALS.
WHEN YOU GET DOWN TO WHO WINS IN
THE WORLD SERIES, NOBODY HAD
STARTING PITCHING LIKE THE
NATIONALS DID.
PATRICK CORBIN WENT BACK, NOT
ONLY STARTED, WENT OUT OF THE
BULLPEN.
THE NATS HAVE BEEN BLESSED WITH
SOME GREAT STARTING PITCHING.
SCOTT: THERE IS HERNANDEZ DOING
DAMAGE AGAINST SOUTHPAWS, 10-17.
HE IS THE FRONT RUNNER FOR THE
TROPHY THAT YOU WANT, YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
HE'S HAD A CAREER-HIGH THREE
R.B.I.'S.
HOMER IN THE SECOND OFF A
HANGING SLIDER, AND BASE HIT,
SCORED TWO IN THE THIRD.
THAT IS TO THIRD.
THEY WILL GET ONE AND THEN THE
TURN TO SECOND FOR THE EASY TWO.
AFTER HITTING JUAN SOTO WITH HIS
FIRST PITCH, KIRBY C WAS ABLE TO
CORRAL THINGS.
JOSH BELL FLIES OUT, AND LET'S
START UP THE FIVE-FOR-THE THREE
BLUE JAYS DOUBLE PLAY.
WE WILL SEE IF THEY CAN CONTINUE
THEIR COMEBACK WEST IN THE TOP
OF THE SIXTH.
>> THERE'S ALWAYS SO MUCH
EXCITEMENT PRIOR TO GAME ONE,
AND FOR GREAT REASON.
>> TWO OUT, NOBODY ON.
HERE'S THE PITCH.
SWING AND A DRIVE HIT WELL.
LOOKING UP, AND IT IS GONE,
GOODBYE.
>> WE GO TO THE FOURTH INNING,
NATIONALS TRAILING TO-ONE.
JUAN SOTO FACING GERRIT COLE.
IT'S GOING, GOING, AND GOING UP
ON THE RAILROAD TRACKS.
>> 20 YEARS OLD AND BURSTING
WITH POWER.
THE ASTROS ARE DOWN TO THEIR
FINAL OUT.
INTO LEFT CENTER FIELD.
ROBLES IS THERE.
THE NATIONALS OF STOLEN GAME ONE
ON THE ROAD.
>> THE NATS, IF THEY CAN WIN THE
THREE OF THEIR NEXT SIX GAMES,
THEY WILL WIN THE WORLD SERIES.
>> EVERYBODY GETTING IN ON THE
ACT TONIGHT.
>> THE NATIONALS HAVE CERTAINLY
COME TO HOUSTON AND FLEXED THEIR
MUSCLES.
>> THAT'S THE BALLGAME.
A BLOWOUT WIN IN GAME TWO.
SCOTT: ASSUME TO MLB'S PODCAST
TO HEAR THE LATEST ANALYSIS FROM
INSIDERS ACROSS THE LEAGUE AND
EXCLUSIVE IN-DEPTH INTERVIEWS
WITH THE BIGGEST STARS.
BIG DAY FOR THE NATS AND TEDDY.
WHICH TEAM OUTSIDE THE
POSTSEASON PICTURE HAS THE BEST
CHANCE TO MAKE THE PLAYOFFS?
TO JAZZ, METS, YANKEES.
NONE OF THESE TEAMS ARE IN A
PLAYOFF SPOT.
WHO IS GETTING IN, DAN PLESAC?
DAN: I KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO
HEAR THIS, BLUE JAYS FANS, BUT I
THINK THE YANKEES BEST BASEBALL,
THEY HAVE NOT PLAYED IT YET.
RIZZO, GALLO, HUGE ACQUISITIONS.
AROLDIS CHAPMAN ON THE I.L.
ZACH BRITTON HAS BEEN
INEFFECTIVE.
A GUY WHO IS SO UNDER LOOKED AND
UNDERAPPRECIATED, LOW WISING
COMING OUT OF THE BULLPEN FOR
THE YANKEES.
THEY'VE BEEN GREAT SINCE THE
ALL-STAR BREAK.
SCOTT: ANDRES MACHADO OUT OF THE
BULLPEN FOR THE NATS.
HE'S WORKING AGAINST RANDAL
GRICHUK.
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THE YANKS.
THEY WON GAME ONE OF THE
DOUBLE-DIP.
THEY ARE ON TOP OF THE RED SOX.
THAT'S A SEVEN-INNING AFFAIR, SO
IT IS DONE SOON AGAINST BOSTON.
YANKEES, MAKING A STRONG PUSH.
THAT A.L. EAST IS ABSOLUTELY
STACKED.
THE RAYS HAVE A DECENT LEAD.
RED SOX, YANKEES, BLUE JAYS, ALL
IN THE MIX FOR A WILD-CARD.
DAN: I THINK THE CONCERN WITH
THE BLUE JAYS WOULD HAVE TO BE
THIS.
THE NATIONALS HAD BEEN REELING
THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS, A VERY
FAVORABLE MATCHUP ON PAPER WITH
MANOA.
THROWING THE BALL REALLY WELL
COMING OFF A BIG OUTING AGAINST
THE ANGELS,, AND CHARLIE MONTOYO
LOOKING OVER THAT SCORECARD,
DOUBLE SWITCHING AND HEADING FOR
THE PITCHERS.
THEY PLAY ANOTHER GAME TOMORROW
IN D.C. AND HEAD HOME FOR THREE
WITH THE TIGERS.
SCOTT: GRICHUK IS GONE.
HERE COMES ESPINAL.
NATIONAL LEAGUE SIDE, A LOT TO
BE DECIDED, AS WELL.
DAN: THIS IS WILD AND WACKY.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
WILD-CARD, AND THAT IS WHAT
JUMPS OUT TO ME, THE SAN DIEGO
PADRES.
THE REDS, TALKING ABOUT A TEAM
THAT CAN MASH.
JOEY VOTTO HAS BEEN HAVING A
RESURGENCE.
SCOTT: HE'S AN M.V.P. CANDIDATE.
DAN: WITHOUT A DOUBT.
SCOTT: JESSE WINKER WENT OUT ON
THE 10-DAY IL
THEY CAN GET SONNY GRAY AND
CASTILLO TO THROW TO THEIR
CAPABILITIES, AND THEY WILL BE
PRESSING THE PADRES ALL THE WAY.
SCOTT: I EVEN SEE THE CARDINALS
AS HAVING A SHOT.
THEY ARE ONLY FOUR GAMES OUT.
DAN: GETTING BACK TO THE PADRES,
THIS IS HOW DESPERATE THEY ARE.
YU DARVISH GOING ON THE I.L.,
PADRES LOOKING FOR ANY KIND OF
HEALTHY BODY.
SCOTT: ESPINAL, HE'S PICKING UP
A ONE-OUT SINGLE FOR TORONTO.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE WONDERING
WHY THE PADRES WOULD TAKE A
FLYER ON A GUY WITH AN E.R.A.
NORTH OF 6.00.
JAKE ARRIETA IS IN THE SAME
PLACE HE WAS IN IN 2016, BUT
EXPERIENCE.
MAYBE YOU CAN FIND LIGHTNING IN
A BOTTLE.
IT'S SCOTT: PROPS TO THE GIANTS.
WE HAVE THE BREWERS AND THE
GIANTS, TWO DIVISION LEADERS
RIGHT HERE ON YOUTUBE.
THOSE ARE TWO SURPRISE TEAMS FOR
ALL THE WORK AND THE WINNING
THEY'VE DONE SO FAR THIS SEASON,
BUT SAN FRANCISCO IS THE
SURPRISE A BASEBALL THIS YEAR.
DAN: THEY HIT HOME RUNS LIKE
NOBODY ELSE IN BASEBALL.
KEVIN GAUSMAN HAS BEEN TERRIFIC.
SCOTT:" ON THE FAN SIDE OF THE
NETTING.
CARTER KIEBOOM GAVE IT A GOOD
LOOK OFF THE BAT OF REESE
MCGUIRE.
DAN: GETS AS FAR AS HE CAN GET
TO THE TARP.
THIS ONE, JUST ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THAT NETTING.
SCOTT: NO CHANCE.
DAN: NOT UNLESS HE HAS A 45-FOOT
VERTICAL TO GET OVER THAT NET.
SCOTT: OR LIKE ACES OR, -- A
SCISSORS, CUT THE NET.
DAN: THINK ABOUT WHERE THE
BREWERS ARE.
IT HAD VERY LITTLE PRODUCTIVITY
OUT OF CHRISTIAN YELICH.
THEY RUN THE THREE STARTING
PITCHERS OUT THERE, AND WOODRUFF
BURNS AND FREDDY PERALTA ARE AS
GOOD AS ANYBODY IN THE BUSINESS.
JOSH HADER CLOSING THINGS OUT IN
THE BACK PART OF THAT BULLPEN.
DEVIN WILLIAMS HAS RESURFACED,
CAME OFF THE INJURED LIST,
THROWING THE BALL GREAT.
THE BREWERS HAVE BLOWN THAT N.L.
CENTRAL WIDE OPEN.
SCOTT: 7.5 UP ON A HOT REDS
TEAM, 72 WINS ALREADY THIS
SEASON FOR MILWAUKEE.
MAGUIRE STRIKES OUT.
DAN: PRETTY GOOD PITCH, 95
MILE-PER-HOUR FASTBALL UP IN THE
ZONE.
YOU WONDER, WHY ARE GUYS CHASING
THIS?
YOU CAN SEE THAT CARRY ON THAT
FOUR-SEAMER UP AND IN, JUST TIES
UP MAGUIRE.
SCOTT: MACHADO HAS BEEN PITCHING
WELL THIS YEAR, E.R.A. UNDER
3.00 ON THE SEASON.
AVERAGES ABOUT 95 ON THE
FASTBALL, WHICH WE JUST SAW.
A VERY COMPETITIVE GAME IN THE
LOSS TO THE BRAVES SUNDAY.
THEY WERE SWEPT BY ATLANTA.
LOOK AT THAT SHOT.
I AM ALL ABOUT THAT CAMERA.
DAN: THAT PORTRAIT KIND OF LOOK.
IT'S A COOL LOOK.
MACHADO GETTING A MEETING FROM
THE PITCHING COACH.
SCOTT: WATCH EXCLUSIVE CONTENT
ON THE NATIONALS YOUTUBE
CHANNEL.
FOLLOW THE NATS TODAY.
HERE HE COMES.
LOURDES GURRIEL JR.
BROTHER OF YULI GURRIEL WHO IS
PLAYING FOR THE ASTROS THIS YEAR
AND ALSO SCORCHING THE BASEBALL.
UP AND DOWN SEASON FOR LITTLE
BRO.
I AM EXCITED TO SEE THIS NEXT
GUY FOR THE NATIONALS, MASON
THOMPSON, ACQUIRED IN THE DANIEL
HUDSON DEAL, AND HIS FASTBALL
CAN REALLY BURST.
>> IT'S ONE OF THE FIRST FEW
PITCHES.
MACHADO TRIED TO YANK AT THAT
ONE OUT OF THE STRIKE ZONE, 96
MILES PER HOUR.
SCOTT: R.B.I.'S AND FIVE
STRAIGHT GAMES FOR LOURDES
GURRIEL JR.
IT'S A WEAKLY HIT GROUND BALL TO
THIRD, AND CARTER KIEBOOM ON THE
RUN WILL MAKE THE PLAY AND HEAD
BACK TO THE DUGOUT.
MACHADO STRANDS A RUNNER, AND
THE NATIONALS PRESERVE THEIR
FIVE-RUN LEAD MID SIX.
>> THIS IS
115TH WORLD SERIES, AND
-- TONIGHT, IT'S THE NATIONALS
TRYING TO FORCE A GAME SEVEN.
>> GOING, GOING, GONE.
GOODBYE.
IT'S THE NATIONALS, TWO.
ASTROS, TWO.
>> NOW JUAN SOTO.
>> HITS ONE HIGH AND DEEP TO
RIGHT.
>> INTO THE TOP TANK.
>> A TREMENDOUS HOME RUN FOR
JUAN SOTO.
A CURLY W IS IN THE BOOKS.
>> LET'S FINISH THE FIGHT
TONIGHT, NATS.
>> THAT IS A ROCKET TO LEFT, AND
THE LEAD IS CUT IN HALF.
>> HE HITS IT DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
>> HOWIE KENDRICK HAS DONE IT
AGAIN.
THE NATIONALS WERE A STRIKE AWAY
FROM THAT FRANCHISES FIRST EVER
WORLD SERIES CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> SWING AND A MISS.
A CURLY W IS IN THE BOOKS.
UNBELIEVABLE.
SCOTT: VLADDY JR. IS PLAYING
TONIGHT.
SO IS JUAN SOTO.
GO BEHIND THE SCENES WITH ALL
YOUR FAVORITE ALL-STARS, WITH
EXCLUSIVE CONTENT AND MORE ON
THE BLUE JAYS YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
THERE IS AN ALL-STAR, TEOSCAR
HERNANDEZ WHO LINED UP ANOTHER
HOME RUN.
EVER SINCE JULY 30, THIS TEAM
HAS HAD AN EXTRA BREATH OF FRESH
AIR, AND ITS CANADIAN AIR
BECAUSE THEY ARE BACK IN
TORONTO.
THERE WERE 670 DAYS BETWEEN
GAMES PLAYED UP NORTH, AND THEY
ARE THE FIRST TEAM TO PLAY HOME
GAMES IN THREE DIFFERENT CITIES.
THEY WERE ON THE ROAD UP UNTIL A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO, AND THAT IS
THE THEME OF THE JAYS.
WE SPOKE WITH CHARLIE MONTOYO
EARLIER, AND HE CONTINUED TO
TELL US HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR
THE TEAM TO BE BACK, SETTLED,
PLAYING IN FRONT OF THEIR HOME
CROWD, AND CANADIAN BASEBALL
FANS ARE FIRED UP.
DAN: THIS WAS A TEAM THAT ALMOST
TWO CALENDAR YEARS BEFORE THEY
GOT TO PLAY AT HOME.
CONNOR OVER 10.
THEY WILL TRY TO KEEP IT RIGHT
HERE AT 8-3.
BEAUTIFUL BALLPARK, THE ROGERS
CENTRE.
A WONDERFUL PLACE.
A GREAT SPORTS TOWN.
I WAS WITH THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS
WHEN THE BREWERS WERE STILL IN
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE.
I PITCHED IN THE FIRST EVER GAME
IN THE ROGERS CENTRE, THE
SKYDOME.
SCOTT: ESPINAL WITH A THROW THAT
IS BROUGHT IN BY VLADDY JR.,
CARTER KIEBOOM DOWN ON A GROUND
BALL.
DAN: THERE WAS NO PLACE LIKE
THAT, THE JUMBOTRON, THE HOTEL
OUT IN THE RIGHT CENTER FIELD
AREA.
IT'S ONE OF THE HIDDEN GEMS.
IF YOU'VE NEVER BEEN TO A
BALLGAME IN TORONTO, GET
YOURSELF UP TO TORONTO.
BEAUTIFUL CITY, BEAUTIFUL
BALLPARK.
SCOTT: THEY LIKE PLAYING THERE,
TOO.
THE ROGERS CENTRE, 9-2.
DAN: YOU NEVER HEAR CHARLIE
MONTOYO TALKING ABOUT IT BEING A
DISADVANTAGE, BUT IT WAS.
STARTING THEIR HOME GAMES IN
DUNEDIN.
IT'S A GRAPEFRUIT LEAGUE SPRING
TRAINING FACILITY, THEN MOVING
TO BUFFALO, THEY NEVER FELT LIKE
THEY HAD A HOME.
YANKEES FANS MADE THE TRACK UP
TO BUFFALO.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PLAY
SOME GOOD BASEBALL TO FIGHT
THEIR WAY BACK INTO THIS ONE.
THEY HAVE ONE MORE AGAINST THE
NATIONALS TOMORROW, OFF DAY
THURSDAY, AND THEN THEY HEAD
HOME FRIDAY, SATURDAY AND SUNDAY
TO TAKE ON THE DETROIT TIGERS.
SCOTT: THERE ARE SOFTER SPOTS
FOR THE BLUE JAYS IN THE
SCHEDULE.
I SEE TWINS.
A GOOD CHUNK OF ORIOLES AND
TIGERS, SO AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO
ON A RUN.
THE BIGGEST THING FOR THEM IS
PLAYING AT HOME AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE.
HERE'S THE UPCOMING SCHEDULE.
OAKLAND IS A TOUGH BALLCLUB TO
FACE.
THEN YOU GET EVEN DEEPER INTO
THE SEASON, AND THEY HAVE SEVEN
AGAINST MINNESOTA.
DAN: LASIX GAME OF THE YEAR FOR
THE YEAR FOR THE BLUE JAYS WILL
BE AT HOME AT THE ROGERS CENTRE.
TUESDAY, WEDNESDAY, THURSDAY.
THEY HAVE A FRIDAY, SATURDAY,
SUNDAY SERIES TO CLOSE IT OUT.
IF YOU ARE A BLUE JAYS FAN, A
CHANCE TO ROOT ON OF THE JAYS,
WHICH I'M ANTICIPATING WILL BE
TOPSY-TURVY.
SCOTT: SAME STORY WITH THE
WILD-CARD.
FOUR GAMES OUT, THE A'S AND RED
SOX HOLDING THOSE TWO SEATS, BUT
THE YANKEES MAY BE A HALF GAME
OUT BY THE END OF THE NIGHT.
HE WILL DO IT AGAIN.
CONNOR OVER 10 MAKING HIS SECOND
EVER APPEARANCE.
THAT IS INTO RIGHT.
OUT NUMBER TWO.
UP NEXT, RILEY ADAMS WHO HOMERED
LAST TIME UP, AND KURODA PARRA
IS MIKED UP ON YOUTUBE.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> HEY!
PERFECT.
SCOTT: EVERY TEAM NEEDS A
GERARDO PARRA.
BABY SHARK WAS ALL THE RAGE IN
2019 IN THIS BALLPARK.
DAN: WHAT HAS BEEN SO DIFFICULT
FOR NATIONALS FANS, 6, 7 WEEKS
AGO, THEY PUT THEMSELVES IN A
SPOT TO CONTEND IN THAT CRAZY
NATIONAL LEAGUE EAST THAT NOBODY
SEEMS TO WANT TO WIN.
THE BRAVES, NOW IN THE LEAD.
THE NETS, GETTING SOME BAD NEWS.
THAT GUY RIGHT THERE PARO WAS
SUCH A BIG PART OF THAT WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIP TEAM IN 2019, ALONG
WITH STEPHEN STRASBURG, JUAN
SOTO.
SCOTT: THAT IS A BIG INNING,
THREE UP, THREE DOWN, FINISHES
IT OFF WITH THE STRIKEOUT OF
ADAMS.
THROUGH SIX, IT IS 8-3,
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
>> OF ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
-- THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
>> WOW!
>> GUERRERO JR. HAS DOUBLED IT.
THAT IS THE 200TH HOME RUN IN
ALL-STAR GAME HISTORY, AND HE'S
GOING TO CHOP THAT UP INTO TWO.
468 FEET.
>> FLY BALL INTO THE GAP.
WHAT A CATCH!
GEORGE SPRINGER IS DOING IT ALL
TONIGHT.
HE LEFT HIS FEET AND CAME DOWN
WITH THE BASEBALL.
THAT IS AS GOOD AS IT GETS,
FOLKS.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SCOTT: WATCH ALL OUT OF MARKET
REGULAR SEASON GAMES LIVE OR
ON-DEMAND AND MLB "BIG INNING"
ON MLB TV.
VISIT MLB.TV FOR DETAILS.
A LOT OF THAT FROM NATS FANS
TONIGHT AS THEIR TEAM LEADS IT
OVER A BLUE JAYS SQUAD THAT IS
FIGHTING FOR A POSTSEASON SPOT.
WHICH TEAM HAS THE BEST CHANCE
TO MAKE THE PLAYOFFS?
I THINK WE COULD'VE GUESSED
WHICH WAY THIS POLL WAS GOING TO
GO.
DAN: A LITTLE BIT CLOSER THAN
ANTICIPATED, BLUE JAYS FANS
COMING IN STRONG.
SETTLED HIM DOWN A LITTLE BIT
TONIGHT, BUT A BIG SIX-RUN THIRD
INNING BY THE NATIONALS BLEW
THIS OPEN.
ALEK MANOAH, A SHORT OUTING.
DAN: MARCUS SEMIEN INTO --
SCOTT: MARCUS SEMIEN INTO
HERNANDEZ'S GLOVE.
HERE'S BO BICHETTE WHO HAS BEEN
LEARNING A LOT FROM MARCUS
SEMIEN.
>> I TALKED WITH BICHETTE
EARLIER.
THIS IS HIS FIRST TIME GOING
THROUGH A FULL 162-GAME SERIES.
HE SAID HE'S LEANING ON MARCUS
SEMIEN FOR ADVICE ALONG THE WAY.
HE SAYS MOST IMPORTANTLY WITH
THE MENTAL SIDE OF THE GAME, THE
SHUT TELLS ME SEMIEN'S BEST TIP
IS TO STAY AGGRESSIVE.
HE SAID HE FEELS MOST MISTAKES
COME WHEN YOU AREN'T PASSIVE.
HE'S FOCUSED ON NOT GETTING TOO
MUCH IN HIS HEAD AND STAYING
AGGRESSIVE.
SCOTT: I LOVE THAT.
BO BICHETTE IS AGGRESSIVE.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S CAPABLE OF
DOING, AND HE CAN REACH FOR A
BASEBALL OUTSIDE THE STRIKE ZONE
AND STILL DO A TON OF DAMAGE.
DAN:DAN: HE HAS UNIQUE BAT TO
BALL SKILLS.
HIS FATHER WAS A TERRIFIC
BIG-LEAGUE PLAYER, HAD TO REND
US -- TREMENDOUS POWER.
THE BLAKE STREET BOMBERS, DANTE
BICHETTE, ANDRES GALARRAGA.
SOME REALLY GOOD ROCKIES TEAMS.
SCOTT: CARTER KIEBOOM COULDN'T
PLAY THAT ONE.
DAN: THAT TOPPER, THAT IS ONE
THAT IS REALLY DO OR DIE.
BICHETTE RUNS WELL.
SCOTT: THAT'S GOOD FOR AN
INFIELD KNOCK.
DAN: FIVE A B'S, FIVE
STRIKEOUTS, ALL SWINGING, ABLE
TO GET THAT GOING TONIGHT,
TOO-FOUR NIGHT SO FAR FOR -- 2-4
NIGHT SO FAR FOR BO.
SCOTT: I LOOK AT THE LINEUP, AND
I GO, BO BICHETTE?
IT MUST BE NICE.
MARCUS SEMIEN, VLADDY JR..
THAT I THINK, VLADDY, YOU ARE IN
FRONT OF BO BICHETTE AND TEOSCAR
HERNANDEZ.
DAN: WHAT HAS MADE BO AND VLAD
JR. DYNAMIC YOUNG HITTERS, HE
GETS HIMSELF INTO A GOOD COUNT.
SCOTT: THIS SHOULD BE TWO.
VLADDY IS DOUBLED UP.
DAN:DAN: GOOD PITCH.
SCOTT: MACHADO WITH A COUPLE OF
NICE INNINGS IN RELIEF FOR THE
WASHINGTON NATIONALS AS THEY
HOLD ONTO THEIR 8-3 EDGE.
LET'S STRETCH ON YOUTUBE.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
>> NOW THE KICK AND THE PITCH.
FLY BALL TO DEEP LEFT.
WARNING TRACK, AT THE WALL.
IT IS GONE!
.
GOODBYE.
SOTO, TWO-RUN HOMER.
>> LEFT FIELD.
CONTRERAS BACK.
YADIEL, SEE YOU LATER!
>> SECOND CAREER WALK AND
WHATO A DAYFF,, AND WHAT A DAY
FOR YADIEL HERNANDEZ.
>> YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE, INCLUDING A HUGE
INSECT ATTACKING VICTOR ROBLES
AT CENTER FIELD.
SCOTT: IF YOU WERE A BIG
BASEBALL FAN IN THE 90'S AND
2000S, YOU WERE WATCHING THE
BLUE JAYS IN GOING, REMEMBER?
BICHETTE, GUERRERO.
LIKE FATHER, LIKE SON, DAN
PLESAC.
FLED MERE GUERRERO IS A HALL OF
FAMER.
HIS SON WAS WITH HIM EVERYWHERE
WHEN HE WAS A KID, AND NOW HE'S
LIVING OUT THOSE DREAMS,
INCLUDING IN ALL-STAR GAME,
PUTTING ON SUCH A SHOW.
NOW ONE OF THE FLAT OUT BEST
TIPPERS -- HITTERS.
DAN: POPS WAS AS GOOD OF A BAD A
BALL HITTER AS ANYONE WHO PLAYED
BASEBALL.
THEY BELIEVED THEY COULD GET THE
BARREL.
THIS GUY, GREAT STRIKE ZONE
RECOGNITION.
PRETTY GOOD BREAKING BALL.
VLAD JR., TERRIFIC YOUNG PLAYER.
THEY KNOW THE STRIKE ZONE, AND
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE SOME
GAMES WHERE THEY GET IMPATIENT
AND CHASE OUT OF THE ZONE.
VLAD JR., WELL ON HIS WAY.
SCOTT: THEY TEND TO HAVE GREAT
LONGEVITY.
TWO QUICK STRIKES AGAINST HIM
FROM OVERTON WHO IS BACK ON THE
MOUND.
I SAY THAT BECAUSE THE HIT TOOL
PLUS THE PLATE DISCIPLINE MAKE
THINGS LAST FOR A LONG TIME.
JOEY VOTTO IS ABOUT TO TURN 38
YEARS OLD.
SCOTT: ONE OF THE KEYS IS
SWINGING AT STRIKES.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS VERY ACADEMIC
AND ROUTINE, BUT IT'S DIFFICULT
IN A GAME WHERE VELOCITY PLAYS
UP IN THE ZONE.
YOU ARE SEEING MORE AND MORE
HITTERS SPINNING THE BALL WITH
BREAKING BALL'S AND SLIDERS.
WHAT ALL THE GOOD HITTERS DO,
THEY SWING AT STRIKES, AND THE
MORE YOU SWING AT, THE BETTER
CHANCE YOU HAVE TO PUT THE
BARREL TO IT.
THE BLUE JAYS, HEADING DOWN THE
STRETCH, CONNOR OVERTON, YOU ARE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR STRIKE
THROWERS.
I KNOW THIS GAME IS ONE-SIDED IN
FAVOR OF THE NATIONALS.
SCOTT: THAT IS HIS SECOND K.
THE BLUE JAYS WERE AGGRESSIVE AT
THE TRADE DEADLINE AND EVEN
BEFORE THE TRADE DEADLINE WITH
THE PICKUP OF DICKERSON, BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY HAVE, A
YOUNG CORE THAT INCLUDES
HERNANDEZ AND VLADDY AND GEORGE
SPRINGER SIGNED UP FOR A LONG
TIME, AND THIS IS THEIR WINNING
WINDOW.
IT'S OPEN RIGHT NOW.
DAN: THEIR ROTATION IS BETTER
THAN PEOPLE APPRECIATE.
STEVEN MATZ WAS SO GOOD EARLY
ON.
HE STARTING TO GET IT BACK, AND
ROBBIE RAY HAS HAD A RESURGENCE.
THE WINDOW FOR THE BLUE JAYS, I
THINK THE A.L. EAST IS GOING FOR
THE BLUE JAYS THE NEXT FEW
YEARS.
YOU WOULD ASSUME THAT BICHETTE
AND VLAD JR. WILL CONTINUE TO
GET BETTER AND BETTER.
SO MANY GOOD THINGS.
SCOTT: THEY ACQUIRED JOSE
BERRIOS ON THE 30TH.
BEST WINNING PERCENTAGE IN THE
A.L. SINCE THE 30TH.
CHARLIE MONTOYO WILL HEAD TO HIS
DRUMS AND JUST LET LOOSE.
TRUE STORY.
HE'S GOT DRUMS IN THE CLUBHOUSE.
THERE WAS A BOBBLEHEAD ONCE WITH
HIM AND HIS DRUMS, AND HE WAS
JUST A COOL GUY, DOESN'T TAKE
ANYTHING TOO SERIOUSLY, TONS OF
EXPERIENCE AS A MINOR LEAGUE
MANAGER.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE IS DOING.
DAN: PRETTY GOOD 3-1 BREAKING
BALL FROM OVERTON.
A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO
RELIEVE STRESS.
CHARLIE MONTOYO'S VERSION IS TO
GO AHEAD AND HIT THE DRUMS.
SCOTT: IT WAS ONE OF MY FIRST
QUESTIONS.
I WAS FOLLOWING HIM QUITE A BIT.
HE SAID, I'M STILL DOING IT.
FOULED OFF THE BAT OF VICTOR
ROBLES.
ONE OUT.
ROBLES, 28 STOLEN BASES.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW GOOD HE
IS ON DEFENSE, BUT HE HAS NOT
TAKEN THAT NEXT STEP AT THE
PLATE YET.
PAYOFF.
POPPED IT UP.
THAT IS FOR HERNANDEZ.
THE SECOND TIME THAT HAS
HAPPENED, THIRD TIME FOR ROBLES.
DAN: TALKING WITH NATIONALS
PEOPLE A COUPLE SEASONS AGO,
THEY THOUGHT ROBLES HAD AS MUCH
POP IN HIS BAT AS JUAN SOTO.
IT HAS NOT TRANSITIONED INTO
GAMES.
YOU CAN WATCH HIM TAKE SOME B.P.
FROM EARLIER.
HITS POWER TO ALL FIELDS.
HE HAS YET TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CONTROL THAT ONCE THE GAME
STARTS.
SKILL SET IS THERE.
IF AND WHEN HE FINDS IT, WE WILL
HAVE TWO THIRDS OF THAT
OUTFIELD.
HE AND SOTO CAN COVER A LOT OF
GROUND.
SCOTT: TWO OUTS.
ALCIDES ESCOBAR IS GOING TO POP
THAT ONE BACK.
WHAT IS SOTO DOING?
HE'S COACHING REESE MCGUIRE.
THAT IS ONE OF THE BEST PARTS
ABOUT BEING AT THE BALLPARK,
JUST TO KEEP YOUR EYES ON JUAN
SOTO SOMETIMES.
ALWAYS UP TO SOMETHING.
ESCOBAR, THIS TIME IN FAIR
TERRITORY FOR HERNANDEZ.
THAT WILL DO IT.
A CLEAN BOTTOM OF THE SEVENTH
FROM CONNOR OVERTON, IMPRESSING
THE BIG-LEAGUE STAFF.
IT IS 8-3, NATS THROUGH SEVEN.
♪
>> YOUR TORONTO BLUE JAYS!
>> SPRINGER READY.
SPRINGER READY.
HOMERED HIS FIRST TIME UP.
>> HE MIGHT HAVE DONE IT AGAIN.
>> HOW ABOUT ANOTHER LEADOFF
HOMER FOR GEORGE SPRINGER?
HE'S DONE IT AGAIN.
WHAT A MOMENT FOR GEORGE
SPRINGER!
SCOTT: DECIDE BASEBALL'S BIGGEST
BLOOPER, AND YOU CAN WIN YOUR
OWN AIR-FREE -- ERROR-FREE
EXPERIENCE.
FILL OUT YOUR BRACKET FOR YOUR
CHANCE TO WIN.
MLB ORIGINALS SEASON TWO IS LIVE
ON YOUTUBE WITH NEW EPISODES
EVERY WEEK.
SEE YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS AND
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE ON YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
LEADING OFF THE EIGHTH FOR THE
BLUE JAYS, THEIR HOTTEST HITTER
RIGHT NOW, TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ WHO
HOMERED FOR TWO IN THE FIFTH
INNING, AND THIS IS PROBABLY THE
HOTTEST RELIEVER COMING OUT OF
THE BULLPEN FOR THE NATIONALS.
HIS NAME IS MASON THOMPSON.
THIS IS A FORMER THIRD ROUND
PICK FOR 2016.
THIS IS BIG-TIME STUFF.
I ACTUALLY SAW HIS MAJOR-LEAGUE
DEBUT.
TONS OF FAMILY THERE.
HAD A BIG EMOTIONAL MOMENT WITH
HIS FATHER.
DAN: HE WAS RANKED THE NINTH
BEST PROSPECT IN THE PADRES
ORGANIZATION ACCORDING TO MLB
PIPELINE.
HE WAS A GUY THAT THE PADRES
THOUGHT HAD A BRIGHT FUTURE.
THE NATS ACQUIRED HIM IN A DEAL
FOR DANIEL HUDSON.
THE LAST OUT OF THE 2019 WORLD
SERIES.
WHAT A WORLD SERIES THAT WAS.
THE ROAD TEAM WON EVERY GAME IN
THAT 2019 WORLD SERIES.
SCOTT: FIRST TIME EVER.
TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE TO
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ.
HE'S A TOUGH OUT.
DAN: YOU HAVE TO BE REALLY
CAREFUL WITH THE BALL UP IN THE
ZONE.
THIS IS A HANGING BREAKING BALL
FROM THE FATTY.
COMPLIMENTS TO STATCAST GOOGLE
CLOUD.
108 EXIT VELO, THE PROJECTED
DIFFERENCE -- DISTANCE 410 FEET.
SCOTT: I LOVE THE TRAJECTORY OF
THAT ONE.
IT WAS FUN TO CALL IT LIVE.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD
, SOME SERIOUS LAUNCH ANGLE ON
THAT ONE FROM TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ,
NUMBER 21 ON THE SEASON, AND
MORE HARD CONTACT, PRODUCING YET
ANOTHER HIT.
HERNANDEZ IS ON AGAIN A.
BY THE WAY, THE HOME RUN HAD A
LAUNCH ANGLE OF 36 DEGREES, AND
THAT'S AN IMPRESSIVE MARK.
HERE'S ANOTHER HARD HIT BASEBALL
OFF THE BAT OF THEIR CLEANUP
HITTER.
DAN: ONE OF THE THINGS MASON
THOMPSON IS GOING TO HAVE TO DO
IS MIX IN A LITTLE OFFSPEED.
-- HITTING TEAM.
IF YOU ARE MASON THOMPSON, YOU
WANT TO BE AGGRESSIVE, KEEP THE
BLUE JAYS LIMITED DAMAGE.
SCOTT: 23-YEAR-OLD MASON
THOMPSON, LIMITED WORK, BUT GOOD
SO FAR IN THE MAJOR LEAGUES.
NOW DICKERSON WATCHES THE FIRST
PITCH UPSTAIRS.
THERE IS A STORY TO THE HEAVY
SINKER USAGE SO FAR FROM MASON
THOMPSON THAT DAVE MARTINEZ TOLD
US EARLIER TODAY.
WHEN THOMPSON FIRST ARRIVED, THE
NATS STAFF LOVED HIS FASTBALL SO
MUCH AND WANTED HIM TO HONE IN
ON THE PITCH AND MAKE IT
COMPETITIVE, THEY SAID, JUST USE
THAT.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THE SLIDER.
NOW HE WILL IMPLEMENT THAT INTO
HIS GAME.
IT IS SUCH A SPECIAL PITCH WITH
POTENTIAL, THEY WANT HIM TO USE
THAT WITH CONFIDENCE AND
DELIVERING IN ALL FOUR QUADRANTS
OF THE ZONE AS WELL.
IT MOVES A TON.
DAN: I THINK YOU HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL.
IF YOU HAVE A TEAM LIKE THE BLUE
JAYS, THEY CAN STRIKE AND STRIKE
QUICKLY.
YOU START GOING UP THERE IF YOU
ARE THE BLUE JAYS LOOKING FOR
NUMBER ONE, NO MATTER  IF THE
MOVEMENT IS THERE OR NOT.
VELOCITY IS NOT DIFFICULT FOR
GUYS TO HIT.
THEY ARE USED TO HITTING VELO.
SCOTT: WE HAVE TALL PITCHERS ON
THE MOUND IN HONOR OF DAN
PLESAC.
THOMPSON IS 6'7".
THAT IS BALL FOUR.
DICKERSON IS ON.
HERNANDEZ TO SECOND.
THIS COULD BE A TROUBLESOME
INNING, THE BLUE JAYS LOOKING TO
DO DAMAGE AND PLAY CATCH UP IN
THE EIGHTH.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU HAVE?
>> YOU GUYS TALKING ABOUT MASON
THOMPSON NEEDING TO USE ALL FOUR
QUADRANTS OF THE STRIKE ZONE.
ANOTHER SUCCESSFUL LATE INNING
RELIEVER, SEAN DOOLIN, THREW A
HIGH PERCENTAGE OF FASTBALLS.
HE TOLD ME HE DID NOT VIEW THAT
AS ONE PITCH, BUT FOUR PITCHES
IF HE COULD LOCATE THAT TO ALL
FOUR QUADRANTS OF THE ZONE.
HE COULD THROW IT 90% OF THE
TIME BECAUSE HE WAS CHANGING EYE
LEVELS.
THE NATIONALS AS YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT, DOING THE SAME
TYPE OF APPROACH WITH MASON
THOMPSON.
YOU WERE VERY SUCCESSFUL FOR A
LONG TIME AT THE MAJOR LEAGUE
LEVEL.
I IMAGINE CHANGING EYE LEVELS,
YOU HAVE TO ATTACK HIM UPSTAIRS.
DAN P.: NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
YOU SEE A LOT OF MOVEMENT ON THE
PITCHES SO FAR FROM THOMPSON.
WHAT HAPPENS WITH A LOT OF YOUNG
PITCHERS, 10 GAMES, HE IS JUST
GETTING STARTED IN HIS
BIG-LEAGUE CAREER.
EVERY EXPERIENCE IS EIGHT
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE.
IT MIGHT BE GOOD MIXING IN A
COUPLE BREAKING BALLS.
EVEN THOUGH IT IS DOWN AND AWAY.
IF YOU ARE THE BLUE JAYS, YOU'RE
FORGETTING ABOUT ANYTHING THAT
IS OFFSPEED, YOU ARE GEARED FOR
NUMBER ONE AND THE MORE PITCHES
THAT YOU SEE, THE MORE YOU SEE,
THE MORE YOU LIKE, THE MORE YOU
GET THE TIME.
SCOTT: 1-0 TO GRICHUK.
NO?
2-0.
DAN P.: UPSTAIRS.
YOU PAINT YOURSELF IN THE CORNER
AND UNDERSTAND WHY IT IS
DIFFERENT LEVELS AT THE
BIG-LEAGUES THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO PITCH.
THE STRIKE ZONE RIGHT HERE FOR
MASON.
EVERY PITCHER LIKES THE HAPPY
ZONE YOU FEEL YOU CAN CLOSE YOUR
EYES AND THROW A STRIKE AT ANY
TIME.
HE HAS SO MUCH MOVEMENT THE BALL
IS DARTING ALL OVER THE PLACE.
IT IS SO NICE TO HAVE ONE SPOT,
I NEED TO THROW DOWN AND AWAY OR
DOWN AND IN.
HE IS HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME
GETTING THE BALL OVER THE WHITE
PLATE.
SCOTT: 3-0, MISSED AGAIN.
BAGS FULL OF BLUE JAYS IN THE
EIGHTH.
A HIT AND TWO WALKS TO START THE
INNING.
KYLE FINNEGAN HAS BEEN HIGH
LEVERAGE OUT OF THE BULLPEN FOR
THE NATS SINCE THE TRADE
DEADLINE.
HERE COMES DAVE MARTINEZ.
THAT WILL DO IT FOR MASON
THOMPSON.
THIS IS TURNING INTO A HIGH
POTENTIAL INNING IN THE EIGHTH,
TO BE ABLE TO FLIP THE LINEUP
CARD AND GET BACK TO THE TOP OF
THE ORDER.
8-3 AGAINST TORONTO WITH SIX
OUTS TO SPARE, IT IS NOT OVER.
♪
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT IF YOU HAVE
COME TO A GAME THIS SUMMER, YOU
HAVE NOTICED CHANGES IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
NEW RESTAURANTS, BUSINESSES,
PLACES TO HANG OUT.
I HAD TO ASK MY NEIGHBORS TO
SHOW ME AROUND.
I AM HERE WITH DARRELL WHO HAS
LIVED HERE SINCE 2006.
WHAT HAS THE TRANSFORMATION BEEN
LIKE SINCE YOU MOVED HERE UNTIL
NOW?
>> WE HAVE SEEN THIS AREA GROW
FROM A FEW BUILDINGS, A HOTEL,
OUR BUILDING, AND NOTHING ELSE.
ONCE THE GAME STARTED, WE SAW
SUCH A BIG DIFFERENCE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> WE BRANDED OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
IN A REGION OF 6.5 MILLION
PEOPLE.
WE SHOW PEOPLE HOW TO GET TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD THROUGH THE
GREENLINE.
IT BROUGHT NATIONAL BASEBALL
HERE ON A PERMANENT BASIS AND
PEOPLE COULD COME 81 TIMES A
YEAR.
>> THE NATIONALS AND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD HAVE EVOLVED
TOGETHER.
WHEN WE BOTH ARRIVED 15 YEARS
AGO, WE WERE FLEDGLING, AND SO
WAS THE TEAM.
WE WERE A CONTENDER AND SO WAS
THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
THEN THE NATS WERE A FIRST-PLACE
CLUB AND THE NEIGHBORHOOD WAS A
FIRST-CLASS PLACE.
SCOTT: DRAMA IN THE EIGHTH.
THIS MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE
ON YOUTUBE, PRESENTED BY
SPOTIFY, HOME OF THE JOE ROGAN
EXPERIENCE.
SCOTT BRAUN THREE TIME ALL-STAR
DAN PLESAC, AND DAN KOLKO LIVE
AT NATIONALS PARK.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING STATCAST
WITH NEW INSIGHTS, TAKING YOU
DEEPER INTO THE GAME THAN EVER
BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
THREE HITTERS SO FAR IN THE
EIGHTH FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
HERNANDEZ HIT, DICKERSON WALKED,
GRICHUK WALKED, AND A CHANCE TO
GO OVER AS WE CHECK OUT THE
ODDS, COURTESY OF FANDUEL.
YOU ARE BIG ON GOING AFTER THE
5.5 NUMBER.
DAN P.: I AM STAYING BULLISH THE
BLUE JAYS 0-6 WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION.
IN A GOOD SPOT, BASES LOADED.
IF YOU ARE THE NATIONALS, THIS
IS THE GUY YOU WANT IN, THEIR
MOST RELIABLE, KYLE FINNEGAN.
E.R.A. 3.11.
WALKS A LITTLE HIGH.
HEAVY SINKER USAGE.
ABOUT 70% OF THE PITCHES HE
THROWS OUR SINKERS.
THEY WOULD TRADE A RUN FOR A
GROUND DOUBLE PLAY RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: SANTIAGO, FIRST PITCH
MISSING WIDE.
DAN P.: ONE OF THE THINGS AS
DAVE MARTINEZ, YOU ARE TRYING TO
MANAGE, WIN, BUT GIVE THEM AN
IDEA WHAT IT IS LIKE TO WIN IN
THE BIG LEAGUES.
FANS ARE GETTING RESTLESS.
MASON THOMPSON HAVING DIFFICULTY
THROWING STRIKES.
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO MIX
YOUNGER PLAYERS IN, GIVE THEM A
CHANCE WHEN IT IS ON THE LINE,
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE YOU HAVE
TO MAKE A TOUGH CALL.
BASES LOADED, NOBODY OUT.
SCOTT: THIS HAS BEEN THEIR GUY,
FINNEGAN PICKING UP SIX SAVES.
ESPINAL, 3-4 WITH BASES LOADED,
A COUPLE DOUBLE DOUBLES.
DAN P.: IT WILL BE A LEARNING
EXPERIENCE FOR MASON THOMPSON.
HE WILL HAVE TO GET TO A SPOT
WHERE THERE IS A PLACE HE COULD
GO THAT IS SAFE, WHERE HE KNOWS
WITH HIS EYES CLOSED, AND THROW
A STRIKE.
HIS STUFF IS SO GOOD, IT GETS A
LOT OF MOVEMENT.
TERRIFIC PITCH BY FINNEGAN.
THOMPSON WILL GET BETTER.
THE VELOCITY IS THERE.
IT IS JUST THE ACCURACY, WHICH
WILL COME IN TIME.
OUT OF THE BULLPEN TWO THINGS
THAT KILL YOU ARE WALKS AND HOME
RUNS.
THIS HAS BEEN A SELF-INFLICTED
RALLY FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
BASE HIT AND A COUPLE WALKS.
THEY ARE LOADED WITH NOBODY OUT.
SCOTT: GIVE THEM AN INCH, THIS
TEAM WILL TAKE A MILE.
ESPINAL ON THE GROUND.
THAT SHOULD BE TWO TO TRADE THE
RUN FOR A DOUBLE PLAY -- NO.
IN COMES HERNANDEZ TO MAKE IT A
8-4 GAME.
FIELDER'S CHOICE'S SECOND BASE
WITH ONE DOWN IN THE EIGHTH.
DAN P.: TERRIFIC HUSTLE BY
ESPINAL.
REALLY GOOD.
GREAT JOB TOO BY FINNEGAN.
TRIED TO TURN THE PLATE -- THE
DOUBLE PLAY.
A STRONG THROW, BUT ESPINAL
BEATS IT BY HALF A STEP.
YOU CAN SEE THE EMPHATIC SAFE
CALL.
GOOD HUSTLE.
SCOTT: WINS THE RACE, GIVES THE
BLUE JAYS TWO OUTS TO PLAY WITH
IN THE EIGHTH AS WE CREEP CLOSER
TO THE TOP OF THE ORDER.
FOUR OF THE BETTER HITTERS IN
THE SPORT COMING UP AFTER
MCGUIRE AND A PINCH HITTER.
DAN P.: TALK ABOUT RIGHT OUT OF
THE BOX.
ESPINAL BEATS THIS ONE.
THAT IS A GOOD PLAY TO GET THE
RALLY GOING.
A DOUBLE PLAY IF YOU ARE
FINNEGAN IS WHAT THE DOCTOR
ORDERED.
YOU TRADED THE RUN FOR A COUPLE
OUTS.
BLUE JAYS BACK IN BUSINESS.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THE JAYS ARE
BACK IN THIS THING.
YOU CAN SEE WHY DAVE MARTINEZ
LIKES HIGH LEVERAGE SPOTS.
NOT AFRAID TO THROW STRIKES.
THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
HAVE TO DO COMING IN OUT OF THE
BULLPEN.
THERE IS SOME ANXIETY IN THAT
SPOT.
YOU ARE TRYING TO GET THE
GROUNDBALL DOUBLE PLAY.
GOING TO GET THE GROUNDBALL IT
IS NOT THAT EASY.
YOU DON'T HAVE CONTROL ONCE IT
LEAVES YOUR HAND.
SCOTT: MCGUIRE SPITZ ONE ON THE
GROUND, BRINGS IN ANOTHER RUN.
DICKERSON WILL SCORE, MCGUIRE
REACHES ON THE E4 AND THE INNING
CONTINUES WITH ONE OUT IN THE
EIGHTH.
IT IS 8-5.
DAN P.: HE MADE SUCH A NICE PLAY
ON THE GROUNDBALL.
THE LINE DRIVE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
HE IS THINKING ABOUT MAKING THE
THROW TO SECOND BASE.
HE IS ALREADY COMMITTED TO
MAKING THE PLAY AT SECOND BASE.
ONE THING YOU WANT TO DO IS MAKE
SURE YOU GET ONE OUT.
UNDERSTAND WHAT HE IS TRYING TO
DO, BUT THAT IS A PLAY YOU HAVE
TO GET AT LEAST ONE OUT.
SCOTT: NOW JUST A THREE RUN GAME
.
SCORES DICKERSON, MAGUIRE IS AT
FIRST.
--MCGUIRE IS AT FIRST.
LOOK BEHIND HIM FOR THE GOTLAND,
WHICH BEGINS WITH SEMIEN.
YOU TALK ABOUT DANGER LURKING.
IT IS LURKING ON THE ON DECK
CIRCLE.
THAT IS WHY THE BLUE JAYS ARE SO
EXPLOSIVE.
THEY WILL TURN THE LINEUP OVER.
HE WILL BEAT OUT, STAY OUT OF
THE DOUBLE PLAY AT LEAST TO GET
ONE OUT.
SCOTT: THE PINCH HITTER HAS
EXCELLENT BAT TO BALL SKILLS.
FINNEGAN STARTS HIM OFF WITH A
BREAKING BALL.
TO GET THE RUN IN 8-6.
SCOTT: OUR YOUTUBE CREATORS ARE
LOVING IT RIGHT NOW.
HE SAID THIS GAME IS VERY SPICY.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING.
WE ARE WITH YOU.
BASE HIT, ANOTHER ONE FOR THE
BLUE JAYS.
IT IS 8-6.
>> HERE THEY COME, THIS IS WHAT
THE BLUE JAYS DO.
THEY CAN BEAT UP ON YOU IN A
HURRY.
THIS ONE LOOKED OVER AT ABOUT
THE THIRD INNING, 8-1.
FASTBALL BULLET HIT UP THE
MIDDLE.
NOT A PARTICULARLY GOOD PITCH
FROM FAGAN.
-- FINNEGAN.
A BULLET RIGHT BACK UP THE
MIDDLE.
JAYS IN BUSINESS.
1-2, ONE OUT.
TOP OF THE ORDER, ROLLING THINGS
OVER.
SCOTT: A RUN OF FOUR ALL-STARS
IN THE ORDER FOR TORONTO.
THEY KNOW HOW MUCH THIS GAME
MEANS TO THE BLUE JAYS.
FIRST OF ALL, THIS WOULD BE AN
EPIC RALLY BACK.
THEY WERE DOWN 8-1.
SOME TEAMS DOWN SEVEN RUNS, I
MIGHT FLIP TO ANOTHER BALLGAME.
NOT WHEN YOU ARE WATCHING THE
BLUE JAYS THIS SEASON.
DAN P.: ANOTHER THING TO GO
UNNOTICED, TWO SOLID INNINGS
FROM CONNOR OVERTON.
SIX UP, SIX DOWN, CAP THE
NATIONALS AT BAY, KEPT THIS IN
STRIKING DISTANCE TO GET THE
BOOT -- TO GET THE BLUE JAYS
BACK INTO THIS.
YOU MAY START SEEING OVERTON IN
MORE HIGH LEVERAGE SPOTS.
BIG KEY, SIX UP, SIX DOWN.
SCOTT: AN ERROR IN THE INNING IN
THE EIGHTH AND THREE RUNS FOR
THE BLUE JAYS.
SEMIEN IN THE AIR.
TWO GONE IN THE EIGHTH.
DAN P.: THAT MIGHT BE THE
BIGGEST OUT.
1-2, OVERTON MAKES A GOOD PITCH.
A SLIDER TO THE MIDDLE OF THE
PLATE.
HAD A BIT OF LATE MOVEMENT.
JUST ENOUGH TO GET SEMIEN OUT
FRONT TO RIGHT FIELD.
SCOTT: HE IS IN FOR KIRK.
MCGUIRE IS AT SECOND.
BO BICHETTE WITH THE GO-AHEAD
RUN.
DAN P.: 96, FOUR SEAMER UP IN
THE ZONE.
A PRETTY GOOD NIGHT FOR BO
BICHETTE.
STOLEN BASE AND A RUN SCORED.
SNEAKY, 20 BOMBS ON THE YEAR.
SCOTT: A LONG PAUSE FOR
FINNEGAN.
HERE WE GO.
DAN P.: PRETTY NICE BLOCK BY
RILEY ADAMS.
YOU CAN SEE A NICE BACKHAND
STOP.
THAT GETS THROUGH THE WICKETS,
STARTS TO GET REAL DICEY.
SCOTT: BIG-TIME MATCH UP
FINNEGAN WITH VLADDY ON DECK.
1-1.
THAT IS A CALLED STRIKE.
BO IS NOT FEELING IT.
DAN P.: THAT WOULD BE ON THE
OUTSIDE PART OF THE STRIKE ZONE.
WHAT DO THOSE SWING PITCHES DO?
THE BALL LOOKS A COUPLE INCHES
OFF THE PLATE.
INSTEAD OF BEING 2-1, IT IS 1-2.
NOW YOU CAN EXPAND THE PLATE A
LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: A LITTLE FRAMING 101 BY
RILEY ADAMS OFF THE DISH.
TO SECOND FOR GARCIA AND HE WILL
GO TO FIRST.
THOUGHT ABOUT AN UNDERHAND TOSS.
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN A WORLD OF
TROUBLE TO KEEP THE INNING
GOING.
INSTEAD, THE NATS ESCAPE.
THE BLUE JAYS ARE INCHING
CLOSER.
VLADDY JR. WILL LEADOFF IN THE
TOP OF THE NINTH INNING.
FIRST, A CHANCE FOR THE NATS TO
ADD INSURANCE.
THIS IS A BALLGAME, AS EXPECTED.
DON'T COUNT OUT THE BLUE JAYS.
8-6.
>> I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
YOUR NATIONALS DEBUT.
YOU MADE A COUPLE APPEARANCES
FOR THE DODGERS, ONE RELIEF
APPEARANCE, ONE START.
THEN THEY ACQUIRE YOU IN AN
ABSOLUTE MONSTER DEAL.
FOR A FUTURE HALL OF FAMER AND
ANOTHER ALL-STAR.
YOU COME TO AN ORGANIZATION THAT
CLEARLY LOVES WHAT YOU BRING TO
THE TABLE AND THEN YOU GO OUT A
COUPLE DAYS AFTER YOU WERE
ACQUIRED AND YOU ARE ON THE
MOUND IN THEIR BALLPARK WITH
THEIR FANS SUPPORTING YOU.
TAKE ME THROUGH THAT DAY AND
WHAT THE SPECIFIC MEMORIES YOU
THINK WILL RESONATE WITH YOU FOR
YEARS TO COME.
JOSIAH: THAT WAS AWESOME.
THE JITTERS WEREN'T TOO CRAZY.
I FELT COMFORTABLE, CONFIDENT AS
I ALWAYS AM.
I GET OUT THERE ON THE MOUND.
FROM PITCH ONE TO PITCH 70 I
FELT GREAT.
COMING OFF THE MOUND AFTER THAT
FIRST INNING, A LIGHT STANDING
OVATION YOU COULD CALL IT.
OBVIOUSLY SEEING ONE OF MY
FORMER COACHES IN THE STANDS,
THE DUGOUT.
EVERYONE ROOTING FOR ME, THAT
WAS AWESOME.
SCOTT: THIS GAME HAS TIGHTENED
UP.
JUAN SOTO WILL LEAD IN THE HOME
EIGHTH FOR THE NATIONALS.
NOW LEADING BY JUST A PAIR OF
RUNS AFTER JUMPING AHEAD 8-1
EARLIER IN THE GAME.
WE ENTER THE FIFTH.
THE BLUE JAYS BULLPEN WILL KEEP
THIS CLOSE.
TAYLOR SALCEDO -- SAUCEDO IS IN
THE BULLPEN.
WE DID SEE THORNTON GIVE AWAY A
HOME RUN TO THE FIRST BATTER
THAT HE FACED.
FACED JUST 12 IT RUNNERS.
SOME EXCELLENT PERFORMANCES.
NOW, IT IS SAUCEDO'S TURN.
DAN P.: KYLE OVERTON WAS
IMPRESSIVE.
SIX UP, SIX DOWN.
THEY WERE ABLE TO COME THROUGH
WITH SIX RUNS IN THE TOP OF THE
EIGHTH.
IT DOES NOT GET ANY EASIER.
LAST AT BAT HE WAS HIT WITH A
FASTBALL.
YOU CAN SEE THE SMART, LIKE NOT
ANOTHER ONE.
THE NATS WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON.
SOTO, BELL, AND HERNANDEZ COMING
UP.
SCOTT: SOTO CONNECTS SOLIDLY
INTO THE GAP IN RIGHT-CENTER.
STANDUP DOUBLE TO LEADOFF FOR
THE EIGHTH.
DAN P.: THERE ARE SO MANY GOOD
LEFT-HANDED HITTERS IN THE GAME,
BUT YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE BEST
OF THE BUNCH.
IT IS AN OLD-SCHOOL APPROACH.
HE DID NOT HIT ONE BALL THINKING
UP THE MIDDLE.
THAT WAS A SWING HE WAS WORKING
ON AT 4:30 IN THE AFTERNOON.
THERE IS A METHOD TO THE
MADNESS.
POWER TO ALL FIELDS.
VERY RARELY EXPANDS THE STRIKE
ZONE.
SPECIAL PLAYER.
HE IS THE BEST LEFT-HANDED
HITTER IN BASEBALL.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT HIM.
SCOTT: 116 MILES PER HOUR OFF
THE BAT.
THIS GUY IS HITTING THE BASEBALL
HARDER THAN EVER.
IT IS JOSH BELL, WHO HAS NOT
BEEN AS DYNAMITE AS HIS ALL-STAR
2019 SEASON.
BUT WE ARE SEEING A CAREER-HIGH
HARD-HIT RATE, THE PERCENTAGE OF
BALLS AT 95 PLUS OFF THE BATS.
THE NATS HAVE LIKED A LOT OF
WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING AT SO FAR
FROM JOSH BELL IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
DAN P.: GOING BACK TO BATTING
PRACTICE, YOU HEAR SCOUTS SAY
THE SOUND IS DIFFERENT.
JUAN SOTO AT 4:00 THIS
AFTERNOON, JUST WATCHING HIM HIT
LINE DRIVE, A LOT OF SHORTSTOP
POSITION.
IT SOUNDED LIKE HE WAS HITTING
IT WITH A TELEPHONE POLE.
HE MUST HAVE HIT OUT OF FIVE OR
SIX SWINGS FOUR LINE DRIVES UP
THE LEFT CENTER FIELD WALL.
HE IS A TREMENDOUS HITTER THAT
WORKS AT HIS CRAFT.
YOU CAN SEE WHY WHEN YOU WATCH
BATTING PRACTICE.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHY HE IS ALWAYS
SMILING.
TO SOTO.
THIS WOULD BE A BIG RUN FOR THE
NATS.
MAN ON THIRD.
DAN P.: T SINKERWO SEAM -- TWO
SEAM SINKER OFF THE GLOVE.
RUNS ARE AT A PREMIUM.
THERE IS A GOOD LOOK AT IT.
DOWN TWO RUNS, YOU CAN ILL
AFFORD TO GIVE UP ANOTHER.
IT IS INTERESTING TO SEE, IT IS
HARD TO DO WHEN YOU HAVE THE
INFIELD IN LIKE THIS.
YOU HAVE TO READ AN ANGLE, WHERE
THE BALL IS AT.
SCOTT: IT IS ON THE GROUND TO
THE DRAWN IN INFIELD AND THE
PLAY IS MADE FOR OUT NUMBER ONE.
DAN P.: ONE OF THE KEYS, YOU
HAVE TO KEEP THE BALL DOWN IN
THE ZONE.
YOUR INFIELDERS, THEIR RANGE IS
SO LIMITED.
YOU DON'T DO YOURSELF MUCH OF A
SERVICE IF YOU DO NOT PITCH INTO
THE ZONE.
YOU'RE PLAYING FOR THE
GROUNDBALL, A TERRIFIC PITCH.
SCOTT: FIRST OUT PICKED UP BY
SAUCEDO.
DAN P.: WHAT MAKES IT SO
DIFFICULT WITH THE THREE BATTER
MINIMUM, YOU GET TO A
RIGHT-HANDER AND HAVE TO BE
FORCED TO HAVE A LEFTY.
THE BLUE JAYS HAVE A
RIGHT-HANDER UP IN THE BULLPEN.
ALMOST IF YOU ARE CHARLIE
MONTOYO, A WALK WOULD NOT BE THE
WORST THING WHERE YOU COULD GET
A MATCHUP THAT IS FAVORABLE.
SCOTT: IF HERNANDEZ DRIVES IN
ANOTHER RUN, HE COULD BE YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
THAT LAST PLAY, MADE BY VALERA.
SEMIEN SHIFTS TO SHORTSTOP.
BICHETTE IS DONE FOR THE DAY.
HE CAN HANDLE THE POSITION.
MARCUS SEMIEN, REGULAR SHORTSTOP
FOR OAKLAND AND HE IMPROVED,
WORKING WITH RON WASHINGTON
QUITE A BIT.
DAN P.: IF YOU ARE LANE THOMAS,
YOU WANT TO GET A BALL UP IN THE
ZONE.
TRYING TO GET THE GROUNDBALL.
A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO GET
THE RUNNER IN.
WE TALK ABOUT PUTTING THE BALL
IN PLAY, THE PRESSURE.
A FAVORABLE COUNTS, LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING, PREFERABLY HE CAN GET
UP IN THE AIR.
SCOTT: 3-1 TO THOMAS.
HERNANDEZ IS DONE.
WE ARE UP AND THIS GUY IN THE
PRESS BOX, BUT HERNANDEZ
REPLACED YOU.
LANE THOMAS WITH A CHANCE TO DO
SOMETHING SPECIAL IN THE FIVE
SPOT.
DAN P.: HAVE TO BE REALLY
CAREFUL RIGHT HERE.
A WALK WOULD NOT BE THE WORST
THING IN THE WORLD.
COULD STILL SET UP A DOUBLE
PLAY.
A LITTLE ANXIOUS, SWUNG AT BALL
FOUR.
I THINK YOU WOULD WANT TO GO
BACK DOWN IN THE ZONE FOR GUYS
SWINGING 3-1.
TRY TO STAY OUT OF THE MIDDLE OF
THE PLATE.
A COUPLE OF BASES OPEN.
SCOTT: THERE IS BALL FOUR, I
THINK.
GO AHEAD, IT IS YOURS.
NO CHARGE.
LANE THOMAS WILL TAKE FIRST.
A TWO HIT.
HIS FIRST TWO AB'S WERE HITS.
PASS THE BATON TO CARTER
KIEBOOM.
SCOTT: -- DAN P.: IT LOOKS LIKE
THE BLUE JAYS WILL ELECT TO
PITCH TO KIEBOOM.
WITH THE LEFT-HANDER GARCIA ON
DECK.
CARTER IS 1-2 TONIGHT.
SINGLE IN THE SECOND, SAC FLY IN
THE THIRD.
THAT WAS THE BIG INNING FOR THE
NATS.
THEY POURED ON SIX RUNS AGAINST
ALEK MANOAH.
FIRST PITCH CHANGEUP.
SEEING IF KIEBOOM WOULD BE
OVERLY AGGRESSIVE SWINGING EARLY
IN THE COUNT.
IT IS A SITUATION DAVE MARTINEZ
AND THE NATS ARE LOOKING FORWARD
TO SEEING.
WILL HE BE A MIDDLE PART OF THE
ORDER GUY GOING INTO THE 2022
SEASON?
SCOTT: HE IS A FORMER
FIRST-ROUND PICK IN 2016.
THEY HAD HIGH EXPECTATIONS FOR
HIM.
THE CONCERN WAS MORE ON THE
GLOVE SIDE.
IT IS THE BATS THAT HAS BEEN
SLOW TO COME AROUND.
DAN P.: TO THIS POINT THE NATS
HAVE BEEN PATIENTS, AND HAVE
GIVEN OPPORTUNITIES TO ESTABLISH
THEMSELVES.
SCOTT: THERE IS A STRIKE FROM
SAUCEDO.
DAN P.: THE BALL MIGHT HAVE BEEN
A LITTLE BIT IN.
MAY HAVE BEEN LIKE A BALL OFF
THE PLATE, A BALL OR TWO.
SCOTT: THAT IS A GOOD TAKE.
ANOTHER TAKE.
3-1.
DAN P.: THIS IS WHERE YOU REALLY
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
THIS GAME IS STILL IN ORDER FOR
THE BLUE JAYS.
IF YOU ARE DAVE MARTINEZ, I AM
SURE YOU ARE TURNING KIEBOOM
LOOSE.
YOU WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO GIVE
KIEBOOM A CHANCE TO SWING THE
BAT HERE.
SCOTT: HE DOES AND FOULS IT OFF.
DAN P.: ANOTHER BREAKING BALL
THE INNER THIRD.
THAT CUT FASTBALL IN.
WE HAVE SEEN SAUCEDO GO TO THE
CIRCLE CHANGEUP DOWN AND AWAY.
TWO SEAM CHANGEUP, FAST AND
AWAY.
SCOTT: SOTO AND THOMAS ARE ON
FOR THE NATIONALS.
THEY HAVE NOT SCORED SINCE THE
FOURTH.
ANOTHER WALK.
KIEBOOM ON BOARD.
WHAT IS THE PLAN?
DAN P.: YOU HAVE A PINCH HITTER,
LOOKS LIKE RYAN ZIMMERMAN, ONE
OF THE ORIGINAL NATS.
YOU WILL HAVE TO GET THE LEFTY.
SCOTT: RYAN ZIMMERMAN FEASTS ON
LEFT-HANDED PITCHING.
THAT IS HIS SPECIALTY THESE DAYS
AND HE IS MR. NATIONAL.
THEIR FIRST-EVER DRAFT PICK AND
FRANCHISE LEADER IN MOST OF THE
MAJOR CATEGORIES.
WE WILL WATCH HIM WORK IN A
CLUTCH SPOT WHEN WE COME BACK ON
YOUTUBE.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HIS
YOUNG CAREER, ALEK MANOAH WILL
TAKE ON THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
>> THIS WILL BE A CHALLENGE FOR
ALEK MANOAH.
IT WILL BE A GOOD RAYS TEAM.
>> WE WANT TO GET THE BALL
ROLLING FOR THE REST OF THE
WEEKEND.
I WAS HUNGRY TO GET BACK OUT
THERE.
>> 2-2 PITCH.
A SLIDER HERE.
>> HE STRIKES OUT AROZARENA.
FOUR STRIKEOUTS IN A ROW FOR
MANOAH.
>> HE GAVE US WHAT WE WANTED AND
NEEDED.
HE WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> A LOT OF STRIKES.
THAT IS 10 STRIKEOUTS FOR MANOAH
.
>> SEVEN INNINGS IN THE BOOKS,
SHUTTING OUT THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
SCOTT: HANG OUT WITH US EVERY
WEEK ON YOUTUBE.
HERE IS WHAT WE HAVE TO WORK
WITH THE REST OF THE SEASON.
NEXT WEEK WE ARE IN HOUSTON FOR
THE ROYALS AT ASTROS.
AND TWO FIRST PLACE BALLCLUBS
SEPTEMBER 2.
THEN WE HAVE THE MARINERS AND
ASTROS.
WE FINISH UP THE SCHEDULE WITH
THE CARDINALS AND THE BREWERS,
TWO TEAMS IN THE N.L. CENTRAL.
ONE THAT LOOKS LIKE A LOCK FOR
THE POSTSEASON.
THE CARDINALS MAKING A LATE PUSH
AS WELL.
IT IS FREE AND EASY.
JOIN US EVERY SINGLE WEEK RIGHT
HERE, LIKE YOU ARE DOING RIGHT
NOW.
THIS IS AN 8-6 GAME.
BASES ARE LOADED FOR THE NATS.
SAUCEDO IS REPLACED.
ZIMMERMAN MAKES A TON OF SENSE
BECAUSE HE EATS UP SOUTHPAWS
THESE DAYS.
DAN P.: ONE THING CONCERNING,
THE WALKS.
AT TIMES HAS A DIFFICULT TIME
THROWING STRIKES.
MR. ALL-TIME NATIONAL LEADS THE
NATS IN JUST ABOUT EVERY
OFFENSIVE CATEGORY.
HIS 281 HOME RUNS A RECORD FOR
THE EXPOS-NATIONALS.
SCOTT: A FEW CLUTCH HITS FOR THE
FRANCHISE.
16 SEASONS.
DAN P.: ELECTED NOT TO PLAY IN
THE COVID-RIDDLED 2020 SEASON.
SCOTT: HE IS 36 AND HE SPITS AT
THE FIRST PITCH FROM DOLIS.
6-8 IN THE EIGHTH.
DAN P.: DOLIS ONE OF THE BETTER
FASTBALL HITTERS.
UP OUT OVER THE PLATE.
YOU CAN SEE THE BLUE JAYS HAVE
IT SHADED TOWARD RIGHT CENTER
FIELD.
A GAP DOWN THE LINE.
SCOTT: DOLIS DELIVERS.
ZIMMERMAN WATCHES.
BALL TWO.
DAN P.: A LOT OF MOVEMENT ON THE
FASTBALL.
IF YOU ARE DAVE MARTINEZ, A
VETERAN HITTER UP.
DIFFICULTY THROWING STRIKES.
THE PITCHES PROBABLY A 2-0
BREAKING BALL.
YOU ARE HUNTING A HEATER.
IF YOU GET IT, TURN IT LOOSE.
SCOTT: SIX CAREER GRAND SLAMS.
HE WAS GOING FOR SEVEN.
DAN P.: THE MOVEMENT WAS ABLE TO
TANGLE THAT SWING AND A MISS.
YOU SEE HIS TWO-SEAM FASTBALL,
YOU SEE THE ROTATION.
ZIMMERMAN LIKES IT UP THERE.
THAT IS ABOUT ARMPIT HIGH.
SCOTT: SOTO STARTED THE EIGHTH
WITH A DOUBLE.
LANE THOMAS WALKED.
SO DID CARTER KIEBOOM.
ONE OUT, BAGS FULL.
NATS DOWN BY TWO.
2-1 TO ZIMMERMAN.
MAKE IT 3-1.
DAN P.: THAT IS THE SPLIT CIDER
HE THROWS, IT BACKED UP ON HIM.
A TOUGH SPOT IF YOU ARE CHARLIE
MONTOYO, BRINGING IN A RELIEVER
THAT HAS DIFFICULTY THROWING
STRIKES AND YOU BRING HIM INTO A
BASES-LOADED ONE OUT SPOT.
NOT AN IDEAL SITUATION, BUT IT
IS WHAT IT IS.
SCOTT: YOU WILL SEE A BIG SWING
FROM ZIMM.
THERE IT IS, DEEP DRIVE LEFT
FIELD WARNING TRACK, NOT ENOUGH
TO BRING HOME EVERYONE, BUT IT
WILL SCORE A KEY INSURANCE RUN
FOR THE NATIONALS.
JUAN SOTO SCORES AND MAKES IT
9-6.
ZIMM DOES HIS JOB IN A
PINCH-HITTING ROLE.
DAN P.: THAT WOULD BE THE NINTH
CAREER GRAND SLAM FOR ZIMM.
JUST OUT IN FRONT RIGHT HERE.
DOLIS FALLS BEHIND IN THE COUNT.
A 3-1 FASTBALL DOWN THE MIDDLE,
OFF THE END OF THE BAT.
RYAN IT AS SOON AS HE HIT IT.
SCOTT: THAT SOUNDED GOOD.
A LITTLE PADDING FOR THE NATS
BULLPEN IN THE NINTH.
LANE THOMAS HUSTLED HIS WAY FROM
SECOND TO THIRD AREA THEY ARE ON
THE CORNERS FOR RILEY ADAMS WHO
HOMERED TONIGHT.
THAT IS FOUL.
TWO HITS FOR ADAMS.
TWO YOUNG CATCHERS AFTER YEARS
OF SUZUKI AND GOMES.
AN EXCELLENT VETERAN TANDEM.
SPLITS TIME WITH CHASE PERERA.
THE FORMER BLUE JAYS PROSPECT.
HE WOULD LOVE ANOTHER.
DAN P.: THAT IS PROBABLY THE
BEST PITCH DOLIS HAS THROWN, A
GOOD TWO-SEAM FASTBALL.
95, DROVE THE BALL INTO THE
STRIKE ZONE.
A LOOK AT GERARDO PARRA ON-DECK.
HE OF THE BABY SHARK FAME.
SCOTT: THE SONG LIVES ON.
IF THE INNING CONTINUES, I WILL
BE HARSH.
DAN P.: I WILL LAY OUT AND LET
IT BREATHE.
SCOTT: ADAMS FOULS ANOTHER ONE.
DAN P.: THAT SPLIT SLIDER.
YOU CAN SEE WHY DOLIS WOULD HAVE
DIFFICULTY IN THE STRIKE ZONE.
EVERYTHING HE THROWS RUNS INTO A
RIGHTY DOWN AND AWAY TO A LEFTY.
IF YOU ARE A RIGHT-HANDED
HITTER, YOU HAVE A GOOD IDEA THE
BALL WILL BE COMING IN TOWARDS
YOU.
SCOTT:
A QUICK CHECK OVER TO
FIRST --
DAN P.: HE WAS PLAYING UP A
LITTLE BIT.
CAUGHT THE BALL, HE WAS A COUPLE
FEET FROM HOME PLATE IN FRONT OF
FIRST BASE.
SCOTT: ADAMS TO RIGHT AND THE
NATS DO ADD ON.
LANE THOMAS IS IN AND KIEBOOM
WAVED AROUND.
TROUBLE IN RIGHT FIELD, THE NATS
GET ANOTHER RUN.
IT IS 11-6.
DAN P.: HE HAS HAD SOME KIND OF
A NIGHT.
TAKES A GOOD FASTBALL.
DOES NOT TRY TO PULL IT.
HITS A BULLET DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
THE UNDERBELLY OF THE BLUE JAYS
HAS BEEN THAT BULLPEN.
THEY HAVE BEEN THROWING THE BALL
BETTER THE LAST WEEK TO 10 DAYS,
BUT IT HAS COME BACK TO BITE
THEM TONIGHT.
TWO SEAM FASTBALL.
RILEY DOES A GREAT JOB, DOES NOT
TRY TO PULL THIS.
HITS A BULLET DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
YOU CAN SEE KIEBOOM BEING WAVED
IN.
A COUPLE BIG INSURANCE RUNS FOR
THE CURLY W'S.
SCOTT: THAT BOUNCED IN A GOOD
SPOT FOR THE OFFENSE INTO THE
CORNER.
HERNANDEZ ABLE TO GRAB IT, BUT
NOT BEFORE TWO MORE RUNS SCORE
FOR THE NATS.
A  THREE RUN EIGHTH AND A FIVE
RUN LEAD.
PARRA SWINGS AND MISSES.
ADAMS DOING IT AGAINST A TEAM
THAT TRADED HIM A FEW WEEKS AGO.
DAN P.: 2022 AND BEYOND, WHERE
WILL THE NATIONALS BE?
A LOT OF PLAYERS AUDITIONING FOR
THE FUTURE.
DAVE MARTINEZ LOOKING AT THE
LINEUP CARD, SEEING WHO HE HAS
AVAILABLE.
A BIG NIGHT FOR RILEY ADAMS.
3-4, A SOLO BOMB TO GO ALONG
WITH IT.
PRETTY NIFTY SLIDE BY CARTER
KIEBOOM.
GETS THE GUARD ON THE LEFT-HAND
AND SLIDES IT OVER THE TOP OF
HOME PLATE.
SCOTT: ENOUGH OF AN VANTAGE
POINT IF YOU ARE IN THE
NATIONALS.
YOUR TEAM IS TRYING TO WIPE AWAY
A SEVEN-GAME LOSING SKID.
THIS WOULD BE A NICE W FOR THE
NATS, UP AGAINST A VERY
COMPETITIVE TORONTO BLUE JAYS
COMING TO TOWN FOR TWO.
DAN P.: I'M SURE THE BLUE JAYS
HAVE TRIED SO MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS TO GET DOLIS GOING.
SO DELIBERATE BETWEEN PITCHES.
IT IS A HARD TIME TO BUILD
TIMING OR RHYTHM.
A LOT OF TIME IN BETWEEN.
AS YOU ARE PLAYING BEHIND A GUY
LIKE THIS, YOU GET ON THE HEELS
OF YOUR FEET, DANCING AROUND THE
STRIKE ZONE, SPEND SO MUCH TIME
WALKING AROUND.
IT SORT OF LULLS YOU TO SLEEP.
IT IS HARD TO BE A CONSISTENT
STRIKE THROWER WHEN YOU SPEND AS
MUCH TIME BETWEEN PITCHES AS HE
DOES.
SCOTT: TALK TO ANY POSITION
PLAYER ABOUT THAT, THEY HATE IT.
THEY WANT PACE, THEY WANT TO BE
ON THEIR TOES.
NEXT PITCH COMING THROUGH, STAY
ALERT.
DAN P.: THE NATIONALS HAVE MADE
BLUE J-ROLL HE WORKED FAVORABLE
COUNTS.
-- THEY HAVE MADE THE BLUE JAYS
WORK FAVORABLE COUNTS.
VERY GOOD SITUATIONAL HITTING
TONIGHT FROM THE NATIONALS.
THEY HAD A DIFFICULT TIME SINCE
THE TRADE DEADLINE.
IT IS NOT EASY WHEN YOU HAVE
GUYS LIKE SCHWARBER AND SCHERZER
GONE.
AS DAVE MARTINEZ TOLD US EARLY
ON, THEY ARE LOOKING FOR 2022
AND BEYOND.
THEIR GM IS A WINNING
ORGANIZATION.
THEY ARE ALL ABOUT WINNING AND
2022 THEY WANT TO BE BACK IN
CONTENTION.
SCOTT: A QUICK RELOAD.
YOU CAN LOOK AT THE TORONTO BLUE
JAYS 15-16.
THEY WERE IN THE POSTSEASON,
THEN DOWN A FEW YEARS AS THEY
LOADED BACKUP.
IT WAS NOT THIS 5, 6 YEAR, TEAR
IT DOWN AS WE HAVE SEEN.
LIKE THE ASTROS AND THE CUBS.
DAN P.: WHEN YOU HAVE A YOUNG
PITCHER, THERE IS A GUY GOING
TOMORROW, JOSIAH GRAY --
SCOTT: ROBLES PASSES THIRD.
RILEY ADAMS WILL SCORE, MAKE IT
12-6.
DAN P.: THIS IS THE KIND OF GAME
THE BLUE JAYS SAW TOO OFTEN, THE
BULLPEN BEING THERE ACHILLES
HEEL.
THE NATS ARE POURING IT ON.
FORTUNATELY IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE, IF YOU ARE CHARLIE
MONTOYO, YOU HAVE TO LET DOLIS
WORK THROUGH THIS ONE.
YOU HATE TO EMPTY OUT THE
BULLPEN WITH THE GAME.
FORTUNATELY, THE BLUE JAYS HAVE
THE DAY OFF.
THEY HAVE THE TIGERS COMING IN
FRIDAY, SATURDAY, SUNDAY.
TOUGH PART OF THE SCHEDULE
COMING UP FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
SCOTT: THIS WAS ALEK MANOAH'S
NIGHT.
DAN P.: CONOR OVERTON, IT WAS
TERRIFIC.
SIX UP, SIX DOWN, KEPT THE BLUE
JAYS IN ITS.
GIVE THE NATS HITTERS CREDIT.
THEY MADE THE BLUE JAY RELIEVERS
THROW STRIKES.
WHEN THEY HAVE GOTTEN FAVORABLE
COUNTS, THEY HAVE PUT WOOD TO
THE BALL.
IGNITE FOR RILEY ADAMS.
SCOTT: A 27 MINUTE INNING.
YOU WILL HAVE TO GET YOUR PICK
SOON FOR YOU TO PLAYER OF THE
GAME.
DOLIS TO ESCOBAR ON THE GROUND.
IT IS SEMIEN TO SECOND.
THE NATS GO DOWN IN THE EIGHTH,
A 28 AND INNING -- MINUTE HALF
INNING.
THE NATIONALS PAD THEIR LEAD.
12-6 AFTER EIGHT.
VLADDY JR. LEADING OFF THE
NINTH.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HIS
YOUNG CAREER, ALEK MANOAH WILL
TAKE ON THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
>> THIS WILL BE A CHALLENGE, A
GOOD RAYS TEAM.
>> WE CAN SET THE TONE, KEEP THE
BALL GOING.
I AM HUNGRY TO GET BACK OUT
THERE.
>> 2-2 PITCHED.
BREAKING BALL AND A MISS.
>> TWO STRIKES, AROZARENA.
>> HE GAVE US EVERYTHING WE
WANTED AND NEEDED.
>> SIX IN A ROW.
THAT IS 10 STRIKEOUTS FOR MANOAH
.
ALEK MANOAH, SEVEN INNINGS IN
THE BOOKS.
JUST THREE HITS AND 10
STRIKEOUTS.
SCOTT: IT IS THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED
BY SPOTIFY, THE EXCLUSIVE HOME
OF THE JOE ROGAN EXPERIENCE.
WATCH EPISODES FREE ON SPOTIFY.
THE NATS HAD A BIG BOTTOM OF THE
EIGHTH.
TO MAKE IT MORE CUSHY TO TRY TO
SHUT THE DOOR AGAINST VLAD JR.,
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ, AND COREY
DICKERSON, DUE UP FOR THE
VISITING BLUE JAYS.
DAN P.: PRETTY COLE PITCH
SEQUENCE BY FINNEGAN.
BO BICHETTE GETS A FASTBALL TO
THE ZONE.
PITCH OFF THE CORNER A COUPLE
INCHES AND HE GETS A BALL RIGHT
HERE, DRIVES IT BACK UP.
A BIG OUT BY FINNEGAN.
PITCHED AROUND SHADY DEFENSE.
HAD THAT ROUGH NIGHT SUNDAY
AFTERNOON IN SEATTLE.
FIVE STRIKEOUTS, CAME BACK WITH
A BIG TWO OUT NIGHT.
SCOTT: IT IS TIME.
TONIGHT'S YOU TO PLAYER OF THE
GAME IS DECIDED BY YOU RIGHT
NOW.
VOTE, PLEASE.
YADIEL HERNANDEZ, ALCIDES
ESCOBAR, RILEY ADAMS, ERICK
FEDDE.
YOU COULD SWAY THE VOTE BEFORE
THEY DECIDE.
DAN P.: I WILL GO WITH THE
FORMER BLUE JAY, RILEY ADAMS.
HAS HAD A BIG NIGHT.
THREE HITS, SOLO HOME RUN IN THE
FOURTH INNING.
SCOTT: HE IS CATCHING THE
26-YEAR-OLD, KEEPING THE THEME
ALIVE OF TALL PITCHERS ON A
TUESDAY.
6'7" ON THE MOUND.
DAN P.: IF YOU'RE DAVE MARTINEZ,
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE HIM ATTACK
THE STRIKE ZONE.
SCOTT: DAVE GETS A GROUND BALL
AND IT IS PAST THE INFIELD.
VLADDY JR. IS ON AGAIN.
DAN P.: NOT MUCH YOU CAN DO
ABOUT THAT.
THAT IS WHY HE IS SUCH A GOOD
HITTER.
95 MILE PER HOUR PLUS FASTBALL.
HE BEATS IT INTO THE GROUND AND
A HIGH CHOPPER GETS THROUGH.
IT IS WHY HE HITS OVER .300.
GREAT BAT TO BALL SKILLS.
SCOTT: HE HAS ONLY ONE
EXTRA-BASE HIT IN HIS LAST 13
GAMES.
HE IS GETTING ON A TIME WITH
SINGLES AND WALKS.
THAT IS A STRIKE TO TEOSCAR
HERNANDEZ WHO HOMERED IN THE
FIFTH.
DAN P.: THAT OUTSIDE CORNER HAS
BEEN STRETCHED TONIGHT.
PITCHERS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE.
THAT BALL UP THE PLATE HAS BEEN
CALLED A STRIKE MOST OF THE
NIGHT.
DAN P.: HOW MANY BUTTONS ARE OFF
FOR KLOBOSITS?
DID YOU EVER SPORT THAT LOOK.
>> THAT WAS NOT MY LOOK.
A LITTLE BIT MORE CONSERVATIVE,
BUTTONED UP.
SCOTT: PERFECTLY STATED.
HERNANDEZ FOULS IT BACK.
DAN P.: THESE ARE THE KIND OF
GAMES IF YOU ARE DAVE MARTINEZ,
YOU ARE STRIKE THROWERS.
A REMADE BULLPEN.
A LOT OF GUYS AUDITIONING FOR
ROLES IN 2022.
KYLE OVERTON WAS TREMENDOUS FOR
THE BLUE JAYS, SIX UP, SIX DOWN.
IF YOU'RE DAVE MARTINEZ, YOU
COULD FIND GUYS TO THROW STRIKES
IN THE SEVENTH, EIGHTH INNING.
WE HAVE SEEN THEM STRUGGLE WITH
STRIKE ZONE COMMAND TONIGHT.
SCOTT: SANCHEZ AT SECOND BASE
TAKING LUIS GARCIA'S SPOT.
SANCHEZ IS A BASEBALL PLAYER.
FUNDAMENTALLY SOUND.
HERNANDEZ STAYS ALIVE.
DAN P.: BREAKING BALL 87 MILES
AN HOUR.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT EARLIER.
TWO THINGS THAT CAN DAMAGE
COMING OUT OF THE BULLPEN, WALKS
AND HOME RUNS.
MAKES IT EASY FOR THE NATS.
SOME FREE PASSES IN THE EIGHTH
INNING INTO THE THIRD INNING.
MADE EASIER, FAVORABLE COUNTS.
THE NATS, GIVE THEM CREDIT.
SCOTT: IN THE AIR TO RIGHT FOR
SOTO.
CHASING AND WON'T GET TO IT.
MAYBE A LITTLE SCRAPE ON THE
HANDS.
DAN P.: SEE IF JUAN CAN FIND
SOMEBODY JUST TOSS THE BALL UP
TO.
LONG WAY TO GO.
IF YOU ARE, YOU CRINGE WHEN YOU
HAVE A PLAYER LIKE THAT GOING
TOWARD THE FOUL LINE.
THEY DON'T RUN INTO THE WALL,
DAMAGE AND ANKLE OR KNEE.
ESPECIALLY A GAME LIKE THIS.
SCOTT: THE HAND HELPS AS AN
EMERGENCY BREAK BEFORE HE WENT
TO THE WALL.
THIS ONE IS ON THE GROUND.
A CHANCE FOR TWO.
KIEBOOM TO SANCHEZ, HOOKING UP
WITH BELL.
THEY WILL RETIRE BOTH GUERRERO
AND HERNANDEZ.
THE NATS ARE ONE OUT AWAY FROM
PICKING UP A W TONIGHT.
DAN P.: GOOD THINGS HAPPEN ON
THE STRIKE ZONE.
THEY CONTINUE TO MAKE GOOD
PITCHES.
5-4-3 DOUBLE PLAY AND OF THE
NATS ONE OUT AWAY FROM PICKING
UP A WIN OVER THE BLUE JAYS.
SCOTT: THIS WOULD BE A NICE PICK
ME UP FOR KLOBOSITS.
A WOBBLY APPEARANCE SUNDAY
AGAINST ATLANTA.
SOME WILD PITCHES, A WALK.
ONE INNING HE GAVE UP ONE EARNED
RUN.
NOW FACING DICKERSON.
DAN P.: YOU SEE A BIG, TALL GUY.
GOOD SINKING ACTION.
COULD BE DIFFICULT FOR GUYS AS
BIG AS HIM TO COMMAND THE STRIKE
ZONE.
A LONG WAY COMING DOWN THE
MOUNTAIN, BUT UNDER CONTROL.
A GOOD FASTBALL DOWN THE MIDDLE.
IF YOU WATCH HIM, EVEN THOUGH HE
IS A BIG GUY, DOES NOT FALL OVER
TOWARD FIRST BASE.
HE TAKES THE CHIN TO THE CHEST
TOWARD HOME PLATE, MAKES IT
EASIER TO COMMAND THE STRIKE
ZONE.
IF YOU ARE DAVE MARTINEZ, YOU
HAVE TO LIKE WHAT YOU SEE.
EVEN THOUGH IT IS A BLOWOUT
GAME, THE NINTH INNING IS THE
NINTH INNING.
A HIGH CHOPPER FROM VLAD TO
START THE INNING OFF.
HE HAS CONTINUED TO POUND THE
STRIKE ZONE.
THE NATIONALS ONE STRIKE AWAY
FROM WINNING GAME 51 ON THE
YEAR.
SCOTT: THE NATS HAVE LOST 12-13
GAMES.
IT HAS BEEN A SLIDE SINCE ALL
THOSE GAMES AT THE DEADLINE.
DAN P.: IF YOU ARE THE BLUE
JAYS, THERE IS CAUSE FOR
CONCERN.
THE YANKEES SWEPT THE
DOUBLEHEADER THIS AFTERNOON.
THEY WON THE OPENER 5-3.
THEY WON  THE NIGHT CAP2-0.
IF YOU ARE THE BLUE JAYS, IT
MAKES THIS GAME VERY IMPORTANT.
THE JAYS HEAD HOME FOR A
HOMESTAND WHERE THEY HOST THE
TIGERS AND THE WHITE SOX.
SCOTT: THE YANKEES ARE PICKING
UP STEAM AND HAVE A LOT OF
PLAYERS COMING BACK.
DAN P.: GERRIT COLE WAS GOOD
COMING OFF THE IL.
NINE STRIKEOUTS THROWING 98 TO
100.
BULLPEN COMING THROUGH.
YANKEES ARE GETTING TOGETHER AT
THE RIGHT TIME.
WE TOUCHED ON IT EARLIER.
BIG TRADES HAVE TURNED THE TEAM
AROUND.
SCOTT: 3-2.
WE WILL GET INTO THAT A.L. EAST
AND THE WILD-CARD.
POSTGAME SHOW COMING UP RIGHT
HERE ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY
SPOTIFY.
WE WILL CHAT WITH A COUPLE
PLAYERS AFTERWARD AS WELL.
JAYS DOWN BY SIX IN THE NINTH.
ON THE GROUND AND THIS SHOULD DO
IT.
GAME OVER.
NATIONALS TAKE IT 12-6, IN D.C.
BIG NIGHT FOR THE NEW BE RILEY
ADAMS.
BEHIND THE PLATE.
OF COURSE, A SINGLE, DOUBLE, A
HOMER AND A GOOD SHOT AT TAKING
HOME YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
HONORS.
YADIEL HERNANDEZ WITH A GOOD
CHANCE AS WELL.
NATIONALS IMPROVED TO 51-68 ON
THE SEASON.
THE JAYS DROPPED TO 53-65.
READY FOR THE POSTGAME SHOW?
DAN P.: LET'S DO IT.
SCOTT: DAN CALLED FOR IT.
TUESDAY NIGHT, POSTGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY SPOTIFY.
THREE HOURS, 25 MINUTES.
FINAL SCORE OF 12-6.
DAVE MARTINEZ AND HIS BALLCLUB,
A VERY STRONG CLUB, JUST -- BOTH
SQUADS HAD YESTERDAY OFF.
THEY DROPPED THE FIRST OF A TWO
GAME INTERLEAGUE AFFAIR.
WE HAD STRONG HITTING
PERFORMANCES FROM THE NATS
LINEUP SHOWING A BIG WITH 12
RUNS THIS EVENING.
FOR AS MUCH AS WE GUSH OVER THE
BLUE JAYS STARTING NINE AND
RIGHTFULLY SO WITH ALL-STARS AT
THE TOP OF THE ORDER, I STILL
SEE JUAN SOTO THERE.
JOSH BELL DO BIG THINGS WITH THE
BAT.
HE HAS POTENTIAL.
SO DOES CARTER KIEBOOM.
THEN THERE IS YOUR YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
RILEY ADAMS HAD THE NIGHT OF HIS
LIFE SO FAR IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
DAN P.: HE DID.
A BIG THREE RUN NIGHT.
EIGHT ROWS DEEP.
BIG NIGHT FOR RILEY ADAMS AND A
BIG NIGHT FOR THE NATIONALS.
A CURLY W IN THE BOOKS FOR THE
NATS.
SCOTT: A BIG HIT AS A BIG
LEAGUER.
HE TAKES 58% OF THE VOTE.
TROPHY COMING HIS WAY.
NAME WILL BE ENGRAVED ON IT.
DAN P.: I HOPE YOU ARE NOT
BLAMING ME FOR SWAYING THE
AUDIENCE.
A BIG NIGHT FOR RILEY.
SCOTT: YOU TELL US WHEN THE
POSTGAME SHOW STARTS.
YOU NAME THE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
THE CROWD AGREES WITH YOU.
HE JOINS US FOR OUR SPOTIFY
INTERVIEW, THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF
THE GAME, RILEY ADAMS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THE HOME RUN IN THE FOURTH, TAKE
US THROUGH THAT.
RILEY: THANK YOU, GUYS.
FACING A TEAM I WAS ON, I KNOW A
LOT OF THESE PITCHERS.
THORNTON WAS THROWING ME A LOT
OF BREAKING BALLS.
I WAS ABLE TO WORK THE 3-2.
HE LEFT TO THE PITCH UP AND I
WAS ABLE TO MISS.
FELT GOOD, ABLE TO GET A GOOD
TEAM WIN.
DAN P.: CONGRATS.
COULD YOU HOLD THE TROPHY UP?
YOU HAD A CHANCE.
YOU KNOW THE BLUE JAYS.
HOW DIFFICULT IS IT TO NAVIGATE
THIS BLUE JAYS LINEUP?
RILEY: YOU SEE THE NUMBERS, THEY
HAVE A GREAT TEAM, GREAT
BATTERS, GREAT LINEUP.
IT IS CHALLENGING TO NAVIGATE.
CREDIT TO OUR OFFENSE, TOO.
WE PUT UP A GOOD SHOWING
TONIGHT.
SCOTT: YOU ARE THE BIG MAN THIS
WEEK FOR THE NATIONALS.
YOU ARE JUST WITH THIS
ORGANIZATION.
HOW DID IT HELP YOUR GAME
PLANNING AT THE PLATE?
HOW MANY CONVERSATIONS HAVE YOU
HAD WITH TEAMMATE SAYING, WHAT
IS THIS GUY LIKE?
RILEY: THERE IS A LOT.
I HAVE BEEN WITH THE BLUE JAYS
FOR A WHILE.
I KNOW A LOT ABOUT THOSE GUYS.
I WAS TRYING TO HELP OUT OUR
TEAMMATES.
I WAS TRYING TO DO AS MUCH AS I
COULD HELP THESE GUYS, THERE ARE
A LOT OF NEW RELIEVERS ON THE
STAFF.
SCOTT: -- DAN P.: A HOT, MUGGY
NIGHT LIKE THIS, YOU ARE
SWEATING LIKE YOU RUN A
MARATHON.
HOW TOUGH IS IT?
IT IS VERY HUMID TONIGHT.
RILEY: SOME HUMIDITY, I START
SWEATING QUITE A BIT.
SCOTT: DID YOU KNOW WHEN HE HIT
IT IT WAS GONE?
DAVE MARTINEZ SPOKE TO US ON THE
FACT YOU HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
SHORTENING UP THE BAT.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENS TONIGHT.
RILEY: K-LONG HAS BEEN GREAT.
TALKING WITH DAVEY, HE IS TRYING
TO SIMPLIFY EVERYTHING, MAKE IT
AS SHORT AS POSSIBLE.
SCOTT: -- DAN P.: WE MARVEL AT
JUAN SOTO.
ISN'T IT AMAZING TO WATCH WHAT
HE DOES WITH A BAT IN HIS HAND?
RILEY: ABSOLUTELY.
HE IS ONE OF THE BEST FOR A
REASON.
IT IS IMPRESSIVE TO WATCH.
I AM TRYING TO LEARN AS MUCH
INFORMATION.
I AM STILL LEARNING.
I AM STILL GETTING USED TO THESE
GUYS.
IT IS FUN WATCHING THEIR DAILY
GRIND.
JUAN SOTO IS SPECIAL.
SCOTT: DO YOU HAVE THE PRIZE?
RILEY: THIS THING IS HEAVY.
SCOTT: THAT MEANS IT IS WORTH
SOMETHING.
YOU DID A LOT OF WORK TONIGHT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
GOOD LUCK THE REST OF THE
SEASON.
DAN P.: GO GET A SHOWER AND GET
CLEANED UP, BIG BOY.
SCOTT: RILEY ADAMS WITH US ON
THE POSTGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY
SPOTIFY.
THE NATS PICK UP A W.
THEY DOUBLE UP THE BLUE JAYS BY
A FINAL SCORE OF 12-6.
ABE WOULD APPROVE.
MUCH MORE TO GO ON THE POSTGAME
SHOW INCLUDING HIGHLIGHTS FROM
THIS ONE.
♪
>> THAT IS SOME SERIOUS SWAG.
>> DID YOU SEE THAT?
>> MAKE SURE YOU RETURN THAT
TUPPERWARE TO ME.
♪
>> MAKE SURE YOU RETURN THIS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THE SECRET TO BEING AN
ALL-STAR?
GRANDMA'S COOKING.
♪
SCOTT: HOT NIGHT IN D.C.
SAME STORY FOR THE NATIONALS
BATS.
THEY PUT UP 12.
HOW DID IT HAPPEN?
WE ARE HERE FOR YOU.
THIS IS THE 33-YEAR-OLD ROOKIE
FROM CUBA.
YADIEL HERNANDEZ.
HE CONNECTS ON THE 0-2.
DRIVES IT TO DEEP RIGHT AND IT
IS GONE.
YADIEL HERNANDEZ MUSCLES UP ON
AN 0-2 PITCHED UP AT THE
NATIONALS UP FIRST.
HIS MANAGER SAID HE HAD SNEAKY
POP AND HE HAD IT JUST OVER THE
WALL.
VICTOR ROBLES WAS JUST HIT BY A
PITCH.
THAT WILL MOVE UP RILEY ADAMS TO
SECOND.
ESCOBAR WILL FIND OPEN SPACE AND
HE COMES THROUGH.
ADAMS, COME ON DOWN.
ROBLES, COME ON DOWN.
ALEK MANOAH LABORING AS THE
NATIONALS SEEM TO HAVE CRACKED
THE CODE.
YADIEL HERNANDEZ HOMERED OFF
MANOAH.
A TOUGH PLAY FOR BICHETTE.
IN COMES ESCOBAR AND SOTO WILL
SCORE.
NOT IN TIME.
BELL IS IN THERE.
YADIEL HERNANDEZ HAS DRIVEN IN
THREE TO MAKE IT 5-1 NATIONALS.
DAN P.: GOOD JOB BY JOSH BELL
BEING AGGRESSIVE.
SCOTT: THAT ONE SALES AWAY.
THAT WILL SCORE ANOTHER RUN.
JOSH BELL WILL RUN HOME.
MANOAH UNRAVELING IN THE THIRD
AND GIVING UP A CAREER-HIGH SIX
RUNS TONIGHT.
7-1, WASHINGTON.
RILEY ADAMS IS 1-1.
RILEY ADAMS, GO LONG.
HE MUSCLES UP FOR A SOLO SHOT.
8-1, WASHINGTON.
SECOND OF THE SEASON FOR ADAMS
WHO WAS PICKED UP IN A TRADE FOR
THE BLUE JAYS.
VLADDY WALKS A SECOND TIME
TONIGHT.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ SWINGING ON
THE FIRST PITCH, DRIVING DEEP TO
CENTER.
A LOT OF LIFT AND IT IS GONE.
TEOSCAR CONTINUES TO LIGHT UP
THE BASEBALL.
HE MAKES IT 8-3.
THIRD STRAIGHT GAME WITH A HOMER
FOR HERNANDEZ.
THE COMEBACK WAS TEMPORARILY ON.
THIS BLUE JAYS TEAM LOADED UP
THE BASES.
BRANDON FINNEGAN TRIES TO SAVE
THE DAY.
ESPINAL BRINGING HOME ANOTHER
ONE.
DAN P.: THIS COULD HAVE BEEN A
6-4-3 DOUBLE PLAY.
FINNEGAN WAS ABLE TO GET OUT OF
THE INNING.
A MISSED PLAY BY GARCIA.
IT LOOKED LIKE THE BLUE JAYS
WERE IN BUSINESS.
BULLET UP THE MIDDLE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN IT IS 8-6 AND
HERE ARE THE BLUEBIRDS.
THIS WAS REALLY A GOOD PITCH.
THIS WAS THE BIGGEST OUT OF THE
GAME, MARCUS SEMIEN POPS IT TO
RIGHT FIELD.
BO BICHETTE HITS A BULLET FOR A
FORCED OUT.
THE POP UP OF SEMIEN WAS THE
GAME.
SCOTT: THE BLUE JAYS WISH THEY
PICKED UP ANOTHER RUN OR TWO.
RYAN ZIMMERMAN COULD NOT GO THE
WHOLE WAY WITH THE BASES LOADED.
THAT WAS GOOD ENOUGH TO SCORE
JUAN SOTO ON A SAC FLY, THEN
RILEY ADAMS BROKE IT OPEN.
DAN P.: HE HIT THE BULLET DOWN
THE LEFT-FIELD LINE.
CARTER KIEBOOM SCORING IN, THAT
WAS ABOUT ALL SHE WROTE FOR THE
NATS.
SCOTT: KLOBOSITS AGAINST COREY
DICKERSON.
WHAT DO THEY CALL THAT W?
DAN P.: THAT IS A CURLY W IN THE
BOOKS.
WIN 51 FOR THE NATS.
SCOTT: 12-6 IS YOUR FINAL SCORE.
PROPS TO YADIEL HERNANDEZ.
HERNANDEZ PICKING UP HIS FIFTH
HOME RUN OF THE YEAR AND HIS
CAREER.
ALSO, HIS FIRST HOME RUN OFF A
NON-FASTBALL.
DAN COCO -- KOKOL CHATTED WITH
HIM AND HIS INTERPRETER.
DAN K.: YADIEL HERNANDEZ 2-3,
BATTING AVERAGE BACKUP OVER
.300.
HE IS 33 YEARS OLD, MADE IT AS A
32-YEAR-OLD.
HE IS GETTING SIGNIFICANT
PLAYING TIME.
HE WAITED A LONG TIME FOR THIS
MOMENT.
I ASKED WHAT IT WAS LIKE.
YOU HAVE BEEN WAITING A LONG
TIME TO GET HERE TO THE MAJOR
LEAGUES AND GET CONSISTENT
PLAYING TIME.
HOW SATISFYING IS IT TO BE
PLAYING THE WAY YOU ARE RIGHT
NOW?
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> I AM EXTREMELY HAPPY, AL
FINALLY SEE IT ON THE FIELD.
I AM EXCITED ABOUT IT.
I AM HAPPY.
>> IT HAS BEEN A TOUGH STRETCH
FOR YOUR TEAM, BUT YOU SNAPPED A
SEVEN-GAME LOSING STREAK
TONIGHT.
HAVE YOU NOTICED YOUR BALLCLUB
HANDLED THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
, SEEING YOU GUYS GO WITH SOME
MORE LOSSES THAN YOU HAVE BEEN
ACCUSTOMED TO?
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> THIS VICTORY IS GREAT FOR US.
IT FEELS LIKE THE TEAM HAS BEEN
DOWN WITH THOSE TOUGH LOSSES.
FOR US TO PULL OFF THIS WIN GETS
THE TEAM EXCITED.
IT IS A YOUNG CLUB, AND WE'VE
GOT TO STAY MOTIVATED AND KEEP
WORKING.
THERE IS A LOT OF TALENT ON THIS
TEAM.
WE CAN DEFINITELY START WINNING
SOME GAMES.
IT ADDS TO THE CONFIDENCE.
WE'VE JUST GOT TO BE CONFIDENT.
WITH THAT SAID, WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO WIN A LOT OF GAMES.
>> ROSSI US.
-- GRACIAS.
>> YADIEL HERNANDEZ HAS BEEN
GREAT A -- QUITE A LEADER FOR
THE NATIONALS TEAM.
EVERYONE GRAVITATES TO HIM.
THAT WAS THE CASE IN TRIPLE-A
FRESNO, THIS YEAR AT TRIPLE-A
ROCHESTER.
BUT IN THE BIG-LEAGUE CLUB AS
WELL, YOU SEE PLAYERS COME UP TO
HIM AND PICK HIS BRAIN ON THINGS
.
HE PLAYED IN CUBA AND HAD A LOT
OF SUCCESS.
HAS TO BE INCREDIBLY SIX SADDEST
-- HAS TO BE INCREDIBLY
SATISFYING FOR HIM.
NOW HE IS GETTING PLAYING TIME
AT 33.
EVEN THOUGH THE NATIONALS ARE
NOT WHERE THEY WANT TO BE IN THE
STANDINGS, A BIG WIN TO SNAP A
SEVEN-GAME SKID AND YADIEL IS
KEY IN THAT.
SCOTT: DAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GREAT CHATTING WITH YOU.
YADIEL HERNANDEZ IS A
THROW.
WHEN THE NATS HAVE WON
BALLGAMES, THAT IS WHEN HE IS
SHOWING A BIG.
-- SHOWING UP BIG.
WHEN HE IS WITH THE BIG-LEAGUE
SQUAD, HE IS APPRECIATIVE, AND
HE IS LOVING HIS TIME WITH THE
NATIONALS, PLAYING ON AN
EVERYDAY BASIS DOWN THE STRETCH.
WE STILL HAVE MORE TO GO ON THE
POSTGAME SHOW, PRESENTED BY
SPOTIFY, AS THE NATIONALS TOPPED
THE BLUE JAYS 12-6 AT HOME.
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> MY GOODNESS.
>> THAT BALL IS CRUSHED.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT IS A GREAT PLAY.
>> TALKING ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS, THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
>> I'M MIC'ED UP.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
GOOD TO SEE YOU, MAN.
HE'S GOING TO SINK IT TO THE
RIGHT SIDE.
GO THE OTHER WAY.
MY GUY, BRO.
NOT YET.
HE'S GOT A GOOD BAT TOO.
>> DO YOU LIKE IT?
>> YEAH.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
♪
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
I GOT IT, I GOT IT!
PAPA!
MANO!
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT: THERE IS SO MUCH GOLD
THERE.
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE IS PRESENTED BY SPOTIFY,
THE EXCLUSIVE HOME OF "THE JOE
ROBING EXPERIENCE."
-- "THE JOE ROGAN
EXPERIENCE."
WE WATCHED A 12-6 NATS W, BUT WE
HAVE LISTENED TO ABSOLUTE GOLD
FROM VLADDY JR. JUST NOW.
LET'S GO TO THE CURATORS IN THE
LIVE GAME COMMENTARY SECTION.
AUSTIN SAID, VLAD JR. MIC'D UP?
YES.
THERE IS SO MUCH THERE.
FIRST, I AM THINKING ABOUT THE
A.B. WHERE HE IS TELLING HIMSELF
TO BE SMART, AND HE IS TALKING
THROUGH THE EXPERIENCE.
HOW ABOUT HIS CONVERSATION WITH
ALCIDES ESCOBAR WHERE HE SAID
WELCOME BACK?
HE HAS HAD QUITE A JOURNEY
GETTING BACK IN THE MAJOR
LEAGUES.
HE WAS TELLING HIM, I NEVER GAVE
UP.
THAT WAS GENUINE GOLD THAT WE
LOVE TO HEAR.
SPORTS GAMING UNIVERSE LETTING
US KNOW, MAN, I LOVE THE NEW
CAMS WITH THE DEPTH OF FIELD,
WHATEVER THEY ARE CALLED LOL.
MEGAN LIVED ON.
-- MEGALODON.
I KNOW THAT BECAUSE IT IS ONE OF
MY NEPHEWS.
THAT'S ONE OF MY NEPHEW'S
FAVORITE PREHISTORIC ANIMALS.
YOU THINK OF SOME OF THE
CINEMATIC EXPERIENCES WE HAVE
THANKS TO MR. MEGALODON, WE ARE
FORTUNATE.
DAN: IT MAKES YOU FEEL LIKE THE
PLAYERS ARE COMING OUT OF YOUR
SCREEN AT HOME.
THIS WAS A BIG WIN FOR THE
NATIONALS.
WE SAW A CHASE BULLPEN STRUGGLE
AGAIN.
IT WAS A REAL UNDERBELLY FOR THE
STEAM.
THEY HAVE MADE CHANGES, MADE A
COUPLE TRADES TO BRING GUYS IN.
A LITTLE BIT DISAPPOINTING FOR
MANOA.
HIS LAST START WAS SO GOOD
AGAINST THE ANGELS, I THINK ON
PAPER THIS LOOKED LIKE A GAME
THAT WAS FAVORING THE BLUE JAYS.
GIVE ERICK FEDDE A LOT OF
CREDIT.
HE WAS ABLE TO CONTAIN THE
LINEUP FOR A LOT OF INNINGS AND
GAVE THE NATIONALS A CHANCE TO
BLOW THIS UP, AND THEY DID.
SCOTT: WE SAW SOME BULLPEN
EXPERIENCES BOTH ON THE BLUE JAY
SOCIETY AND THE NATIONALS ASIDE.
ULTIMATELY, THE BLUE JAYS HAD
TROUBLE IN LATE STAGES, AND THAT
IS AT THIS POINT THE WEAKNESS
FOR TORONTO, EVEN THOUGH THEY
HAVE DONE WORK TO SHORE UP THE
OPEN.
ADAM CIMBER HAS BEEN NAILS, BUT
THAT IS STILL A SOFT SPOT.
DAN: I THINK WHAT MAKES IT SO
DIFFICULT IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE, IF YOU HAVE A WEAK
BULLPEN, THESE LINEUPS ARE SO
DEEP, PARTICULARLY IN THE A.L.
EAST, THAT IT IS DIFFICULT FOR
PITCHERS TO GET THROUGH 5, 6, 7
INNINGS, SO YOU'RE ARE GOING TO
GO THROUGH THE BULLPEN MORE.
THE LINEUPS ARE NOT AS DEEP.
THIS IS A GROWN MAN'S BASEBALL,
WHEN YOU ARE PLAYING IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE, AND IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A BULLPEN, IT WILL
SHOW.
THE BLUE JAYS' STARTING PITCHING
IS GOOD.
THEY NEED TO GET MORE LENGTH.
THEY SCORE ENOUGH RUNS.
THEY CATCH THE BALL.
THE KEY, CAN THE BULLPEN COME
THROUGH IN THE NEXT SEVEN WEEKS?
SCOTT: THE NEXT SEVEN WEEKS ARE
GOING TO BE WILD.
WE WERE HAVING FUN DURING ONE OF
THE BRAKES, LOOKING THROUGH
STANDINGS AS THE YANKEES PICKED
UP TWO WIN'S TODAY AGAINST THE
RED SOX.
OK, LOOK AT THE YANKEES GO.
LOOK AT THE RED SOX STARTING TO
CRUMBLE A BIT.
SUDDENLY THOSE TWO ARE IN THE
SAME SPOT.
DAN: THE OAKLAND A'S HAVE LIKE,
HALF A GAME LEAD ON THE RED SOX.
THE BLUE JAYS ARE FOUR GAMES
BACK OUT OF THE WILD-CARD SPOT.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
UP GROUND.
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE EASY
BECAUSE I DO NOT THINK THE RED
SOX, THE A'S, AND THE YANKEES
ARE ALL GOING TO GO INTO IS
WHEN.
JJS -- THE BLUE JAYS NEED TO
PLAY WELL OVER THE NEXT SEVEN
WEEKS.
SCOTT: IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR
SCHEDULE, THEY ARE SEVEN GAMES
OVER THE TWINS STILL.
THEY HAVE QUITE A FEW MATCHUPS
WITH THE TIGERS AND ORIOLES.
THOSE ARE THE WIN'S YOU NEED TO
PICK UP.
JUST LIKE THIS SERIES, YOU'VE
GOT TO PICK UP A GAME IF YOU'VE
GOT TWO AGAINST THE NATIONALS
WITH THE WAY THE ROSTER IS SET
UP ON THE STRETCH, SO TORONTO IS
FOUR GAMES OUT OF THE WILD-CARD
SPOT.
THE YANKEES AND THE RED SOX ARE
NOW TIED FOR THE SECOND SEED.
THE A'S HAVE THE FIRST ONE.
YOU SEE THREE TEAMS HIGHLIGHTED
ON THE LEFT SIDE OF YOUR SCREEN,
BUT ONLY TWO TEAMS MAKE IT AS A
WILDCARD IN EACH LEAGUE.
THE MARINERS WITH SOTO MORE OF A
FIGHTING CHANCE.
IT IS STILL A TWO-TEAM LEAD WITH
THE ASTROS AND A'S.
WHITE SOX COULD LOAD UP AND
MAKE SURE EVERYONE IS HEALTHY
AND THE ROTATION IS SET, THE
UPTIME.
WE WERE WITH THAT TEAM LAST WEEK
AND TONY LA RUSSA SAID YES, BUT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
PLAYING COMPETITIVE BASEBALL
TOO.
DAN: THE WHITE SOX HAVE THE
LUXURY OF HIM AND AS AN ROBERTS,
THEY DON'T HAVE TO RUSH THEM TO
-- BELOW HIM AND AS AN ROBERTS,
THEY DON'T HAVE TO RUSH TO GET
THEM BACK -- ELOY JIMENEZ AN
ROBERTS, THEY DON'T HAVE TO RUSH
TO GET THEM BACK.
MY QUESTION IS, CARLOS RENDON
HAS HAD A TERRIFIC YEAR.
HE HAS SKIPPED THE START, HAS
INFLAMMATION IN HIS SHOULDER.
DALLAS KEUCHEL HAS BEEN ONE
GOOD, ONE BAD.
LANCE LYNN AND DYLAN CEASE HAVE
BEEN VERY GOOD FOR THE WHITE
SOX, BUT THIS AMERICAN LEAGUE IS
GOING TO BE INTERESTING, AND THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE WEST IS GOING TO
BE WILD.
SCOTT: LET'S FLIP IT TO THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE SIDE, BECAUSE
THE GIANTS LEAD THE CHARGE
STILL, AND THEY ARE FOUR GAMES
BETTER THAN L.A., 11 UP NOW ON
SAN DIEGO.
THAT IS THE LEAD FOR THE GIANTS
OVER THE PADRES CLUB THAT MANY
EXPECTED TO BE BETTER THAN SAN
FRANCISCO.
MILWAUKEE SITTING PRETTY IN THE
CENTRAL.
WE WILL HAVE THE BREWERS ON THE
SCHEDULE A COUPLE TIMES, ONCE
AGAINST THE GIANTS, ON OUR
YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK, AND
ONCE AGAINST THE CARDINALS ALL
THE WAY IN SEPTEMBER.
THE BRAVES HAVE TAKEN COMMAND OF
THE EAST, TWO GAMES UP ON PHILLY
.
THE METS CONTINUE TO SLIDE IN
THAT DIFFICULT STRETCH.
MY FATHER IS A BIG METS FAN.
HE CALLED ME YESTERDAY AND GOES,
HOW DOES IT WORK OUT WHERE THEY
SUDDENLY PLAY 13 AGAINST THE
GIANTS AND DODGERS?
THE SCHEDULE WAS MADE A WHILE
BACK, AND THE GIANTS WERE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE THIS GOOD, SO YOU
DID NOT LOOK AT IT AND THINK
THIS IS GOING TO BE SO DIFFICULT
FOR THE METS, AND THEY HAD
CHANCES TO GRAB A BIG LEAD IN
THE DIVISION AND IT NEVER
HAPPENED, AND THAT THEY ARE
LOOKING UP.
DAN: THE MAJOR DANGER, LOOK OUT
FOR THE CINCINNATI REDS.
JOEY VOTTO IS PLAYING WITH FIRE.
THERE BULLPEN IS MUCH BETTER.
ON THE NEGATIVE, JESSE WINKER
WHEN ON THE I.L.
THEY THINK YOU WILL BE BACK IN
10 DAYS.
THE PADRES ARE ONLY TWO GAMES UP
ON THE WILD-CARD WITH THE
CINCINNATI REDS, AND THE REDS
HAVE A.
FAVORABLE SCHEDULE GOING DOWN
THE STRETCH.
THE PADRES HAVE A DIFFICULT
SCHEDULE.
SCOTT: THEY ARE IN THE MIDST OF
A DIFFICULT PART OF THE
SCHEDULE, THE PADRES, AND THEY
HAVE NOT TAKEN ADVANTAGE.
THEY HAD A WALKOFF LOSS
YESTERDAY FOR COLORADO -- TO
COLORADO.
IT HAS BEEN A PROBLEM.
DAN: THEIR STARTING PITCHING HAS
NOT BEEN GOOD.
LIKE SNELL HAS HAD A COUPLE
STARTS, YU DARVISH ON THE I.L..
THAT IS HOW DESPERATE RIGHT NOW
PADRES ARE FOR STARTING
PITCHING.
IS JAKE ARRIETA THE ANSWER?
I DON'T KNOW, BUT HE IS BETTER
THAN ANYTHING ELSE THEY HAVE
BEEN RUNNING.
IT HAS BEEN A DISAPPOINTING
SEASON TO THIS POINT, EVEN
THOUGH TATIS HAS BEEN ONE
SHINING STAR.
I THINK THE PADRES THOUGHT THEY
WOULD BE WHERE THE GIANTS ARE
AT, AND THEY ARE ON THE OUTSIDE
LOOKING IN.
SCOTT: THAT IS RIGHT, AND
LUCKILY THEY HAVE FERNANDO TATIS
JR. BACK, BUT AS YOU CAN SEE,
THERE IS STILL A LOT OF WORK FOR
US TO DO HERE ON YOUTUBE.
DAN, IT WAS GREAT TO HAVE YOU IN
THE BALLPARK.
DAN: GETTING IT NICE TO BE IN
THE BALLPARK?
A BEAUTIFUL BALLPARK, NATIONALS
BALLPARK.
IF YOU HAVE NEVER BEEN, GET HERE
TO SEE IT.
SCOTT: WE WILL BE IN HOUSTON
NEXT WEEK FOR A ROYALS AT ASTROS
GAME THAT COULD REALLY SWING THE
BAT.
MARINERS AND ASTROS IN PLAYOFF
CONTENTION ON THE EIGHTH OF
SEPTEMBER.
THEN WE HAVE THE A'S AND ANGELS,
AND OAKLAND IS JUST TWO GAMES
BACK OF FIRST PLACE HOUSTON.
WE WILL FINISH UP WITH THE
CARDINALS AND BREWER'S.
THE BREWERS ARE IN CONTROL OF
THE DIVISION IN THE CENTRAL, BUT
THE CARDINALS ARE NOT OUT OF IT.
THEY HAVE A SHOT.
JACK FLAHERTY IS BACK.
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE EASY, BUT
IT IS DOABLE.
JIM: --
DAN: AND NOLAN ARENADO IS
STARTING TO HIT HOME RUNS, ALONG
WITH PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT.
MIGHT BE TOO LITTLE, TOO LATE.
SCOTT: THE NATIONALS TAKE IT
12-6 OVER THE BLUE JAYS.
WE WILL SWING BACK ON WEDNESDAY.
WE WILL SEE YOU ON THE 25TH OF
AUGUST FOR A MATCHUP IN HOUSTON,
TEXAS.
COVERAGE BEGINS WITH OUR PREGAME
SHOW AT 1:30 EASTERN.
WE WILL SEE YOU THEN.
FOR OUR ENTIRE CREW, I'M SCOTT,
LOGGING OUT FOR NOW.
WE WILL SEE YOU NEXT TIME ON
YOUTUBE.
♪